ALL RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE HEARING.
WANT TO BEGIN BY WELCOMING OUR
NEWEST ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE WERE DELIGHTED TO HAVE
YOU. AND I GOING TO DO SOME OF
OUR- OUR DISCLAIMERS AS WE DO IS
ALWAYS SO WE CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN
THE HEARING ROOM SO ONLY A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE MAY
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN PLEASE NOTE THAT AB TWO
FOUR EIGHT EIGHT. AB TWO EIGHT
TWO SIX AND AB TWO NINE SIX
EIGHT HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM THIS
HEARING AND THEY WILL NOT BE
TAKEN UP TODAY. ADDITIONALLY THE
FOLLOWING BILLS HAVE BEEN
APPROVED FOR CONSENT. AB
EIGHTEEN OH SIX AB TWO ZERO ZERO
ONE. AB TWO ONE THREE FIVE AB
TWO ONE NINE ZERO AB TWO THREE
FIVE FIVE. AB TWO THREE SEVEN
ZERO A. B. TWO FOUR EIGHT SIX.
AB TWO SEVEN FIVE ZERO AND AB
TWO SEVEN EIGHT ONE. AND I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE ARE STILL
WAITING. ON A FEW MEMBERS.
FINALLY IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE A VERY FULL AGENDA
TODAY. AND AS THE ASSEMBLY WE
HAVE EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND FOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT ME INCLUDED TALKING OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE.
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE
ALLOTTED TIME. IF IN AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP IN WARN THEM THAT CONTINUED
DISTRAUGHT AS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WANT TO DOCUMENT ON
THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
DISRUPTIVE CONTACT. I AM A
TEMPORARY RECESSED THE HEARING.
IF THE CONDUCT IS NOT STOP I
WILL REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF
SERGEANTS IN A SUPPORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL. THANK CORPORATION
AND WE CAN NOW TURN TO THE ITEMS
BEFORE US. TODAY I'M FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WITNESSES MAY TESTIFY.
BY PHONE OR IN PERSON. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. YOU CAN
OFTEN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE RELEVANT. GETTING
THEIR PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE.
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. YOU FOR BEING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WITH THE WAY WE CAN NOW
TURN TO THE BILLS BEFORE US
TODAY- MISTER RAMOS HAS ASKED
FOR SEND AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO FIRST THIS AFTERNOON SINCE
THE BILL WILL BE TAKING UP FOR
PRESENTATION ONLY. AND HE'S SUCH
A NICE GUY THERE WAS NO WAY WE
COULD SAY NO TO HIM SO THE
COMMITTEE IS. DELIGHTED TO
WELCOME MISTER RAMOS. ALTHOUGH
WE WILL NOT HAVE A VOTE ON THE
BILL MYSTERON MOST WELCOME.
BUT YEAH. THANK YOU I'M- GERMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO IT IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE SEEING IN OUR COMMUNITIES-
RETAIL THEFT- WOMEN ALL ACTIVITY
SHOOTING IN THE USE OF- VLR- B.
L. PR LICENSE PLATE READERS. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO WOULD
PROVIDE THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CAN SHARE A
LPR DATA WITH OUT OF STATE OR
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO LOCATE A VEHICLE OR PERSON
RESPONSIBLY SUSPECTED OF BEING
INVOLVED IN THE COMMISSION OF A
CRIME. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A. L. P. R. DATA HAS
PROVEN TO BE USEFUL AND
SUCCESSFUL A SUCCESSFUL TOOL
WHEN IT COMES TO INVESTIGATING
CRIMES AND IDENTIFYING OR
EXCLUDING SUSPECTS SUCH AS
RECENTLY. IN THE CITY OF
VICTORVILLE A NINE YEAR OLD GIRL
WAS SHOT. AND THE PERSON THAT.
SHOT THE NINE YEAR OLD GIRL FLED
AND WASN'T FOUND IN NEVADA IN
ANOTHER STATE THAT'S THE REASON
WHY I INTRODUCED THIS BILL. ALSO
TO ADDRESS RETAIL THEFT THAT HAS
BECOME A COMMON DAY OCCURRENCE-
WITHIN OUR LOCAL AREAS. THAT WE
COULD ACTUALLY START TO GIVE UP
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THE TOOLS
TO CURB THESE ISSUES THESE
ISSUES THAT WE SEE THAT VIOLENT
CRIMES CONTINUE TO- MOVE FORWARD
IN A LOT OF OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
THE RISE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ADDITIONALLY A BIG REASON TO
MOVE FORWARD FOR ME. TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS BILL WAS ALSO
THE CASES OF INVOLVING MISSING
AND MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN THAT MANY TIMES AS
PERPETRATORS HELPED LEAD ACROSS
STATE LINES. AND STILL MANY OF
THOSE CASES GO UNSOLVED SO BEING
ABLE TO USE THE TOOLS AND TO ADD
ADEQUATELY EQUIPPED LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE THEM
IS THE MAIN PREMISE OF THIS
BILL. EXISTING LAW GOVERNING THE
USE OF A LPR DATA ATTEMPTS
ATTEMPTS TO STRIKE A BALANCE
WITH THOSE- AND THE LAWS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
TO START TO TALK ABOUT BALANCE
OF WHERE WILL. BE WITH LONG. IN
THE TOOL TO AND THE OUR
COMMUNITY HAS SAY. CERTAINLY
MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN'S HAVE HAVE BEEN
GOING ON FOR SO MANY YEARS THAT
NOW IT'S RISE TO THE LEVEL
ADVOCACY BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
EQUIPPED WITH THE TOOLS ARE
AVAILABLE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
BRING CLOSURE TO THOSE BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO START TO TALK ABOUT
A BALANCE HERE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE A BALANCE THAT WILL
PROTECT. OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE
PRIVACY RIGHTS OF ISSUES AND
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE AS WELL AS
PROVIDING A SAFETY ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND RESOLVING CRIMES ARE
AFFECTED SO MANY OF US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO FIND THAT BALANCE
IF THERE'S A BALANCE TO BE FOUND
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
PUT PEOPLE AROUND THE TABLE TO.
TALK ABOUT AND HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WHILE PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THE INDIVIDUALS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW ENFORCED BILITY TO
COMMUNICATE AND SHARE RESOURCES
TOWARDS THE GOAL OF PROTECTING
THE PUBLIC. AND HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
THAT'S THE MAIN GOAL THAT WE SET
OUT. TO ACCOMPLISH THROUGH THIS
BILL IT WAS NEVER OUR INTENTION
TO CREATE A BILL THAT CIRCUMVENT
IT THE WILL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PUT UNNECESSARY.
PAUL IN HARM'S WAY WE BELIEVE IN
THE LAWS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PROTECTION OF
PRIVACY BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
CRIMES SHOULD BE ABLE TO. PEOPLE
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
THEY'RE MOVING FORWARD AND
GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT THE TOOL
TO BE ABLE TO BE A QUIPPED TO
BRING TO SPEEDILY- THE
CONVICTION OF THOSE THATARE
THERE AND TO SAVE VICTIMS RIGHTS
OUT THERE FROM CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. OUR GOAL TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD- WE MOVED
IT OUT OF TRANSPORTATION WE TOOK
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS SEVERAL
MEMBERS THAT WE BELIEVE STARTED
TO MOVE THE PENDULUM TO THAT
BALANCE TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE MADE TO THE
BILL WERE IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
OPPOSITION CONCERNS WE HAVE IT
CLEAR THAT THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CANNOT
SHARE. THIS DATA WITH STATES
THAT ARE IN DIRECT VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA VALUES OR HAVE STRICT
LAWS AGAINST WOMEN'S RIGHTS. WE
HAVE MET WITH OPPOSITION TO
STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL CONTINUE
AND COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH THEM TO FIND THAT BALANCE
THAT BALANCE THAT SHOWS THAT
WHEN SOMEBODY DOES PERPETRATE A
CRIME LIKE A NINE YEAR OLD
GETTING SHOT NAY FLEE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. ND ALSO FOR THOSE AT
THE CONTINUE TO IMPACT MISSING
AND MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN WITH THOSE CASES ARE STILL
THE HIGHEST THE HIGHEST OF
UNSOLVED TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
RESOURCE AND TOOL IS AVAILABLE
TO THE FAMILIES THE FAMILIES IS
STILL LOOK FOR CLOSURE FOR THAT
CRIME THAT'S BEEN PERPETRATED
AGAINST THEM. WE WILL WORK HARD
TO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TO FIND THAT BALANCE TO FIND
THAT BALANCE MOVING FORWARD AND
TO BRING BACK A BILL THAT MEETS
THAT BALANCE NOW IS THE TIME
THAT WE START TO WE HAVE TO
START TO DISCUSS. THE BALANCE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE STATE LEGISLATURE ON
ISSUES LIKE THIS ONE THAT
PROTECTS PEOPLE'S RIGHT BUT ALSO
. PERPETRATING AGAINST OUR
PUBLIC HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WANT TO FLEET-
OUT OF STATE THAT WERE ABLE TO-
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE. WITH ME
TODAY IS A COREY. SAYS HELLO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TRIMMERS COURCELLES
ALONG BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
SPONSORS THE BILL WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR BRING THE BILL
FORWARD IN THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEEHEARING A BILL WORKING
WITH US MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE- WORKING WITH US TO
SEE IF THERE IS A PATH FORWARD-
OUR GOAL IS TO AS THE AUTHOR
SAID WAS TO ENSURE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HAS THE TOOLS TO
FIGHT AND SOLVE CRIMES MURDER
KIDNAPPING ORGANIZED CRIMES-
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENSES OUR
TENT HAS NEVER BEEN TO
FACILITATE ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS-
AND PROPOSALS THAT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- THAT WE HOPE THAT THAT'S
EVIDENCED BY THE AMENDMENTS-
WE'VE TAKEN THUS FAR TO THE
BILL- WE KNOW THE BILL IS GONNA
MOVE FORWARD TODAY- BUT WE- YOU
KNOW AS THE OTHER SIDE- WITH.
WORKING WITH EVERYONE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ALL MEMBERS THAT BOTH
HOUSES STAKEHOLDERS- SO WE CAN.
BALANCES THE- THE NEEDS OF LAW.
TO SOLVE CRIMES AND KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE BUT ALSO TO. PROTECT
PRIVACY SO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR ON HIS STAFF AND THANK
YOU THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
ROBERTS AND THANK YOU TO THE-
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
MISTRUSTED TO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES AND SUPPORT. ON
THE PHONE AND WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE QUEUING UP THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN THIS CASE WE'RE GOING TO
TURN TO THE PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE HAVE TO BOTH OF
WHOM ARE ON THE PHONE IN THE
FIRST WE HAVE IS TRACY ROSENBERG
FROM OAKLAND PRIVACY. ARE YOU
THERE. YEAH WHAT I AM THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE TEN
MEMBERS I WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF
SINCE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO IS NOT
TODAY MY NAME IS TRACY ROSENBERG
AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE PRIVACY WE HAVE WORKED WITH
. ALL THESE ALL OVER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ON THEIR AUTOMATED
LICENSE PLATE READER POLICIES TO
ATTEMPT TO KEEP. THE DATA SAFE
AND SECURE UNFORTUNATELY THE
CHANGES TO THE CURRENT LAW
PROPOSED IN EIGHT TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO WOULD NOT DONE THAT.
MOST OF THE SCANS COLLECTED BY
PUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
STORED IN PRIVATELY OWNED CLOUD
DATABASES. THE LARGEST BEING
MOTOROLA'S RICH. SOLUTION DATA
IS SHARED BY. ALLOWING ONE AGENT
IN THIS CASE AN OUT OF STATE
FEDERAL ONE TO QUERY. ANOTHER
AGENT. IT DIDN'T HAVE A TWENTY
ARE AUTOMATIC CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES HAVE HUNDREDS OF OTHER
AGENCIES WITH ACCESS TO THEIR
ACCOUNTS IN THE CLOUD AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY. TWO PROPOSED TO EAT
THE CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CONSTANTLY
MONITOR STATE AND- LOCAL LAWS
ACROSS. FIFTY OTHER STATE
PRODUCTOR EN EL PR SHARE EVERY
SINGLE TIME IN THE STATE PARK OR
LOCAL LAW IT'S PAST EACH EIGHT
WOULD NOT ONLY NEED TO IDENTIFY
THE PATH OF BLOOD BUT THEN. YOU
THEIR ENTIRE SHIP AND LYFT FOR
WHAT COULD BE DOZENS OF
INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
LOCATED IN THAT STATE THERE'S NO
PRACTICAL WAY FOR THEM TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY AGENCY GOES THROUGH
THIS PROCESS EVERY SINGLE TIME
AND NO PRACTICAL WAY TO INSURE
THAT THE SHARING IS IN FACT CUT
OFF BY EACH. AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT NO LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE. AND WOULD
HELP YOUR CRIME LAWS THAT WERE
PASSED IN. TWENTY FIFTEEN SEVEN
YEARS AGO. I A TIME WHEN THE- IS
ENTER THANK YOU SPELLS ON THE
SUBJECT OF REPRODUCTIVE PRIVACY
RIGHT USE MEDICAL CARE AND
SANCTUARY BILL TWENTY ONE.
NINETY TWO WHAT UNDER EACH.
EVERY ONE OF THEM IF I COULD ASK
YOUR ABOUT THAT WE BE GREAT
THANK YOU. IT MAY NOT. FOR OUT
OF. AGENCIES SERVE L. DATA
SOLELY JESUS COMPLIANT WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW CALIFORNIA POLICY
AND CAP VALUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AN APOLOGIES WE
JUST HAVE A PACKED HEARING SO
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP BY EVERYBODY
ON SCHEDULE TODAY. OUR OUR
SECOND OPPOSITION WITNESS IS
ADAM SCHWARTZ FROM THE
ELECTRONIC AND- FRONTIER
FOUNDATION OTHER EITHER. HE
ABANDONED YOU HEAR ME I CAN'T
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M ADAM SPORTS FROM
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO. EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW
PLACE IMPORTANT PRIVACY
SAFEGUARDS ON AUTOMATIC LICENSE
PLATE READERS LPARS BECAUSE THE
FALL ONLY A FIVE IN CALIFORNIA
IT BARS OUR STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES DISCLOSING THEIR LPR
DATA TO OUT OF STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO WOULD UNDERMINE THIS
PROTECTION AND ALLOW VAST
AMOUNTS OF OUR SENSITIVE
HEALTHCARE DATA TO LEAVE THE.
STATE WHERE CAN BE ABUSED. FOR
EXAMPLE KERN LAW THE OF L. P.
DATA. U. S. IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT OR ICE. THIS
IS CRUCIAL TO PROTECT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES. ASSEMBLY TWENTY
NINETEEN ACES USE LPR DATA TO
FIND AND DEPORT IMMIGRANTS. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO WOULD PUT
IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS BACK IN
HARM'S WAY. BY MARCH AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL WHICH WE APPRECIATE
THE GOOD FAITH OFFERING. WELL
THE MEMBERS REFERENCE THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES ACT THE BILL
OULD STILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA
AGENCIES THE SENDER LPR DATA TO
OUT OF STATE AGENCIES WHICH
COULD EASILY SENATE ON. ICE THE
BILL WOULD ALSO UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS A
SANCTUARY FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
ABORTIONS AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. EIGHT THE CRIMINALIZES
CARE COMMUTE CALIFORNIA LPR DATA
BY DAD TO FIGHT AND PUNISH THEIR
RESIDENTS WHO. CAME TO
CALIFORNIA FOR CARE. THE MARKET
MEN AND- TO THE TRIED TO SOLVE
THIS. BY REQUIRING CAL AGENCY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE MANY
FEDERAL AN OUT OF STATE AGENCIES
THAT SEEK THEIR LPR DATA WILL
USE THE HARMONIES GROUPS BUT IT
SIMPLY IS NOT PRACTICAL TO
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA EIGHT. TRACK
OF COMPLICATED AND EVER CHANGING
LAWS THE FORTY NINE STATES.
CONCERNING ABORTION AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE. AND AGAIN ONCE
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES SPEND THEIR
LPR DATA OUT OF STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ONLY NEEDED AROUND UP
AND- WHAT WHAT THANK YOU FOR
HEARING OUT AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ADAM
SCHWARTZ WERE NOW GOING TO TURN
ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM NEWMAN
EXFOLIATION PLACE SECOND KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SEE NO
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
TWO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CARE LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP. CARRILLO SOME
MOMENT.
THE LINE NUMBER FORTY FOUR
THAT'S FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOU ARE PROVIDED A LINE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOU'RE FREE TO SPEAK.
FIVE NO KIDDING THAT'S NORTH OF
THE PHILIPPINE RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE B. TWO ONE
NINE TWO THANK YOU. SIX LITTLE
AYE NUMBER NINETEEN THAT'S ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
ONE NINE TWO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE'RE
GONNA TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
RARE MOMENT TO TRY TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. I'M SECRETARY APRIL
PRESENT KILEY. OUR QUE EN
BENNETT BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM FONG
IRWIN. CALAVERAS WICKS HERE
WE'LL SEND HERE. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A QUORUM WITH THAT I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NONE. MR ALMOST I JUST WANT TO-
FIRST I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT- TO GIVING
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT THE TOOLS
AND THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED
I KNOW YOU AND I HAVE. SPOKEN AT
SOME LENGTH ABOUT YOUR EFFORTS
AND I KNOW. THEY ARE INTENDED
AND INSINCERE GOOD FAITH TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS THE TOOLS AND THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. TO DEAL WITH SOME
REALLY REPREHENSIBLE VIOLENT
CRIMES THINGS LIKE KIDNAPPING
AND MURDER AND OTHER THINGS THAT
CAN GO ACROSS STATE LINES THAT-
I KNOW HOW PASSIONATE YOU ARE
ABOUT A LEADER YOU'VE BEEN ON.
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
INDIGENOUS WINDOW. WOMEN AND I
THINK ALL OF US AROUND THE
COMMITTEE TABLE HERE ARE
HEARING. A LOT FROM CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY ABOUT
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY SAFE- AS
YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGE HERE IS
THAT WE HAVE. SOME STATES THAT
HAVE. PASSED WAS I THINK A LOT
OF US WANT TO BE VERY
REPREHENSIBLE- THAT THREATEN THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES. I'M COMMUNITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PART. WHETHER
THAT'S OUR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY
OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY. OF PEOPLE
SEEKING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
YOU KNOW WE ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IS YOUR LIFE
TALKING ABOUT- I THINK WE CAN DO
BOTH. AND I THINK YOU USE AN
IMPORTANT WORD HERE WHICH IS
BALANCE AND IT'S ABOUT THREADING
THAT NEEDLE. THE WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN. AFFORD TO GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS BUT ALSO. DO
SO WITH THE CONFIDENCE THAT
WE'RE DOING IT IN A NUANCED WAY
THAT IS GOING TO PROTECT PRIVACY
RIGHTS. AND THEN ALSO GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROTECTING
THE FUNDAMENTAL CIVIL LIBERTIES
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES SO. I'M
VERY COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH YOU
OVER THE COURSE OF THE FALL TO
WORK WITH YOU. I KNOW THAT OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT AS WELL- I KNOW.
HOW YOU APPROACH THIS WITH
TREMENDOUS GOOD FAITH AND THE
RIGHT INTENTIONS AND SO. I WANT
TO. DO FIRST IN THIS
CONVERSATION IT'S A REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE-
LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU- AND SO. WITHOUT YOU
KNOW THE BILL'S BEEN FOR.
FOUNDER SAYS TESTIMONY ONLY SO
WE WILL BE TAKING ABOUT- BUT I
DO WANT TO BE OPPORTUNE TO
CLOSE. AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CERTAINLY
THIS IS A TOPIC AN ISSUE THAT-
NEEDS MORE- VETTING AND DIALOGUE
AROUND. THAT WOULD- PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF THOSE. IN THE
CALIFORNIA- AND TO ENSURE THAT
THAT SAFETY AND THAT PROTECTION-
MISS FOLLOW THROUGH- THROUGHOUT.
THE UNITED STATES IN DIFFERENT
STATES THAT CHALLENGE.
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO FIND THAT BALANCE. THAT
BALANCE THAT BALANCES STRUCTURE
BRING CLOSE TO THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME. VICTIMS OF CRIME.
PERPETRATORS FLEE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE HAVE TO EQUIP
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO AFTER AND
RESOLVE THOSE CRIMES AND BRING
CLOSURE BACK TO THE FAMILIES.
SUCH JAZZ AGAIN MISSED HIM
MURDERED. NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
THAT IS HI CALIFORNIA HAS THE
SEVENTH HIGHEST STATE- WITH
MISSING AND MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN IN THE NATION. AND SO THIS
BILL IS MEANT TO- EQUAL. LONG
FORCE OF THE TWO TO SAW THESE.
WELL AT THE SAME TIME I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE- THE GREAT-
CHALLENGE IN FRONT OF US. TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE LAWS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
INDIVIDUALS COMING TO THE STATE.
ARE ARE PROTECTED BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DIALOGUE IN FALL SO THAT
WE CAN COME. BALANCE AND THEN
BRING BACK THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT EQUIPS LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WITH THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO BRING CLOSURE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR ALMOST APPRECIATE
IT APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY FROM
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION AND VERY MUCH LOOKING
FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. WITH THAT. ASK MRS
FRIEDMAN TO COME UP AND GET
READY. AND WHILE WE'RE DOING
THAT WITH TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS MOMENT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAX A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR GABRIEL
HI GABRIEL I KILEY. OUR CAYENNE.
BUYER CAN AYE BENNETT. BENNETT I
BERMAN CUNNINGHAM FONG IRWIN
FIVE- WHEN I VALLADARES
BALLADEERS I WICKS WICKS I
WILSON LISTEN HI. WITHOUT THE
CONSENT COUNTERS APPROVED WE ARE
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE ARE ALMOST
HALFWAY DONE SO WITH THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR LETTING ME PRESENT AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ANALYSIS. AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK TRIPLE A FOR WORKING
WITH US ON AMENDMENTS- AND THEY
ARE NOW TO TRY ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE WITH THEM EVERY YEAR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS DIE ON
THE ROAD IN TWENTY TWENTY MORE
THAN THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED COLOR
ONES LOST THEIR LIFE TO A CAR.
OR ONE THOUSAND WHICH WERE
PEDESTRIANS TO ALMOST A QUARTER
OF THE PEOPLE KILLED IN TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE
NOT ACTUALLY IN THE VEHICLE AND
SPEEDING IS A FACTOR IN OVER 30%
OF TRAFFIC FATALITIES XIN WIDE
ACCORDING TO THE NTSB FEEDING IS
A FACT SPEEDING IS A FACTOR IN
31% OF ALL TRAFFIC FATALITIES SO
WE WANT TO TACKLE TRAFFIC
FATALITIES WE ALSO HAVE TO. YOU
TO BE. FIRST WHICH- BROWN'S
TONIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN. TO AND-
DOWN. REDUCING AND REDUCE FATE.
BECAUSE EVERY FEW MILES AN HOUR
FASTER CARGOES THE INCREASED.
RATE OF INJURIES AND. SYSTEMATIC
REVIEW OF FOURTEEN STUDIES HAVE
SPEED SAFETY SYSTEMS IN CANADA.
EUROPE AUSTRALIA NEW ZEALAND.
FOUND THAT CRAP POUND CRASH
REDUCTIONS OF FIVE TO SEVENTY
PERCENT. INJURY REDUCTIONS OF
TWELVE TO SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND FATALITY REDUCTIONS OF
SEVENTEEN TO SEVENTY ONE
PERCENT. AT SPEED SAFETY SYSTEMS
LOCATIONS AFTER. THE SPEED
CAMERA PROGRAMS WERE
IMPLEMENTED. THIS IS WHY THE
NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
BOARD THE CENTER FOR DISEASE
CONTROL. AND NOW THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THE U. S.
CONGRESS ARE ADVOCATING. FOR
STATES TO USE SPEED CAMERAS TO
SAVE LIVES. NOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED. GIVEN THE FAILURE OF THE
OLD RED LIGHT CAMERA BILL AREN'T
WE JUST WALKING DOWN THE SAME
ROAD IN MAKING THE SAME
MISTAKES. SO WE ARE VALUE WAITED
THE RED LIGHT CAMERA PROGRAM TO
LOOK AT EVERYTHING THAT THEY DID
WRONG. AND DESIGNED THIS BILL TO
DO THE OPPOSITE. SO FOR INSTANCE
WE DESIGNED THE BILL WITH BOTH
PRIVACY AN EQUITY IN MIND. WE
SAID THAT IT THE BILL WON'T BE
PUNITIVE THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
GOING AT LEAST ELEVEN MILES AN
HOUR OVER THE SPEED LIMIT TO
EVEN GET A TICKET. UNLIKE
pREGULAR TICKETS WHICH GIVE YOU
POINT. EVERS LICENSES AND THAT
STARTED. SEVERAL HUNDRED
DOLLARS. THESE TICKETS ARE
WARNINGS FOR THE FIRST SIXTY
DAYS ONLY TO PEOPLE WHO GET THE
TICKETS. AND THEN AFTER THAT
THEY STARTED JUST FIFTY DOLLARS
AND HAVE NO POINTS AT ALL ON
PEOPLE'S LICENSES. AND PEOPLE
WHO LIVE ON. THE LINE MUST BE
OFFERED EITHER AN 80% REDUCTION
IN THAT FINE OR COMMUNITY
SERVICE. AND A PAYMENT PLAN CAP
THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND THE END. FAMILIES OF FOR
LESS THAN FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR MUST BE OFFERED A
50% REDUCTION IN FIND REMEMBER
THAT FINE STARTS AT FIFTY
DOLLARS- CAMERAS ONLY TAKE
PICTURES OF PEOPLE'S LICENSE
PLATE. AND THE PICTURES MUST BE
DESTROYED IN SIXTY DAYS UNDER
THIS BILL. AND UNLIKE A- PRC
INFORMATION CAN ONLY BE USED TO
ENFORCE SPEED LIMITS AND NOT ANY
OTHER VIOLATIONS. AND IT ALSO
PROTECTS RESIDENTS FROM USING
THESE CAMERAS FROM CITIES WHO
WANT TO PAD THEIR GENERAL FUND.
AND WE DESIGNED THE BILL SAYING
THAT THAT MONEY CANNOT GO TO
CITIES GENERAL FUND THE REVENUES
MUST GO RIGHT BACK INTO THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD TO IMPROVE SAFETY
CONDITIONS IN THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. SO IT'S REALLY
MEANT TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND LASTLY TO SHOW THAT WE'RE
NOT ABOUT THE MONEY. IF THE
SPEEDING IN THE AREA DOES NOT GO
DOWN IN OTHER WORDS IF THE
AMOUNT OF TICKETS THE CAMERA
GENERATES DOES NOT GO DOWN. THE
CAMERA MUST BE REMOVED. SO AGAIN
THESE ARE CLEARLY USED AS A
TOOL. AND YOU HAVE TO WARN
PEOPLE BEFORE THEY EVEN COME TO
THE CAMERA AND WE HAVE TO TELL
DRIVERS THAT THEY'RE COMING INTO
AN AREA WHERE SPEED ENFORCEMENT
CAMERAS USING BECAUSE AGAIN. THE
GOAL IS NOT TO ISSUE A LOT OF
TICKETS IS TO SLOW AT THE
DRIVERS DOWN. NOW THIS IS A
PILOT PROGRAM IN ONLY SIX CITIES
IN THE STATE. AND WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS THE MAYOR OF ONE
OF THE CITY'S THAT'S
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT TRYING THIS
TOOL. LISA MIDDLETON FROM THE
CITY OF PALM SPRINGS AND THEN
AFTER HER WE WILL HAVE PASTOR
PATRICIA STRONG WITH FEES PAID
FOR LA STREETS. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU. LEASE
MIDDLETON AMERISAFE A PALM
SPRINGS. AND PREVIOUSLY I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE CIGARETTE TRAFFIC
FATALITIES TASK FORCE. THAT
RECOMMENDED THAT CAMERAS BE
ADDED AS ONE OF THE TOOLS. IN
SPEED ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA.
MY CITY IS VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM. IN THE LAST YEAR
FATALITIES THROUGHOUT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. INCREASED BY
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT. AND MY
SMALL CITY LESS THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. IN THE LAST
FIFTY ONE MONTHS FORTY NINE
PEOPLE. HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES TO
TRAFFIC FATALITIES. MANY OF
THOSE PEDESTRIANS. MOST OF THOSE
AS A RESULT OF SPEEDING. EITHER
OF THE- DRIVERS SPEEDING AND-
LOSING CONTROL OR A PEDESTRIAN
OR SOMEONE ELSE DOING SOMETHING.
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT DO AND A
DRIVER DOING. DRIVING TOO FAST
TO BE ABLE. TO STOP IN TO AVOID.
HITTING THE AN INDIVIDUAL AND
CAUSING A FATALITY. WE HAVE. AN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FROM
RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT OUR CITY WE
HAD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE OUT- TWO
WEEKS AGO TO CELEBRATE- AB FORTY
THREE AND LOWERING THE SPEED
LIMITS ON THIRTY SIX SEGMENTS
BUT WHAT WAS SAID TO. US
REPEATEDLY IS LOWERING SPEED
LIMITS ARE GOOD BUT THEY'RE NOT
ENOUGH WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT WE Z.
GASTRIC ABOUT BRINGING THIS
PROGRAM TO OUR CITY. AS A SMALL
CITY THAT IS- RELATED WE WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH DIFFERENT
DEMOGRAPHIC THAN WHAT YOU WILL
FIND. THE OTHER FIVE CITIES
THEY'RE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM CAMERAS WORK AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEST IT AND WE
THINK PROVIDE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAYOR- WE APPRECIATE HAVING
UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO OUR SECOND
WITNESS PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT AND THAT IS- PASTOR
PATRICIA STRONG FARGAS. FROM
FAITH FOR SAFE STREETS I BELIEVE
IS ON THE PHONE- MISTRUST REITER. HELLO YOUR MATE YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I AM PASSED THE
PATRICIA STRONG BARGAINS. YES
THERE ARE IN THE TOP WALL STREET
THE LOWEST I'M ALSO THE COLD
CHAIR OF SACRED. AND I JUST WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT- PASTORS AT
BERRY. HARD TO MANY IN THE DAYS
FROM THE INVISIBLE DISEASE
CALLED PUBLIC. BUT ALSO WE VERY
HAVE EVEN DOING THE PANDEMIC
VERY TOO MANY INDIVIDUALS FROM
TRAFFIC COLLISIONS BECAUSE TO
SPEAK. WE ARE VISITS TO MANY
PATIENTS IN OUR REGION IN
OBSTACLE BEEN. WE GOT THE THREE
THE END RESULT SO MANY FAMILIES
WHO HAVE LOST A LOVED ONE OR
SOMEONE IN THEIR FAMILY HAS HAD
A SERIOUS INJURY FROM THE STATE
. HOW LONG ARE A QUESTION. HOW
LONG HAVE WE GOT THEY GOT THE
NUMBER HEARING OF THE NUGGETS
COLLISION ARE PROJECTS YOU ON
THE INCIDENT ARTS CYCLISTS
INJURIES DOT WOULD BE IT YEAH.
HOW FIVE. HELLO ARE WE GOING
IGNORE EFFORT THERE WE GO WERE
VERY TRIED FROM SOME SPEEDING BY
SCHOOL. OUR CHURCHES. SENIOR
CENTER. OUR EVEN THOUGH OUR NAY
IS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO ENJOY THE NEED FOR. AS
I WANTED GET IN STOCK LOSS SAID
. THERE IS NO. ENFORCEMENT AND
STOP WHAT IT. THEY STAY DRY AS
YOU WHICH- EVERY DAY. DO YOU
WANT TO SAVE A LIFE PASTOR I I'M
SORRY THERE WERE COMING ON OUR
TIME LIMIT HERE. OKAY SB TWO
THREE SIX SPEAKS CAMERAS FOLLOW
. IT OFFERS. THAT WOULD STOP THE
SPEED INCIDENTS. I JUST SUGGEST
WE IT. WHAT IT AND SAVE A LIFE
FULLY NO MORE YEAH THANK YOU SO
WITH YOU MUCH APPRECIATE
ATTACHED TO VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE ARE NOW GO TO TURN WITNESS IN
THE ROOM SUPPORT OF THERE ANYONE
IS. MISTER TERRY MEMBERS SILVIUS
LEASE BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS.
AND SUPPORT AND ALSO WANTED TO
TEST TO ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
BEVERLY THANK. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW GOING TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT MR ARE PRATER ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THREE THREE SIX. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
ON AB TWO THREE THREE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE ALREADY HAVE A FEW IN THE
QUEUE. LINE NUMBER FORTY THAT'S
FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
MARK BOOKS THAT SHE MUST BE
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH STREETS FOR
ALL. ROD ALL OF THE POPULACE OF
LAURA FRIEDMAN AND WE'RE PROUD
TO SUPPORT ITSELF THANK YOU.
EXTRALITE NUMBER SIXTY TWO THAT
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON A MISTER JOHN MEMBERS
PROGRAM ACROSS ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ANALOGY TO THE
COURT THANK YOU. GIVEN THE
GROWING NUMBER FORTY SEVEN
THAT'S FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NEED CREWS ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR THE CARDIO AND THE
ATTACKERS THAT THEY'VE BEEN I'M
SO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GROWING NUMBER SIXTY FIVE THAT'S
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NICOLE
FERRARA CALLING FROM THE CITY OF
OAKLAND DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
. NOT GONNA LIE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE THAT'S SIX THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ALI
GALLAGHER FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA FAMILIES FOR SAFE
STREETS AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. DICKS'S LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN THAT SIX SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU'RE FREE TO
SPEAK. I'M SORRY YES I MEAN
FOREVER OF IT- BUT THANK YOU.
GOOGLE HIGH NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
THAT SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO JONATHAN KATZ FROM SUPER
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FIFTY SIX AT FIVE
SIX OR ONE IS OPEN. HI THERE MY
NAME IS PUBLICATION I'M
REPRESENTING STREETS ARE FOR
EVERYONE STATE. I'M SUPPORT THIS
BILL I THANK YOU TO OUR MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AND EVERYONE FOR THEIR
INPUT ON THE STOCK. WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN CUBA LINE NUMBER SIXTY
ONE THAT SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHARGE YOUR SHOP FOR CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIR WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE TO ONE IT BELIEVES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM SO WE'RE
GONNA TURN TO BECCA. CREAMER
MATTER FROM ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. THANK YOU BACK A KRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORTS TO INCLUDE
PRIVACY IN EQUITY PROVISIONS
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE IN THE BILL
DO NOT PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
PROTECTIONS. AUTOMATED TRAFFIC
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEMS REYES
NUMEROUS PRIVACY CONCERNS. BY
ENCOURAGING THE USE OF
SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGIES FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF SPEED LIMITS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX SUBJECTS
CALIFORNIANS TO INCREASE
SURVEILLANCE AND PERPETUATES THE
FALSE NOTION. SURVEILLANCE
BENEFITS THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SURVEILLED. SALEM CAN BE
EASILY MISUSED LEADING TO THE
EROSION OF COMMUNITY TRUST AND
COSTLY LAWSUITS AS WELL AS
DISCOURAGING PEOPLE FROM GOING
ABOUT THEIR DAILY LIVES AND
THEIR CIVIL LIBERTIES. THEY NEED
FOR REDUCING SPEED RELATED
TRAFFIC COLLISIONS DOES NOT
WARRANT THE CREATION OF THE NEW
MECHANISM FOR GOVERNMENT
COLLECTION OF LARGE AMOUNTS OF
DATA ON CALIFORNIANS. THERE ARE
OTHER MEANS OF REDUCING SPEED
BASED TRAFFIC COLLISIONS THAT DO
NOT IMPLICATE PRIVACY IN EQUITY.
PUTTING THOSE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE
BILL ITSELF ROUND ABOUT SPEED
HUMPS OR SPEED TABLES TRAFFIC
CIRCLES AND OTHER TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES. YET RATHER
THAN CENTER THESE THE BALANCED
RELY ON SURVEILLANCE THE MADE IN
THIS MATTER AN INCREASED. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES COST MONEY
HOWEVER AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
SIX ALSO OF COST. INSTEAD OF
CITIES AND COUNTIES PAYING THE
BILL AB. TWENTY THIRTY. FIRST OF
ALL. FOR THE TERM INCREASE
TICKET THE AB TWENTY THIRTY
FRIGHTENS WOULD GO AGAINST
RECENT ROUGH TO CALIFORNIA'S
TICKETING LAWS TO REDUCE THE
WELL DOCUMENTED ECONOMIC HARMS
CAUSED BY MASS TICKETING
PARTICULARLY FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WOMEN OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY BLACK IN MY NEXT
WOMEN ARE ESPECIALLY LIKELY TO
SUFFER UNDER ABTWENTY THREE
THIRTY SIX BECAUSE THEY TEND TO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THE COSTS OF
CITATIONS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY INCURRED THE CITATIONS. FOR
THESE AND OTHER REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU ALMOST EXACTLY
TWO MINUTES WELL DONE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR A SECOND
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
FROM SAFE STREETS LOS ANGELES J.
NUMBER WHOSE. THANK YOU CAN YOU.
PLEASE TELL RESPECT A LOT.
PERFECT THE OFFICE REPUBLICAN
AMENDMENTS AND TO ADDRESS SOME.
HOWEVER THIS LEGISLATION STILL
TO BROADEN ONEROUS IN THE TOP
LOCATION FOR PARTS OF PORT.
EIGHTY TWO THREE THREE SIX NOT
REALLY A- FROM. AT THE PUMP
RIGHT THIS LITTLE BEHIND THE
TICKETING KAPUSO CALIFORNIA.
BYRON THERE BE MORE SPEED
CAMERAS OPERATING THE SIX DEPUTY
END ALLOW RED LIGHT CAMERAS
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. THE CITY OF LA
AMONG WOULD BE ALLOWED TO DEPLOY
UP TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY POUNDS.
HUNDRED. SO INCOME DRIVERS THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZE TO
CARRY TO BE THE- ON. WERE PER AB
PUT THREE FIFTY LIMIT HAS BEEN
REDUCED A TO TWELVE MILES PER
HOUR BELOW THE- SPEED THE
ROADWAY. IN ATHENS THE GUY WILL
HAVE BUILT UPON MAKING. DRIVERS
TO YOU'LL COME DRIVING A SECOND
. SB LIMITS WERE MILES PER HOUR
LOWER AND USE CAMERA TO TAKE
ANYONE BY THE- MY PER HOUR ABOVE
WHAT WE PEOPLE. IN OTHER WORDS
DR WILL BE. FOR HELLO THIS. THE
GOVERNMENT BILL THE ROADWAY OR
ADDRESS ALL ACTION NOT PERCENT
OF. IN THE CURRENT WILL BE. AT
THE COMMITTEE AND THE POINTS OUT
OF THEM DANGEROUS. MY CAN
NEIGHBOR. THIS IS DUE TO A STORE
THAT THE BEEN A BILL STATE
DESIGN THE COMMUNITIES. AS A
RESULT THE CAMPUS WILL BE CRIME
MERRILEES THOSE VERY. AS THE
BILL LOOKED SOME CHEN BY THE OF
THE PROMOTE INCLUDING. THE
TICKET COLLECTOR TAX BACK IN THE
- TO PAY FOR STATE IMPACT TO THE
DOCK SHOULD PREVIOUS EIGHT READ
AND- WE WILL HAVE BEEN. FIRST BY
PREVIOUS UNDERWENT. WE TO HIGHER
COUNTY RATES AND THEN BUYING.
HUNDRED OF DOLLARS IN TICKET THE
PAPER CORRECT. THAT HISTORIC
UNDER. AB. TWO THREE THREE.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX. I'M ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
THREE THREE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT ONE
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT THAT'S FIVE
EIGHT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS AND THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. GROWING
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE THAT'S FIVE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU TOWARDS THE BURKE FROM OPEN
. WE ARE STILL IN. RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF CHAIR OF MY
QUESTIONS FOR THE WITNESS IN IN
IN OPPOSITION- YOU POINTED OUT
THAT BOTH THE CAMERAS HAVE A
COST IN THE ROAD IMPROVEMENTS
THAT YOU REFER TO AS A SOLUTION
A PROBLEM HAVE A COST. BUT IT
SEEMS THAT THE ROAD IMPROVEMENTS
ARE MUCH MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
THE PUTTING IN MORE ROUNDABOUTS
ETCETERA- THEN THE VICTIM THE
CAMERA- SET UP- AND I. WE HAVE
TO TWO FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS DO
YOU THINK THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH-
ROAD IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE COULD
MAKE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF SPEEDING. IT TEARS
UP TO THE LEVEL THAT WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE NUMBER
OF PEDESTRIAN DEATHS. BUT REALLY
IS- I WOULD LOVE TO GET AN
ANSWER BUT IT'S ACTUALLY YOUR
CALL IS A LEGISLATOR YOU GOT TO
DETERMINE HOW WE SPEND MONEY AS
A STATE JUST LIKE THE LOCAL-
ELECTED WOULD HAVE DETERMINATION
OVER HOW THEY SPEND MONEY IN
THEIR BUDGET. AND SO IT'S REALLY
IT'S NOT MY CALL TO MAKE OF
WHETHER WE INVEST ENOUGH BUT I
DO THINK THAT. IF THE-
COMMITMENT WAS THERE TO INVEST
THE MONEY THAT YES IT IS
POSSIBLE. TO BUILD THE ROADS AND
IMPROVE THE ROADS SAID THAT
SPEEDING IS NOT THERE BUT IT
WOULD BE MISSED. SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION IN DEATHS. AFTER AND
THEN MY OTHER QUESTION FOR YOU
YOUR- ORIGINAL STATEMENT WAS. OF
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS DON'T JUST.
HEY THIS. IN A PRIVACY- THE THAT
YOU SEE WITH THIS AND- IS THERE
A LEVEL OF DEBT NUMBER OF DEATHS
THAT DOES JUSTIFY. THE THAT
INVASION. WHAT WOULD IT BE IS-
IS IT IF IT WAS FIVE TIMES WORSE
WITH THAT JUSTIFY. THAT WAS NOT
ACTUALLY WHAT MY STATEMENT WAS
MY STATEMENT WAS THAT THERE ARE
OTHER METHODS TO GET TO THE
POINT OF REDUCING DEATHS. THAT
DON'T HAVE THE SAME PRIVACY AND
EQUITY CONCERNS AND THAT THOSE
ARE WHAT THE LEGISLATURE. SHOULD
BE PURSUING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU AND
I WANNA AND COMMEND THE ALL FOR
HARD WORK ON THIS I THINK YOU
CAN SEE IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
SHE HAS SPENT SIGNIFICANT TIME
AND ENERGY MAKING SURE BELL A
NARROW IN ITS SCOPE BASED ON
COMMUNITIES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NOT TARGETING THAT
MAKES THAT ARE AT SO I GUESS
GIVEN THE HARD WORK SHE'S DONE
TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE
HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY COULD
SUPPORT IT- YOU ARE BALANCING
THE PRIVACY INTEREST WITH I WAS
BEING SAVED- I'M CURIOUS WHAT.
WHAT WOULD GET YOU TO THAT POINT
OR NOTHING I MEAN YOU JUST
AGAINST ALL CAMERAS. I'M WE
WOULD AT THE VERY LEAST NEED TO
SEE IF OTHER METHODS EXPLORED
THAT ARE NOT INCREASING
SURVEILLANCE BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT SURVEILLANCE COMES WITH ITS
OWN SITE IS STILL VERY POPULAR
TRYING. WHAT IS OUT THERE DOING
A GREAT. GOING OVER YOUR- YEAH-
BUT THAT THEY SURVEILLANCE COME
WITH ITS OWN AND COSTS AS WELL.
AS SO SHE NOT BE THE FIRST
PROPOSED SOLUTION THE OTHER
SOLUTIONS SHOULD BE EXAMINED
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE OTHER
VERY CLEAR SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. THANK YOU ONE I KNOW
IS CHAIR OF THIS POSITION
COMMITTEE THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY FOCUSED ON IN THIS
ISN'T THE ONLY MEANS SHE HAS
USED TO REDUCE DEATHS AND
PROTECT LIVES AND COMMUNITIES-
AND SO I THINK THIS IS A
COMMITTEE HAVING SAT ON IT FOR
YEARS. IT REALLY DOES VALUE THE
PRIVACY OF OUR TEAM MEMBERS AND
AS I YOU KNOW LOOK AT THIS BILL
AND THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND SAW THE
WAY IN WHICH SHE NARROWED THE
RETENTION OF THE DATA THE DATA
THAT WAS BEING- I THINK SHE HAS
DONE A GOOD JOB IN NARROWING-
THE PRIVACY THAT IS BEING GIVEN
UP HERE TO SAVE LIVES AND SO I
REALLY WOULD URGE THE ACLU THAT
IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN PROTECT THE PRIVACY
TO BRING THAT TO THE SOME
AMERICANS I THINK HER. INTEREST
IN DOING SO. IN THE CLEAR IN
THE- NATION STANDS TODAY BECAUSE
I THINK WE DO HAVE TO. INTEREST
BUT THE INTEREST AS SAWYER
BENNETT POINTED OUT OF SAVING
LIVES IS PARAMOUNT AND SO I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU I THINK WE HAD A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIGHT OURS. THANK YOU- SO
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THAT THIS
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS GREAT
NO OTHER MAMA FIVE YEAR OLDS-
WHO WILL NOT ALLOW HER TO PLAY
ON THE STREET OR WRITE HER BACK
ON THE STREET. I'M SORRY RIGHT.
BOB UP. CHILDREN ON BIKES THEY
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDING AND
SUPPORT THE INTENT. IT REMINDS
ME A LITTLE BIT OF THE RED LIGHT
CAMERAS THAT WERE ONCE INSTALLED
IN THE CITY OF COULD- AND THE
CITY OVER THE YEARS COLLECTED
DATA AND WHICH WOULD SAY THAT
THERE WAS A DECREASE IN
COLLISIONS. THERE WERE ALSO
INCREASING. AT ABOUT. PERCENT.
THERE WAS. A LOT OF CAN CAN
RIGHT. CAN RATHER CHRIS. THAT
WORK- IN THE MAIL- FOR THEIR
CARS BUT THEY WEREN'T
NECESSARILY DRIVING- WITH THE
CITY ULTIMATELY- PULLED OUT ALL
THE RED LIGHT CAMERAS BUT I AM.
A LITTLE WORRIED THATYOUR BILL
DOES LIMIT THE DUE PROCESS- AND
IN SPECIFICALLY. WITH TYPICAL
SPEEDING TICKETS. YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO BUT WE SPEAK BOTH I'M
SORRY UNLIKE WITH THE TYPICAL
SPEEDING TICKET. SPEED CAMERA
VIOLATORS ARE NOT ENTITLED TO A
COURT HEARING IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THIS
LANGUAGE AND THEY CAN REQUEST
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING BUT AFTER
THEY PAID THE FULL PENALTY THE
TICKET ALSO DOESN'T HAVE THE-
DATA IN WHICH- INFORMATION ON
HOW FAST THEY WERE GOING NOW
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT TO GET. WITH
WE CAN TAKE IT WHEN YOU'RE GOING
FIFTIES FIFTY FIVE VERSUS EIGHTY
AND FIFTY FIVE- SO IT JUST
CONCERNS ME THAT AND I FEEL LIKE
THERE COULD BE SOME MORE WORK IN
THIS AREA TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CITIZENS HAVE. PROCESS THOUGH
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU. DUG INTO
THIS A LITTLE BIT DON'T NEED TO
WRITE. VISIT. CONCERT. THIS
AMERICAN HIM. YEAH I JUST WANNA
TO. FOR THE WITNESS OPPOSITION-
YOU KEEP USING THE TERM PRIVACY
INVASION OR SOMETHING CORRECT ME
IF I MISQUOTED YOU- BUT I DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND WHAT. WHAT
TECHNICALLY OR LEGALLY YOU'RE
REFERRING TO BUT THATIS AS I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL HE CAN'T USE
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE.%
PASSAT THAT RIGHT RIGHT THAT'S
BUT I THINK IMPORTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT THING THE DATA
THAT'S RETAIN HAS TO BE EXPUNGED
ENTIRELY WITHIN CERTAIN DOESN'T
IN TIME PERIOD HAS LIKE FIVE
DAYS IF THEY DON'T ISSUE A
TICKET. RIGHT SO THERE'S NO.
READ THE GOVERNMENT OLLECTING
DATA THAT STORY INDEFINITELY.
AND AS LONG AS THEY'RE FOLLOWING
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
RIGHT. AND WE AND YOU DON'T
GENERALLY HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
PRIVACY INTEREST IN. THE MAKE
MODEL COLOR OF YOUR VEHICLE AND
YOUR VEHICLE LICENSE PLATE
BECAUSE YOU DRIVE AROUND AND
EVERYWHERE ANYBODY WANTS COULD
TAKE A PICTURE OF YOU DRIVING IN
THE CAR THERE REALLY ISN'T MUCH
TO DO ABOUT THAT. SO WHAT WHERE
IS THE INVASION OF PRIVACY IS
YOU GUYS SEE IT COMING FROM WHAT
WHAT I'M WHAT AM I MISSING HERE.
YES SO AND JUST HAVE IT FOR US
PRIVACY IS ONE OF THE CONCERNS
BUT IT IS ALSO NOT THE SOLE
CONCERN I KNOWS THE- PURVIEW OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT WE ALSO HAVE.
TO PROCESS AN EQUITY CONCERNS AS
WELL OUR PRIVACY CONCERNS THERE
ARE SEVERAL SO ONE IS. ANYTIME
THAT YOU'RE INCREASING
SURVEILLANCE YOU THAT IS. THEY
CALL THE IMPACTS PRIVACY AND
PROBLEMATIC WAYS THESE CAMERAS
WILL ALSO NOT JUST BE CAPTURING.
YOUR LICENSE PLATE INFORMATION
BUT ALSO. BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
BE TIED TO THAT. SPECIFIC CAMERA
IT'S GOING TO BE TRACKING YOUR
LOCATION INFORMATION AS WELL. OF
WHERE YOU WERE AT A PARTICULAR
MOMENT IN TIME- AND DEPENDING ON
WHERE THESE CAMERAS ARE SET UP
THAT COULD REVEAL VERY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU BUT AT THE
VERY LEAST COULD REVEAL. YOUR
TRAVEL AND FOR ME. THAT EVENT
PERSONAL INFORMATION- SO THERE
IS A LOT WE ALSO OFTENTIMES SEE
THAT NO MATTER HOW TIGHTLY THE
PROTECTIONS ARE. THAT ARE PUT IN
PLACE TO TRY AND PROTECT DATA
THAT DATA IS FREQUENTLY STILL.
USE FOR OTHER PURPOSES AND
SHARED AND APPROPRIATELY AND WE
CAUGHT MISSION CREEP AND THAT'S
ANOTHER CONCERN HERE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN MANY TIMES WHERE THERE
ARE STRICT. REQUIREMENTS ON WHEN
INFORMATION CAN BE SHARED IN
WHEN IT CAN'T GOING BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS BELL THAT WAS UP IN
COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE ON ALE PR
INFORMATION THE LAW IS REALLY
CLEAR OF IT CALIFORNIA AGENCIES
CANNOT SHARE ALE PR INFORMATION
OUT OF STATE. OR WITH THE FEDS
AND YET WE'VE SEEN MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DOING THAT
JUST THAT I MEAN ACLU AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
FOR EXAMPLE ARE CURRENTLY
LITIGATING. WITH MARIN COUNTY
SHERIFF OVER THAT EVEN WHEN WE
DO SEE IT AS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS AND I DO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
PUT IN SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS WE STILL SEE PRIVACY
VIOLATIONS HAPPENING DESPITE
SOME OF THOSE- PROTECTIONS AND
SO IT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE IMPACTS THE
IMPACTS NOT JUST THE INTENDED
IMPACTS OF THE BILL. OKAY THANK
YOU CHAIRS AND DOGS I DON'T WANT
FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR YOU CAN
ADDRESS YOUR CLOTHES. ON THE-
THE APPEAL PROCESS OR DUE
PROCESS AND- IT'S THE IT'S
UNCLEAR TO ME WHAT HAPPENS IN A
SITUATION WHERE A LADY SAY I LET
MY SIXTEEN YEAR OLD BORROW MY
CAR. AND SHE'S DOING TWELVE
MILES AN HOUR OVER THE POSTED
LIMIT GET TWENTY TICKETS- YOUR
HOUSE THAT SORTED OUT THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND PROCEDURE. WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO ANSWER SO THINK
OF THIS BECAUSE SHE'S PAYING
THAT THAT RIGHT RIGHT. I DON'T
THINK OF THIS THINK OF THIS THIS
THINK OF THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE- TICKET. WHERE
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS NOT ABOUT
YOU GETTING A TICKET THIS IS
ABOUT THE VEHICLE AND THAT'S WHY
THERE'S NO POINTS ON THE LICENSE
PLATE THAT'S WHY IT'S A NOMINAL
TICKET FEE. THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
THE CAR ENGAGING IN A MOVING
VIOLATION THE SAME WAY A CAR
GAUGING AND APART WE DON'T CARE
WHETHER YOU PARK THE CAR THERE
YOU THAT TALKING ABOUT DEFENSE
IN COURT WHEN YOU COME IN YOU
SAY MY DAUGHTER PARK THE CAR IN
THE RED ZONE. PARK UP TICKET. UP
VERY SIMILAR UP WAY THAT THIS
HAS BEEN- SO WE WILL CERTAINLY
LOOK AT THAT THE DUE PROCESS IN
THIS- BUT- IT WAS STRUCTURED
VERY SIMILAR TO. WHAT WHAT ANY
CAR THAT MADE A VIOLATION. YOU
KNOW THAT WAS OUTSIDE OF A
DRIVER'S VIOLATIONS NOT A MOVING
VIOLATION ON THE DRIVER IT'S-
IT'S A CAR DOING OF- HAVING A
VIOLATION JUST LIKE A PARKING
pWHO'S DRIVING YOUR CAR AT THE
MOMENT THE TICKETS ISSUED YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO. EXACT REVENGE
ON I HAVE A TICKET THE FAMILY
MEMBER OPEN THOSE DRIVE MY CAR.
YEAH OKAY SO AND I DON'T MEAN TO
GO OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF PRIVACY
BUT I. MEANT TO ASK SINCE.
RITESH YEP. SO IT UNDER NO SIR.
BUILD THE YOU CAN. GET A POINT
ON THEIR DRIVING RECORD.
ABSOLUTE CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
NO POINTS. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER.
HELP MISTER BENNETT PLEASE. JUST
JUST VERY QUICKLY COULD JUST
THIS BILL IS THE ONE THAT I'VE
BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO AND I
APPRECIATE BUT JUST. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ASKED QUESTIONS ABOUT PRIVACY
AND JUST WHAT I'M HEARING
BASICALLY AND I'M HEARING IT
JUST DOESN'T MATTER IF THIS IS A
CAMERA THAT TAKES A PICTURE
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME OPPOSITION
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M HEARING.
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND I GUESS
IF YOU TOOK THAT LOGIC TO A TO
EXTREME THEN YOU WOULD A WEEK.
CAN TAKE A- JENNIFER SWEAR YOUR
V. WAS AT A PARTICULAR POINT IN
TIME- AND WITH THAT- I WOULD
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AS I WILL BE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR BENNETT ARE THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISH
ASK QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CHECK
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAX AND A SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT.
WITH THAT. MISPRONOUNCING QUEUE
FOR THE TIME ATTENTION YOU PUT
INTO THE SPELL- IN WHERE THE
COMMITTEE OF SECOND REFERRAL SO
WE'RE PRIMARILY. CHARGED WITH
VIOLATING THE PRIVACY IMPACT SHE
JUST. A COMPLIMENTARY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BARRICADED DID FOR BEING
MINDFUL OF PRIVACY
CONSIDERATIONS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
EVERYBODY DOING ITS VERY CLEAR
TO ME THAT YOU PUT TIME AND
ATTENTION AND EFFORT INTO
THINKING ABOUT. HOW DO YOU
ADVANCE THE- THE SPEED SAFETY
ISSUES THAT I KNOW YOU ARE SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT AND TESTIFIED
ABOUT WITH SOME ENTHUSIASM. BUT
ALSO THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
PROTECT. THE UNITED. YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF ANY HERE THAT
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT PEOPLE TRY TO
SLIDE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE BUT
TO ME. THERE ARE SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO THIS
BILL. YOU KNOW POTENTIAL TO SAVE
LIVES TO KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE-
YOU'VE CLEARLY. AS YOU MENTIONED
YOU KNOW PUT IN SOME PRIVACY
REQUIREMENTS. RELATED TO THE
VIDEO GENERATED BY THE SYSTEM
THE DELETION REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE DATA COLLECTED. ALL THE
VENDORS TO THE SAME COMMONSENSE
I JUST WANT TO. APPLAUD YOU FOR
THAT AND SOME OF THE OTHER
ISSUES I KNOW ARE OUTSIDE THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS COMMITTEE
SPOKE- YOU KNOW EXPECT YOU'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
STEAK. ON SOME OF THOSE WERE
ISSUED ARE OUTSIDE OF OUR
PURVIEW. BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK. FOR
YOU STOP IN FOR WORKING WITH US
TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE- YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. WITH
THAT BECAUSE- THANK YOU TO WE'VE
SEEN IN ALMOST 30% INCREASE IN
TRAFFIC FATALITIES AND SERIOUS
INJURIES JUST IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS. THIS IS SUCH A PROBLEM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT NOW
SPEED CAMERAS ARE CALLED OUT AS
BEING ELIGIBLE. FOR FEDERAL
FUNDING UNDER THE BI.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND JOB ACT. AS
PART OF A NATIONWIDE GOAL OF
REDUCING TRAFFIC FATALITIES. TO
ZERO SIXTEEN OTHER STATES ALLOW
FOR THE USE OF CAMERAS AND I
THINK THAT CALIFORNIA'S GOT
ABOUT IF WE DO. IT WE SET THE
STANDARD FOR A MORE THOUGHTFUL-
MORE EQUITABLE MORE PRIVACY
CENTERED- WAY OF INITIATING
THESE. CAN ALL YOU LOCATE WHERE
WE ALREADY HAVE A SPEEDING
PROBLEM AFTER PROBLEM YOU HAVE
TO BE GOING. AWAY SEVEN MILE
HOUR OVER THE SPEED LIMIT. WE'VE
TRIED TO TAKE THIS THEY CAN'T
I'D LIKE CAMERA BILL IN A- WAY
LOOKING. TO WORK WITH STICKLES
DO IT AT IT'S NOT IN A VACUUM.
WE ALSO WERE ON FUNDING FOR
THOSE OTHER- SAFETY IMPROVE.
THIS IS UP A TOOL TO GIVE ME
THAT MUNICIPALITIES TO USE. AND
WE ARE ONLY PILOTING THIS NOW IN
SIX CITIES IN THE IN IN THE IN
THE STATE AND WHICH WILL GIVE US
THE DATA WE NEED DOWN THE ROAD.
EVERYONE IS SPREAD THE STATE.
THAT I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES AS
WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY REVIEWING. THEM QUICKLY
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO THREE
THREE SIX MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GABRIEL I GREATER- I'D
KILEY. BARRICADE CAN BARRICADE
HAND AYE BENNETT. BENNETT I
BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
FONG IRWIN. IRWIN I VALLADARES
VALLADARES I WICKS WIXII WILSON
WILSON I. THANK YOU ALL THANK
YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS I THINK WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TURN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WAX. WHO'S GOING TO GO NEXT SO
THIS IS- ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO. TWENTY THE WOMAN IN THE MAKE.
HE HAS A PLAN TO MAKE. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE- OUR BY PART OF DUO-
SOME AND SUMMER HIM YOU MAY BE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
WANT TO- I LIKE TO BEGIN BACK
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS LISTED
AND ANALYSIS AND I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR. AND THE HARDWORKING
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE TO FOR THEIR LINE THIS
BILL TO CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
PRIVACY LAWS. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE AS AMENDED WILL
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA AGE
APPROPRIATE DESIGN CODE. TO HELP
CREATE A SAFER ONLINE EXPERIENCE
FOR OUR CHILDREN. WELL EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE PRIVACY
STATUTES OFFER IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS THAT GUARD
CHILDREN'S PRIVACY THERE IS NO
COHERENT COMPREHENSIVE LAW THAT
PROTECTS CHILDREN UNDER
EIGHTEEN. FROM ONLINE PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT THEY'RE LIKELY
TO ACCESS. AS A RESULT ONLINE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THE KIDS
USE DAILY HAVE BEEN LOADED ITH
ADULT DESIGN PRINCIPLES THEY DO
NOT FACTOR IN THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF YOUNG MINDS ABILITIES AND
SENSIBILITIES. BY NOT
CONSIDERING CHILDREN UNDER
EIGHTEEN THE DESIGN OF ONLINE
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE LIKELY TO ACCESS. THEY
FACE A NUMBER OF ADVERSE IMPACTS
TO THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH THE
ONLINE WORLD INCLUDING BULLYING
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES AND
ADDICTIVE BEHAVIOR. AS AMENDED
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE WILL
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
REQUIRING WEBSITES AND OTHER
ONLINE SERVICES THAT ARE LIKELY
TO BE ACCESSED BY CHILDREN. TO
OFFER PRIVACY AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS BY DEFAULT. UNLESS
THERE'S REASONABLE CERTAINTY
THAT THE CONSUMER IS AN ADULT.
IS PROTECTIONS INCLUDE DISABLING
PROFILING. PROHIBITING THE
COLLECTION OR RETENTION OF
CHILDREN'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT IS NOT NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE REQUESTED. OR USING
A CHILD'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
FOR ANY REASON OTHER THAN THE
REASON FOR WHICH IT WAS
COLLECTED. PROHIBITING THE
COLLECTION OF ANY PRECISE
GEOLOCATION INFORMATION BY
DEFAULT UNLESS THE BUSINESS CAN
DEMONSTRATE A COMPELLING REASON
THAT DOING. SO BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD. PROHIBITING THE USE
DARK. I EVEN IF LITTLE DESIGN TO
LEAD OR ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS TO
HER PROVIDE PERSONAL INFORMATION
BEYOND WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE REQUESTED SERVICE.
FOR TRICO PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY WHICH IS THE PRIVACY
AGENCY WE DOUBLES IN CALIFORNIA.
TO SABOTAGING CONVENE THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S DATA
PROTECTION TASK FORCE TO
EVALUATE BEST PRACTICES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE DESIGN
CODE AND TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
BUSINESSES AS SPECIFIED IN THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THE
BILL I KNOW SOME OF YOU HAVE
HAD. IMPLEMENTATION QUESTIONS-
AND I THINK HAVING THAT TOP
FORCE WORKING WITH THE
REGULATORY AGENCY TO. WITH THE
OWNERS ARE LIMITATION IS KEY.
FINALLY AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
TWO WOULD REQUIRE THE PRIVACY
AGENCY IN CONSULTATION THE TASK
FORCE TO ADOPT REGULATIONS TO
PUT A- IT IS A CO. PAY FIRST
TWENTY FOUR WE KNOW A BIT. OF
THE LONG RUN WIFE TIMING BUT
THOUGHT THAT THAT IMPORTANT JUST
ENTER OF GETTING RIGHT IN WE
NEED THE TIME TO BE ABLE.
SEVENTY THREE ISN'T STEP TOWARDS
ADDRESS THE WE CAN TO FACE. AND
ENSURING THAT OUR CHILDREN ARE
SAFE WHEN THEYGO ONLINE WITH
THE AMENDMENTS I'M TAKING TODAY
SORRY WHILE HE AMENDMENTS I'VE
TAKEN A JOB DRESS ALL THE
CONCERNS. RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
I'M SURE THIS BILL MOVES. THAT
HAD MANY MEETINGS WITH THE TECH
INDUSTRY WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO
TO CREATE A BILL THAT. AND WE
THINK IT CAN WORK FOR THEM- I
WILL HAVE MY WITNESSES SELF
INTRODUCED AND I ALSO WOULD
LIKE- WITH THE TERMS AND DOLLARS
TO ALLOW MY TURN AUTHOR JUST A
COUPLE WORDS AS WELL. POSSIBLE
TO SAY NOW. THEN I'LL BE FAIRLY
BREF I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE-
THE INCREDIBLE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS LEGISLATION TO. THE CURRENT
GENERATION OF KIDS AND ALL THE
GENERATIONS THAT ARE. TO COME
THE DIGITAL WORLD THE ONLINE
WORLDWHATEVER. NAME IT GOES BY
IS. INTEGRAL TO THEIR LIVES AND
HOW THEY COMMUNICATE AND HOW
THEY INTERACT WITH EACH OTHER
AND HOW THEY INTERACT WITH SOME
PEOPLE THEY PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
BE INTERACTING WITH. AND THERE
IS NOT A PARENT. I WOULD. BET MY
OUSTER IS NOT APPARENT ON THIS
PLANET. THAT RULE. THE
CAPABILITY OF. GETTING ALL THE
DIFFERENT WAYS. THAT THE- KIDS
ARE ABLE TO GET ALL THE THINGS
THAT. PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO. THAT
HAVE NO GOOD INTENTION AT ALL.
AND I'M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
MARKETING PRODUCTS. I'M TALKING
ABOUT OTHER NEFARIOUS NEFARIOUS
THINGS. DRAWN SOME OF MY- PRIOR
EXPERIENCES DEPUTY DA I REMEMBER
GOING TO A CONFERENCE WIN. AT
THIS IS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. AND THEY WERE USING
GEOLOCATION TO TRY TO FIND KIDS
THAT. PARKS ADOPTION. PROCESS I
MEAN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON. A LONG TIME NOT
THE FAULT OF THE COME. AND TERMS
. WE AFTER. MORE WE HAVE TO
BETTER WE HAVE TO DO IT IN TO
MAKES THAT ARE KEY THEY'RE NOT
WE'RE TURN BACK THE CLOCK ON
TECHNOLOGY AND THIS IS PART OF
IT I MEAN MY TEENAGERS THEY'D
TARGET OTHER OVER VIDEO GAMES
THAT TALK TO EACH OTHER ON
SNAPCHAT THEY TALK TO EACH OTHER
THEY WATCH TICTOC VIDEOS AND IT
IS PART OF THE THAT'S- TO MAKE-
GOING TOWARD THE- IT'S- SUPPORT
. APPROPRIATELY FOR THEM AND I
JUST WANT AND HAVE AN AWESOME
WHAT IS YOUR WHO LED THE CHARGE
TO IMPLEMENT THIS THE BILL WATER
IN THE U. K. THAT THIS IS
PATTERNED OFF OF. IS MY AND
TWENTY TO PRINT A POTENTIAL
ARGUE YOU MIGHT HEAR IT IS
WORKING THERE THE COMPANIES ARE
ALREADY COMPLYING WITH THIS IT
IS ALL RIGHT LED TO SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THAT ARE KEEPING OUR
KIDS SAFE KEEPING THE KIDS IN
THE UK SAFER AND WE NEED TO
CALIFORNIA WE NEED IN AMERICA SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE
GOING TO TURN TO OUR- PRIMARY.
WITNESS IT'S A- AND WE HAVE A-
S. B. B. Q. DRAWN FOR THE FIVE
RIGHTS FOUNDATION BARONESS IT'S
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN WELCOME
BACK. AT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JAFFA HAVING ME BACK AM I
AM BARONESS THE BANK IS DRAWN ON
THE CROSS PEER IN THE HOUSE OF
LORDS AND THE ARCHITECT. AT U.
K. H. PRO. DESIGN CODE AND I'D
LIKE TO STRESS THAT THAT WAS A
BIPARTISAN. M. INTERVENTION ALSO
AND I SUCH AS AN INDEPENDENT
PAN. AM ASSET NOT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS THERE ARE
THREE. PRIMARY PRINCIPLES AT OF
THE BILL AND IT THAT IT REALLY
NEW TO THE AREA OF ONLINE
REGULATION THE FIRST IS THAT IT
DEFINES A CHILD AS A PERSON
UNDER EIGHTEEN WHICH DOES AWAY
WITH THE IDEA OF ADULTHOOD AT
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS THE NORM
CURRENTLY. ONLINE IS ALSO
SUPPORTS CHILDREN ONLINE WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY SPEND THAT TIME BY
EXPECT EXTENDING THE SCOPE. FROM
DIRECTED AT CHILDREN TO SERVICES
LIKELY TO BE ACCESSED BY
CHILDREN AND IT'S FOCUSED ON
DESIGN NOT REQUIRING COMPLEX
ACTIONS FROM YOUNG USES THIS IS
A PARADIGM SHIFT TOWARDS PRODUCT
SAFETY RATHER THAN TRYING TO
DEAL WITH ISSUES AFTER HOME HAS
ALREADY BEEN PERRANCE BY
CHILDREN. I PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE. AS AT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM HAS
ALLUDED TO IS THAT WHILE THIS IS
A NEW APPROACH IT IS ALREADY
INTERNAL AND THE U. K. AND THE
RESULTS OF WHICH HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST INNOVATION AND DESIGNING
FOR CHILD SAFETY THAT THAT TAX
HIKES SET TO. HAS EVER
UNDERTAKEN GOOGLE DEFAULTS TO
SAVE SUCH FOR UNDER EIGHTEENS
YOU TRIP TURNED OFF AUTOPLAY
TICTOC AN INSTAGRAM STOP DIRECT
MESSAGING OF UNKNOWN ADULTS TO
MINUS AMONG HUNDREDS OF THE
INCREMENTAL CHANGES THAT
DETOXIFY THE ONLINE EXPERIENCE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. I AM PRO TECH
BUT JUST AS ONE CANNOT OR SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO SELL RANCHO DRIVE
A CAR WITH NO SEAT BELTS REVIEW
MIRACLE HEADLINES. IT MUST NOT
BE POSSIBLE TO SELL RENTAL OFFER
A CHILD SERVICES AND PRODUCTS
THAT HAVE NOT TAKEN ACCOUNT OF
THAT PRIVACY AND SAFETY. THE
CALIFORNIA AGE APPROPRIATE
DESIGN BILL SIMPLY AND SHOWS
THAT COMPANIES HAVE TO ASK
THEMSELVES THE QUESTION WHAT
WOULD YOU DO DIFFERENTLY IF. THE
END USER WAS A CHILD. IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS THE OFFICE OF
WORKED AT WITH INDUSTRY TO
ENSURE THAT LANGUAGES CLARIFIED
AND ALIGNED WITH THE C. P. R. A.
M. BUT IF CALIFORNIA DOES PULSE
AB TWO TWO SEVEN THREE. IT WILL
I BELIEVE IN TIME BECOME A
GLOBAL NORM THAT WILL BE AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEGACY FOR THE
STATE. CON MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE. MOST AND- THE
WELLBEING OF THE BILLION
CHILDREN WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY NICE
FURNACE AND WE NOW SECOND.
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY KIM WHO IS A HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR FROM PORTER RANCH
CALIFORNIA FROM AND ABOUT. THAT
FOR GOLF WELCOME TO. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU CHAIRED YOU COME.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE MYSELF MY
NAME IS EMMA AND CAM I AM
EIGHTEEN YEAR FROM POOR RANCH.
AND I WANT TO TALK MY STORY ON
TECH PLATFORMS AND HOW THEY
COULD AND SHOULD HAVE STEPPED UP
TO PREVENT THE MANY ISSUES I
EXPERIENCED. YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
SUFFERED GREATLY EMOTIONALLY AND
MENTALLY AS A RESULT SUCH
PLATFORMS AND MANY PROBLEMS HAVE
ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
LACK OF OVERSIGHT. THIS IS WHY
I'M CALLING FOR LEGISLATION TO
ENSURE SOCIAL MEDIA CORPORATIONS
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
LACK OF PRECAUTION AND SAFETY
MEASURES. I GOT MY FIRST
CELLPHONE AFTER I TURNED
THIRTEEN ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
I DID WAS DONAL INSTAGRAM SO
THAT COULD FIT IN. MANY OF MY
CLASSMATES ALREADY HAD ACCOUNTS
AS I SCROLL DOWN LOOKING AT MY
PEERS IS PROFILED I FOUND MYSELF
STARING AT MY OWN IMAGE. READING
LIST TENS CALLING ME FAT AND
UGLY WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE MY
FRIENDS HAVE UPLOADED PHOTOS ME
RIDICULING EVERY ASPECT MY BODY.
AT THE AGE OF THIRTEEN I DID NOT
USE THE THAT I DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO BLOCK OR FLAG CONTENT.
PLATFORMS DO NOT GIVE USERS
CREEK SUCTION SO YOU DON'T GET A
BREAK DOWN WE WANT SOMETHING
GOES WRONG. IT FELT LIKE A GAME
WITH THE GOAL OF HIGH ALERT ONS
AND BIKE NOW. AND COMMENTS WHEN
YOU DON'T GET HIGH ENGAGEMENT
YOU THINK YOU MUST BE MISS
UNDERSTANDING THE GAME ARE NOT
PLAYING RIGHT. YOU DON'T THINK
ABOUT THE COMPANY HAT MADE THE
GAME AND IN THIS GAME IT WAS-
WHAT'S SOMETHING WENT WRONG. MY
MIND TORMENT YOU CAN SEE. ONE
AFTER I WAS. WITHOUT AREATA AND
- DISEASE THAT LEADS TO. HAIR
LOSS. CLASSMATES SUPPOSED OF
THEM. PARTICIPATE IN TOWN TRENDS
THAT I. COULD NOT PART. IN THIS
IS ALSO THE TIME INSTAGRAM
STORIES CAME OUT WHENSOMEBODY
UPLOADED A NEW STORY THERE WOULD
BE A PUSH NOTIFICATION. I GET
NOTIFICATIONS THAT ONE OF MY
CLASSMATES OR FRIENDS HAD A NEW
STORY. I CLICK ON THE
NOTIFICATION AND BE SHOWN YET
ANOTHER PHOTO. THAT MADE ME FEEL
LIKE I COULDN'T FIT IN. I'D LIKE
AND COMMENT ON THE POST MADE BY
MY CLASSMATES BECAUSE I FELT
LIKE I HAD TO. AND THEN BECAUSE
I INTERACTED WITH THAT POST I
GET MORE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THOSE KINDS OF POSTS. I KEPT
GETTING NOTIFICATIONS SCREAMING
FOR MY ATTENTION REMINDING ME OF
WHO I CANNOT BE. DESPITE NOT
POSTING PHOTOS OF MYSELF I STOP
AT HORRIBLE WHENEVER I WAS.
UPSET MEDIA PLATFORM SO I
DELETED THE APPS OFF MY PHONE.
BUT I STARTED BEING EXCLUDED
FROM CONVERSATIONS AT SCHOOL. I
WAS MEASURING MYSELF UP TO ALL
OF MY PEERS ON THESE PLATFORMS
AND I FELT LIKE I WAS LOSING. MY
KNOW. THE DESIGN PURGING PEOPLE
GO. BACK TO THE TOP SO
COMPARISON. AND THEY KNOW WHAT.
PEOPLE AS A DID ME. IT MAKES ME.
DIZZY AS IF NOT WELCOME ARE NOT
NEEDED. AND TO THINK THAT THIS
IS A DESIGN FEATURE ON THESE
PLATFORMS IS SICKENING. THIS
WASN'T SOMETHING I COULD TALK TO
MY PARENTS ABOUT. DIDIT HAVE
ANY SIMILAR EXPERIENCES ON
SOCIAL MEDIA GROWING UP SO THEY
DID NOT CATCH ME WHEN I FELL. I
FOUND MYSELF IN A POSITION WITH
NO SUPPORT. BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
ONE TO HELP ME. SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS FACILITATE THIS HARM
AND THEY REFUSED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON MY GRADES MY MENTAL
AND MY PHYSICAL HEALTH MY
ATTENTION WAS ON OTHER GIRLS ON
THE INTERNET. I FIXATED ON
TRYING TO BE LIKE THEM. I HATED
BEING ME. IT WAS NO LONGER ABOUT
FITTING IN WITH MY CLASSMATES IT
WAS A PLEASING SOMEONE. AND HE-
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE POPE
NINETEEN KNOCKED DOWN THAT I
LEARNED ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA AND
DIGITAL ON THIS ADVOCACY SHORTLY
AFTER DISCOVERING THE LOG OFF
MOVEMENT I BECAME THE DIRECTOR
OF THE LGBTQ PLUS INITIATIVE I
WORK HARD TO INFORM AND PROTECT
YOUNG PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY MY
LGBTQ PLUS PEERS ON THE HARMS OF
SOCIAL MEDIA AND HOW TO USE IT
SAFELY I AM SO SORRY WE NEED YOU
TO WRAP UP. I GENUINE I
GENUINELY BELIEVE THAT THE RISE
OF THE STUDENT LED MOVEMENTS
LIKE THE LOG OFF MOVEMENT
TECHNICALLY POLITICS. PROVE HOW
BADLY LEGISLATION NEEDS TO BE
PASSED IN ORDER PROTECT YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM THE GROWING. MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL DANGERS OF SOCIAL
MEDIA TEAMS LIKE MYSELF ARE
BEING HARMED AND WE WANT TO
SPEAK UP AND TELL OUR STORIES
BUT THE HARSH REALITY IS THERE'S
ONLY SO MUCH WE CAN DO. TEAMS DO
NOT HOLDING GOVERNMENT. SO I ON
BEHALF OF MILLIONS HARMED AND
SCARED IF USERS. ASK FOR HELP IN
THE FIGHT TO MAKE THE DIGITAL
SAFER THROUGH LEGISLATION. AND
PROTECT THE NEXT GENERATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU. WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN TO
ANY WITNESSES IN A HEARING ROOM
IN SUPPORT IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE.
HELLO I'M SUSAN REYNOLDS OF
PIEDMONT CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO
THE FOUNDER. OF LOOK UP THAT
EMPOWERS YOUTH JUST LIKE ME.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS
LEADERS ASKING FOR A CHANGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I MEAN I IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME AND ASK FOR
HIS NAME AN AFFILIATION PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. HI MY NAME IS
AMY LEVEL AND I'M HERE WITH THE
ALEXANDER NOBLE FOUNDATION AND
REPRESENTING MY SON ALEXANDER
WHO IS NO LONGER WITH US THANKS
TO HARM THROUGH SNAPCHAT. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. DIANNE SHARED
WITH PARENTS TOGETHER IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. FEET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE ARE NOW GOING TO LOOK
FOR ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. MISTER ROBERT OR DO
pLINES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY THREE. TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. LOCAL FIRST
ONLINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN IN
THE SOME OF THE MEN ON THE PARK
DIRECTOR STATE POLICY AT PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE CALLING AT THE
PORT ITSELF THANK YOU. EXTRA
HELP LINE FOR. NINE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN NUMBER
CATALINA SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER REPORTS- IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION WE
ARE A PART OF THE BOOK OF THE
BILL AND WE DO HAVE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LANGUAGE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ESTIMATES
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
FIFTY FIVE. BOB THE CRIME OPEN
PRIVATE G. CALLING CHECK OUR
SUPPORT POINTED OUT.
EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JUDY ROGG
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I LOST MY SON
ERIC TO THE CHOKING GAME WHICH
IS RAMPANT ACROSS ALL PLATFORMS
OF SOCIAL MEDIA JUST ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS AGO NOW AND
ANYTHING THAT CAN HELP KIDS.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE
EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS THAT THAT AT ONE POINT
BOND ON BEHALFOF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. A LINE SEVENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAMMY KERR WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA COULD SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WE ARE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BLIND EIGHTY
TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREW
MILTON ISLAND SAN FRANCISCO AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
NATALIE SMITH I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE STYLE. FIND
SEVENTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
SAMANTHA CARPENTER AT LIVE IN
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITSELF THANK
YOU. I TO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
FOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE ARE NOW GOING TO TURN TO
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- I BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE BOTH ON THE PHONE SO DO WE
HAVE. RONAK DAVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
HEY I WAS GOING TO THE SECOND
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE ALL RIGHT
IF YOU. GO AHEAD PLEASE. I THINK
WE HAVE A LIEN TO TALK A FROM
TECHNET ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS AND WE ANY TALK I WOULD
TAKE THAT AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
VERSION OF AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
THREE IN PRINT THANK. WELL WE
ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL I'D LIKE TO DRAW A
DISTINCTION AND BE VERY CLEAR
THAT OUR MEMBER COMPANIES BUT A
HIGH VALUE ON CHILDREN'S PRIVACY
AND THE UNDERLYING PRINCIPLES
AND INTENT TO SELL. THE
AMENDMENT MORE KNOWLEDGE THE
STATE PROGRESS IN IMPROVING THE
THOUSAND PLANTATION AND I
COMMEND THE AUTHOR STAKEHOLDERS
AND IMPORTANTLY THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK THAT WENT THESE
AMENDMENTS. THERE ARE STILL A
COUPLE OF MAJOR ISSUES THAT I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED. IN ORDER TO ALIGN
ITSELF MORE CLOSELY WITH
EXISTING LAW AND COMPANY
COMPLIANCE AFTER THE THINK THE
LEADING ADULT COOPER CAME
DESPITE SERVICES AND FEATURES.
ARE DIRECTED TO THEM RATHER THAN
THOSE THAT ARE LIKELY. TO BE
ACCESSED BY A CHILD. GOOD TO
TALK. TO MAKE THE THINGS ARE
THAT ARE. BY THAT COMPLY WITH
FOR YEARS. THE FOCUS ON CHILDREN
RUN THAN AT. ABOUT THE- AS ONE
CAN IMAGINE A SINGLE CHILD THEIR
ALWAYS ACCESS AND NUMBER OF
BRENDA MUCH. INCLUDING THE
CHANGES AND THE CHILDREN THINK
IT MAKE THE BILL EASIER TO THAT
ALIGNED WITH CURRENT LAW AND BY
CHILDREN AGE. FURTHERMORE
WHICHEVER THING AND THE EVENTS
PASSED WITHIN THE FOUNDER WILL
BE ABLE TO BETTER AND ENFORCE.
CORRECTED THE CHILDREN SPEND
LIKELY THE ACT. PLEASE MAKE MY
NEXT POINT THAT WE'D LIKE TO-
THE APART MECHANISM OF THE PHONE
CLEARLY I. AS I. AN INTERCOM
DURING COMMITTEE. HEARING WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH. WITH ADOPTION OF
OBJECTIVE. ON THE BREAK. AND HE
DOES PROVIDE. ADEQUATE GUIDANCE
OPPORTUNITY TO CRACK MISTAKES
BEFORE LET FIND HEALTHY.
MEMBERSHIP IS OUR THE AND WE
WILL BE EVALUATE CONDITIONS
LIGHT OF THE PRISTINE. AGAIN
WELL WE ARE A- OPPOSE THE BIRD
POINT THE NAMES OF FORWARD TO
OUR WITH YA. TO CONTINUE.
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ABOUT YOU KNOW NOT VERY
LAWMAKERS IN THAT CHAMBER. YES
SIR THANK YOU TO GET YOUR
MEMBERS AND AUTHORS RUNOFF
DAYLAMI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE BECKLEY
ALTHOUGH IN A POSITION TO EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE I LIKED A
LOT OPPONENTS WITHOUT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM TECHCONNECT AND
ECHO THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHORS FOR WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS BEING TAKEN
TODAY. HI MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
MAY HAVE SOME CONCERN. FOR THE
BILL ITSELF BUT WE VERY MUCH
AGREE INTO CARE ITS LEAD TO
HEIGHTENED PRIVACY AND SECURITY
CONCERNS THAT EXISTS FOR
CHILDREN. THERE'S A COUPLE OF
POINTS I WANT TO EXPAND ON FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TO PAY FOR IT
WE BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
NEEDS AND VULNERABILITIE OF A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD MINOR ARE NOT
THE SAME AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
CHILD. TO OUR CONCERN AT THE
BILLION. ALL MY INTO THE SAME
AGE GROUP ABOUT DIFFERENT AND WE
SIMPLY AFTER THE IN ARE AND YOU
CAN RETURNS THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
IS THAT RIGHT TO THE FROM. ARRAY
THE MAP PUBLIC POLICY SECOND WE
APPRECIATE THEM AND BEING TAKEN
TO THE PROVISIONS RELATING TO
THE TASK FORCE THAT WE SUGGEST
THAT UPON COMPLETION OF ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES THE TASK FORCE
TO BE REQUIRED TO REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE DECIDE HOW TO
PROCEED FROM THERE APPLICATIONS
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH DOCTORS. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA GO IS THERE ANY. ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM TO AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE. SEEING
NONE WE WILL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ONLY A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE THAN SEARLE TO OPPOSE
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE. WE
HAVE ONE LINE WITH AN OPERATOR
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
FIFTY NINE. NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON THAT THE
TEMPLATE ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ON OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR-
TECHNOLOGY PARTNERS ON THIS BILL. THERE ARE NO FURTHER ALLIANCE
IN QUEUE FOR A POSITION AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WITHOUT
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. REMEMBER FIGHT ARE.
I'M FIRST OF ALL EMILY I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE FOR BEING A VOICE FOR YOUR
GENERATION- I AM SO PROUD TO
REPRESENT YOU YOUR BRAVE YOU ARE
COURAGEOUS- AND YOUR- THE WAY
THAT. OUR I CAN APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE- FOR YOUR GENERATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR AND I'M
I'M HOPING YOU CAN EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT ON WHY THE NEED FOR
THE LANGUAGE LIKELY. ACCESS
VERSES A MOST LIKELY- WHY LET IF
THE CHAIR ALLOWS- THE BARONESS
TO ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE YOU'VE I
THANK GOD FOR THIS IN THE UK
YEAH- ABSOLUTELY AND IF I MIGHT
AT ECHO YOU WITH AND I'M- LIKELY
TO BE ACTS I MEAN I THINK THAT
THAT IS A VERY CAÑADA ABOUT
DIRECT TRIP FROM THE I'M NOT
ALWAYS WHEN YOU WISH THEM TO BE
AND AT LOOK SENATE YOU CAN. WE
LOOKED AT THE WAY CHILDREN
REALLY WANNA DID NOT WANT TO
BRING IN SOMETHING THAT MAKE
SESAME STREET BATCH TO BATCH BUT
LEFT TECH TALK FACEBOOK AS WELL
AS SCOPE SATELLITE THE ACCESS IS
DEFINED AT BY YOUR- PERCENT
WHICH MIGHT. NAY RESEARCH BY
DONALD WAS. A BY A- IF YOU WANT.
AT OF THE S. THAT HAVE BEEN THAT
SEEM TO HAVE A LOT OF CHILDREN
AND INDEED IF YOU YOUR FORMAT SO
IF YOUR IN A- CARTOON OR
SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW CHILDREN
LIKE. I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THIS
POINT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
SERVICES ARE NOT LIKELY TO BE
ACCESSED ON THAT DEFINITION AT.
MOM AND POP. GET OUT OF WEBSITES
B. TWO B. AT THINGS THAT OF
FRACTALS SPECIFICALLY SO IT WILL
BE JUST SAYS. WE TAKE THE
PROTECTIONS WHETHER CHILDREN ARE
. AND TO TALK NOT THE OPPOSITION
ON THE LINE IS THERE A
DIFFERENTIATION BETWEEN YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WAS
EXPLAINED AND YOUR UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT LIKELY VERSUS THE MOST
LIKELY LANGUAGE. HOW THAT WOULD
BE APPLIED. THANK YOU- IN IN OUR
DEFENDING OF YOU KNOW- DIRECTED
TO CHILDREN THAT WOULD BE. AND
ARE. LIKELY TO BE ACCESSED BY
CHILDREN WOULD BE AN OVER
INCREASE IN STANDARD IT WOULD
CAPTURE FAR MORE WEBSITES AND
PLATFORMS- AND SUBJECT THEM TO
THE BOULDER CARMEN- WHICH- AS
NOTED ARE DIFFICULT TO INTERPRET
AND IMPLEMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE.
CONSIDERATION SHOULD BE GIVEN
WEBSITES SUCH AS ONLINE NEWS
WHICH ARE LIKELY TO BE ACCESSED
BY USERS OF ALL AGES AND DON'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE VISITORS. TO
REGISTER IN ORDER TO KEEP
CONTENT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT I
MISTER KILEY. I APOLOGIZE IF
THIS IS A PRESS TO YOUR
INTRODUCTION COULD YOUHELP ME
UNDERSTAND ALL THAT THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD STANDARD
AND HAT THAT'S HOW THAT WOULD
KIND OF WORK IN PRACTICE I GET A
LETTER THAT THE BARONESS ADDRESS%
BECAUSE THEY'VE GONE THROUGH
THESE DEFINITIONS IN THE UK
YEAH- THE BEST INTEREST IS A
CONCEPT FROM CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
LEGISLATION THE CONVENTION ON
THE RIGHTS OF THE CHILD WHICH
HAS A HUNDRED NINETY SIX
SIGNATORY COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD. AND IT IS- IT HAS A LOT
OF CASE LAW BEHIND IT AND IT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE COURTS
UNDERSTAND AS BEING A BALANCING
ACT SO IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION IN
FRONT OF YOU AND IS IT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD TO DO
ABLE. THE INTERESTING THING
ABOUT YOUR QUESTION IS I HAVE
SINCE SPOKEN TO A LOT OF
ENGINEERS AND THAT LIKE THAT
STANDARD IS THERE YOU KNOW ACT
CAN YOU OPTIMIZE FOR STICKINESS
IS THAT A OR B. AS A SIMILAR
QUESTION FOR THEM AS- CAN YOU
ACT IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF A
CHILD A. B. I WOULD SAY. THAT
SIDE OF THE US AND HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF CANCEL BUT THE WAY THAT
USUALLY HERE THAT- THAT FREEZE
USES YOU'RE DEALING WITH LIKE A
JUDGE WHOSE- DISCERNING THAT
AFFECT A PARTICULAR CHILD IN A
PARTICULAR SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
HERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
CORPORATION SOMEHOW MAKE THAT
JUDGMENT WITH RESPECT TO ALL
CHILDREN I MEAN HOW DO YOU EVEN
AND THAT SORT OF ANALYSIS WHEN I
THINK YOU SEE HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
DONE SO FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAVE
DECIDED IT IS NOT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF CHILDREN TO
CONTINUE. IN TO OUR STRANGE
HEALTH TO DIRECT MESSAGE. AT
UNDER AGE CHILDREN AND THAT IS
ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT'S COME
OUT OF THIS OF WHACK OUT OF THE
CODE AND I THINK THAT UNTIL IT
WAS IN THE INBOX TO CONSIDER
CHILDREN HOW WOULD YOU DO IT
DIFFERENTLY IF YOU KNEW THE END
USER WAS A CHILD THEY WENT
HOSKING THE QUESTION. IS WERE
COMPLETE AC THE MAPS YOU'RE NOT. TO MAKE A SYSTEM THAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST. OF CHILDREN.
OKAY THAT SO YOU SAYING THAT
THIS THIS HAS ACTUALLY APPLIED
IN THE IN THE WAY THAT IT'S
BEING APPLIED HERE ANOTHER
ANOTHER- JUDICIAL SYSTEMS.
INDEED INDEED I'M NOT AND I'M%
NOT GOING TO PRETEND TO YOU THAT
EVERY AND THAT THERE IS A BRIGHT
LINE. YOU KNOW BETWEEN THE EVERY
SINGLE DECISION THAT THE IN THE
THAT A COMPANY CAN MAKE BUT THAT
ALREADY IS NOT A BRIGHT LINE OF
THE DECISIONS THAT MAKING SO I
THINK THAT. THAT THIS IS A
INTENT ON THE PRINCIPLES THAT
THAT CODE SET TOP TWO. YEAH A
VERY CLEARLY INTENTIONAL AND IT
GIVES A LOT OF SPACE TO THE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES TO
INTERPRET THEM. AND MEET THE
BOMB AND- YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE
ACTUALLY LAID DOWN IN MORE
DETAIL SO THERE ARE SOME SAFE
HARBORS WERE. EXCELLENT AND Z.
THEN YOU'RE- NOT SUBJECT TO
LITIGATION BASED ON THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD STANDARD.
THERE IS NOT. A SERGEANT YEAH I
WAS JUST TO JUMP INTO YOU DON'T
MIND. I JUST I JUST ONE FOR
FIRMEST HAS BEEN- THIS THIS
NOTION. THE WAY ABOUT THE BEST
INTERESTS AND WE'VE CHANGED IT.
IF IN THE AMENDMENTS EVERY TAKE
ON THIS COMMITTEE TOTHE BEST
INTERESTS OF CHILDREN AND MOVED
INTO FINDING SOME DECORATIONS.
SO THIS IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT AS AS FOLKS
ARE THINK ABOUT THIS A CALL IF A
CONFLICT ARISES BETWEEN
COMMERCIAL INTERESTS AND THE
BEST INTERESTS OF CHILDREN
COMPANIES SHOULD PRIORITIZE THE
PRIVACY SAFETY. AND WELL BEING
OF CHILDREN OVER COMMERCIAL
INTERESTS THAT HAS BEEN MOVED
INTO THE- SECTION THE FINDINGS
OF DECORATION THE BEGINNING OF
THE BILL. OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THE AYE AYES ADS RIGHT NOW
THAT WOULD NOT BE THE STANDARD
ACCORDING WHICH LIABILITIES IF
YOU COULD. WHAT CORRECT ALTHOUGH
WE I WILL SAY NO A RESERVE THIS
FOR MY TIME WHEN I SPEAK THERE I
THINK WE DO NEED TO THERE NEED
TO BE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THE
REMEDY ISSUE I THINK ALL PARTIES
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT- AND I THINK
IT'S SUBJECT TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS BUT FOR RIGHT NOW
THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT
OPERATIVE STATUTORY LANGUAGE ON
WHICH A LIABILITY WOULD ATTACK.
OKAY THAT'S GOOD I MEAN IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME OFTEN WE HAVE THESE
DEBATES SORT OF YOU KNOW WITH
SOME TRYING TO HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT PLAY A ROLE IN THIS
AND WHAT'S BEST FOR KIDS WHILE
OTHERS YOU KNOW I'D BE ON THIS I
GENERALLY SAY THEY SHOULD BE
LEFT TO FAMILIES SEEMS LIKE
HAVING THE CORPORATION MAKE THE
DECISIONS HAVE THE WORST OF ALL
WORLDS THAT'S NOT I WILL
CORPORATIONS ARE ARE ARE BUILT
FOR HIMSELF I'M- SIR. ABOUT
STANDARD THAT WOULD SORT.
DEPUTIZE THAT RESPONSIBILITY- TO
A CORPORATION WHICH IS SORT OF
BY ITS NATURE- I'VE YOU KNOW A
PROFIT MAXIMIZING ENTITY AND- IS
NOT NECESSARILY AND TO DO WE
USUALLY ASK TO MAKE YOU SORT OF.
OF SOCIAL DEBT YOU KNOW
JUDGMENTS ABOUT THE PUBLIC GOOD. TRY TO RESPONSE I'M JUST GONNA
ALSO ADD YOU KNOW I THINK. PART
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS.
PROVIDE MORE PARAMETERS FOR THE
AGENCY THE REGULATORY AGENCY WHO
I THINK IS GOING TO BE. A MORE
CLOSELY FOLLOWING THE UPS AND
DOWNS OF TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
MORE THAN THIS CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE IS- IT'LL BE ABLE TO
GRAPPLE WITH SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES AND I THINK A MORE
SIGNIFICANT KIND OF WAY- WAS
ESTABLISHING THE- SUPPORTERS I
THINK CAN HELP GIVE INPUT TO
SOME OF THE- CHALLENGES AROUND
SOME OF THE STUFF AS WELL SO
WE'RE TRYING TO GET MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO REGULATORY
AGENCIES WILL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IF YOU DON'T MIND EARNEST
MONEY GO TO- SIMILAR ABOUT HER
QUE HAN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THINGS
ONE IS. I AM. THESE THAT I THINK
EVERY TIME I TURN ON MY END HERE
PODCAST I HEAR AN ADVERTISEMENT
FROM THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
OPPOSING TODAY'S BELL ABOUT HOW
THEY WANT US TO REGULATE THEM.
WELL HERE WE ARE ASKING YOU TO
DO WHAT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST
YOUR CHILDREN AND GUESS WHAT.
OPPOSING IT SEEMS WE WILL TURN
THE APPS OFF AND STOP SPENDING
YOUR MONEY- SO I THINK THAT WHAT
WE WOULD LIKE IS FOR EACH OF YOU
TO COME TO THE TABLE. AND TO BE.
WILLING TO DO WHAT IS IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF OUR CHILDREN
AND NOT WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF YOUR BOTTOM LINES
BUT THAT IS NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE MARKET PLACE
RIGHT NOW AND IS THE MOTHER OF A
TWELVE YEAR OLD. WHO WAS JUST
ENGAGING THE BEHAVIOR THAT I'M
ONLY DISCUSSED GETTING ONLINE
AND- TRYING TO DEAL WITH WHAT
MIDDLE SCHOOL LOOKS LIKE MIDDLE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN THANK YOU
FOR GIVING VOICE TO. BECAUSE I
SEE IT EVERYDAY IT IS INCREDIBLY
HARD AS A PARENT. I LOVE YOU
TOUCHED ON WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
PARENT IN THE STATE AGE WE
DIDN'T GROW UP WITH THIS. TO ME
TO HELP GUIDE HIM THROUGH IT IS
ACTUALLY INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
BECAUSE I DIDN'T GO THROUGH THIS
IS THAT. AS A YOUNG PERSON. AND
YET IT IS. BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT. IT LOOKS LIKE FOR IT TO
FAIL OUR FAMILIES. I'M SO SORRY
FOR YOUR LOSS. IT IS EVERY
MOTHER'S WORST NIGHTMARE TO LOSE
A CHILD. AND THE FACT THAT WE
KNOW. WE KNOW BASED ON TESTIMONY
IN THE FEDERAL. MEANT THAT THERE
WAS CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE BEFORE THE- TECHNOLOGY.
COMPANY DOING. CHILDREN IT TURNS
THEIR BACK. THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED AND WE KNOW THAT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN CONGRESS KNOW
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON SITTING
ON THIS GUYS IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
DOING WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF OUR CHILDREN. AND SO
TO THE COMING OF. TURNOFF WE
CARE ABOUT OUR CHILDREN IN YOUR
PROFITS AND WE'RE GOING TO PASS
LEGISLATION THAT DOES EXACTLY
THAT. SO I AM GLAD YOU KEPT AT
SEVENTEEN I LOVE THAT THAT MIGHT
MY SIX YEAR OLD AND HAVE ACCESS
TO A DEVICE SO TO BE HONEST BILL
WOULDN'T BE AS MEANINGFUL IF IT
WERE THIRTEEN AND UNDER. BUT A
TWELVE YEAR OLD MY SON IS NOT
GETTING ACCESS. THESE THINGS TO
BE PAID ATTENTION TO SO I THINK
SEVENTEEN IS ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE EIGHTEEN IF YOU
WILL. I AND I THINK THE STANDARD
YOU SET FORTH. LOOK IF I AM A
FORMER DEFENSE ATTORNEY EVER IF
A COMPANY CAN COME INTO COURT
AND SHOW. THE DAY. LAID IT OUT
AND THEN. THEY MADE THEY BELIEVE
IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CHILD AND NOT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF AUTUMN I AM I
BELIEVE THAT UNDER THIS STANDARD
SET FORTH. THE COURT WOULD NOT
FIND THEM TO BE LIABLE TO
ANSWER. MY COLLEAGUES QUEST. YOU
DOING. WITH DOING TODAY INSIDE
THIS IS ACTUALLY VERY WELL DONE
AND I'M GLAD WE HAVE YOU HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT HOW IT IS
PLAYED OUT IN PRACTICE BUT- FOR
EMILY AND EVERY. SINGLE PERSON.
LIKE EMILY THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT MOVE AND
WE SHOULD ALL BE SUPPORTING THIS
IN A BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS WAY.
AND ATTACKED MANY SHOULD LISTEN
TO THEIR OWN ADS AND COME TO THE
TABLE AND SUPPORT IT SO THINKING
ABOUT. MISTER BENNETT. I KNOW
THIS IS A LONG MEETING AND WE
ALL HAVE IMPORTATION MAYBE TRY
TO BE AS CONCISE AS I CAN I
REALLY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
THIS BILL HAVE ONE SPECIFIC
QUESTION FOR YOU WITH YOUR
EXPERIENCE FROM GREAT BRITAIN.
ALL COMPANIES HAVE TO DO IN
GAUGING THE DIFFICULT TASK OF
TRYING TO DE IDENTIFY WHETHER A
PARTICULAR USER IS A CHILD. THAT
WILL HELP. TRYING TO BE AN ADULT
OR WHAT I LIKE IS THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING IS NO THEY SIMPLY HAVE
SAY THESE ARE THE STANDARD TWO
GOING TO APPLY TO A- KALITA. ARE
NOT. DON'T TO DO THE DIFFICULT.
OF DOING THAT CAN YOU HELP ME
WITH THAT PLEASE YES I CAN AND I
THINK THEY HAVE TWO CHOICES ONE
IS. TO THE BALLOT LATE ACCESS.
FOLLOWED THE- PROTOCOL AND
THEREFORE WE DON'T YOU KNOW IT
IS AVAILABLE TO ANYONE WHO COMES
ASIDE. THAT THIS IS THAT CAN AT
IDENTA THE AGE OF THAT YOU. AT
2 DEGREES I THINK I HAVE TO SAY
AT THIS POINT THAT. MOST OF
THESE COMPANIES DO IDENTIFY THE
H. OF THE USER. READY AT BUT
THEY WISH HIM WELL I'M NOT
SECURE NOT PREVIOUSLY PRESENT
THANK NOT TRANSPARENT AND
ANOTHER TO THE BUS. SO I THINK
THAT THE VISIONS EIGHT SURE. BUT
IS DONE RIVAS THE PRESENT BASIS
AND ACTUALLY PULLS THE PREFER OF
CHILDREN RATHER THAN EXTENDS
FURTHER SURVEILLANCE INTO THEM
AND ALSO JUST TO SAY THE IN THE
U. K. WE HAVE ACTUALLY POST
LOOKING AT AGE STEP THIS IS WHAT
YOU DON'T. UNDER NEED TO KNOW.
IT IS OF A CHILD YOU JUST NEED
TO KNOW ROUGHLY WHERE THEY ARE
ROUGHLY WHERE YOUR USER GROUP IS
AT AND SO FOR EXAMPLE. AT VIDEO
SEVEN LEGAL TAXED YOU DON'T
REALLY NEED TO KNOW WHETHER THAT
SEVEN EIGHT OR ELEVEN AB YEAH
BUT YOU MAY WISH TO KNOW THAT
THAT NOT SO. THANK AND- POSTED
THERE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
CORPORATIONS TO BE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS- THAT- MY COLLEAGUE
WAS REFERRING TO I WOULD OFFER-
EMILY COMING TODAY TO TESTIFY
TESTIFY IS A GOOD IS A PRIME
EXAMPLE OF A COMPANY NOT
FOLLOWING. OF DOING WHAT'S THE
PERSON IN A STEP PUTTING THEIR
BOTTOM LINE IN FRONT AND SO I
WOULD JUST SUGGEST THIS IS
DEPUTISING CORPORATIONS IT'S
RATHER. THEM TO A MINIMUM. THAT
EVERYBODY ELSE IS ALSO TO BE. ON
SO THAT'S THE DISTINCTION THAT I
WOULD MAKE RESPECTFULLY THANK
YOU AND IF I MIGHT SAY IN
RESPONSE TO THAT IS TO SAY THAT
FOR MANY YEARS. I.
IT TAKES STANDS USE AND ACTUALLY
IT IS ONE OF HUNDREDS OF THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE IN RESPONSE.
TO A SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO
PRODUCT DESIGN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WISH TO SPEAK OR HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT NONE. I JUST WANNA MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS FIRST WANT TO THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WICKS IN
CUNNINGHAM FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDER
MY STEP TO MAKES. CAN PRINT I
THINK THAT. I'M TAKING GOING TO.
I ALSO WANTTO. OUR IN
PARTICULAR WANT THANK YOU A AND
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FIGHT R. S. WERE
DON'T HAVE THE- OF. ANY OF YOU
BUT I'M STILL PRODUCT YOU- AND I
AM AM. APOLOGY FOR COMING UP
HERE BOY TO THINK WHAT'S- OUR
FEELING. PRESS ANY FOR COMMITTEE
PROPERTY IT'S- IS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR ME AND I THINK FOR THIS- AND
A LOT OF WHAT WE HEARD AT THAT-
AT THAT HEARING AT THE NEW FOR
HERE GET TREMENDOUS PAUSE- THAT
. COUNTY YEAH A LOT OF WORK.
WHICH IS THAT YOU ARE FACING
TODAY AND I THINK WE THAT. TODAY
OUR COLLEAGUES MEMBER POWER K. I
WAS PRETTY STRUCK SOME OF THE
PURPLE TESTIMONY THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUT SHARE HIS KIDS OLDER
THAN. HE GAVE ME A LITTLE BIT TO
WHAT IS. A FEW ALL OF THE ISSUE
HE HAS SEEN AND FELT AND OF PER.
WE PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN
THEY'RE RIDING IN CARS HOW DO WE
PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN
THEY'RE ON PLAYGROUNDS THAT ARE
WALKING TO SCHOOL. BUT POSTPONED
LIKE THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
TEENAGERS THIS CLOSE TO EIGHT
HOURS A DAY AT ONE. TWENTY THIRD
OF THE I DON'T WANT. SIR IT
FOCUSED ON PROTECTING. PLACE
ANYONE I MEAN WE HEARD FOR
RESEARCHERS WHO TALKED ABOUT THE
PHYSICAL THE MENTAL THE
EMOTIONAL RISKS TO OUR ONLINE
AND THEY ARE VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND SO I'M REALLY.
YOU THAT. BILLS BUT FOR THIS
YEAR WE HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS.
ISSUED A PROTECTING YOUNG PEOPLE
ONLINE- I THINK THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT PART CONVERSATION
THY'RE CURRENTLY A- PUBLIC. NEW
TO WORK. MOVING FOR TRAVEL. THE
AUTHORS FOR DOING. SOME GOOD
WORK THIS BILL WITH SAID I THINK
THERE ARE THERE IS GREAT OF WORK
LEFT TO BE DONE ON THE LANGUAGE
AND BILL- LET OF THE PREVIOUS.
IS NOT VERY. I KNOW. THIRTY TWO
KIDS NO WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES.
WILL COME UP TODAY AROUND AND
FORCE AROUND THE TASK FORCE
THEIR THINGS THAT THAT STILL TO
BE FOR. OUTTHIS BILL TODAY.
WHEN ASKED YOU WITH STOP WITH
THE WITH THE COMMITTEE WAS AS
THE BILL TOWARD WE WANT TO BE
INVOLVED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THE STRONG PART I THINK WE'RE
TAKE VERY TODAY WITH. IT NOT
HAVE. THANK SEAT. A LOT. WORK
PRACTICE THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE YEAH AND I WOULD LEAVE
FOR A CALL ASSEMBLY KILEY YOU
KNOW ONE OF THINGS THAT STRUCK
ME FROM THE FROM HEARING. UP FOR
OUT OF IN THE FRAME OF SAFETY
RIGHT IT'S NOT KNOWN B. AND M.
OF EARNESTLY TO THIS NOBODY
WANTS TO FIND OF A- IT WHICH
ARE. FROM HELP YOU COVER.
PRODUCTS A- CHECK PEOPLE RIGHT-
YOU THINK ABOUT THE SEAT IN A
CAR RIGHT NOBODY SAID THE DO
AWAY WITH CARS TO PEOPLE ARE
GONNA ACCESS IN THEY'RE GOING
HURT HOW DO WE GO SAY FEET. SIGN
UP AND I THINK THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IT TODAY IS BILLED. INTO
JUST IN OF OUR ONLINE PROPERTY
AND SERVICES SO I THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
THIS BELT. WHAT WHAT. THAT CAR.
FORTY THE NIFTY. WE WORK WITH
ALL OF YOU I AM. HAPPY TO SEE
THE BILL AND WITH THAT YOU CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT MUCH
OF THE CONVERSE. YOU KNOW AND I
TO THIS BILL SELFISH REAL MOM
I'VE GOT A FIVE YEAR OLD AND AN
ALMOST TWO YEAR OLD AND OLD
LOVES THE THIS IS MY- FIVE YEAR
OLD- NO THAT WERE FOR HER RIGHT
IT'S RELATIVELY- CHRIS. PAUL
WELL THERE WERE A I WOULD HEARD
IT MUCH FOR IN. WHERE PAGE WE
HAVE FAITH THEM WE HAVE FAILED
THEM LAWMAKER AND IT IS OUR OUR
NUMBER ONE DO ISLAMIC IS TO
WORKING SAFE PERIOD RIGHT
COMMUNITY BLIND NOW IT'S NOT
SAFE FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF
OUR CHILDREN. I DO WHAT. BUTTON
UP JUST GOT. WE FIGURE OUT OF IT
BUT- WE'VE HAD MORE MEMBER A LOT
MORE IS PERRANCE TECHNO FOR. AND
THAT'S BEEN A REALITY OR KIDS
ARE A LOT MORE AND THE REALITY
OF THE MATTER IS THAT WE NEED A
STRONGER REGULAR IRONMAN FOR THE
- B. I THINK. A LOT OF THAT BIT
THE PARENTS. PAY YOU THEY CARE
ABOUT THE RIGHT THEY WANDERED
THE KIDS TO BE SAFE ONLINE WELL
BUT A- OF. IT THIS. IS THIS
ISSUE OF TOP SAFETY MAKE IT IN
THEIR SEATS CONVERSATIONS AS
PARTY NUMBER ONE OR TWO IS IT.
ISN'T AT THE- AND- AS PART.
WONDERED NINE. MEETING OF.
MORNING WHAT. ABOUT HOW
ENGINEERING. TO PASS THEY'RE
PUTTING THIS ISSUE. AND SO
THAT'S WHAT BILLS OF. I WILL
CAN. MISTER CHAIR TO WORK WITH
THE TECH COMPANIES I WILL MEET
WITH ANY OF THEM. NEED AND- HOW
WE CAN MADE. A PLEA CRAFT ALL
THAT HONORS THE INTENT. OF IT
STILL ENABLES OUR TWO COMPANIES
TO STEP UP TO THE PROPERTY
REALLY BE PART OF. POLLUTION
HERE SO THAT. I'D LOVE. I WOULD
LIKE TO. DO AS WELL BUT I WOULD.
FOR AN ITEM. I RESPECTFULLY.
GOES WELL. WONDERFUL WELL THANK
VERY MUCH WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN MOTION ON THE BILL.
MOVED BY SIMPLY OF OUR K. HANTEC
BY ASSEMBLY BEN- OUT OF COURT
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO TWO SEVEN.
DO A AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GABRIEL
HI GABRIEL I KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING THERE CAN BARRICADE HAND
I'D- AYE BENNETT AYE BERMAN.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FONG-
FONG I IRWIN IRWIN HI VALLADARES
BALLADEERS AYE WICKS AYE WICKS
AYE WILSON WILSON I. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT WE ARE GOING TO
TRY TO GET SOMEONE BACK IN ORDER
I THINK NEXT UP. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON IT'S GOING TO BE A
PRIVATE TO A SINGER SOME
IMMIGRATION.
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR COLLABORATION TO WORK ON
THIS BILL IT WILL BE ACCEPTING
THAT THE AMENDMENT AS OUTLINED
IN THE AND NOW IT'S A BIG NIGHT
ZERO FOUR WILL PROVIDE. WE'LL
DISCUSS WHEN THEY WAS. AT
NANCIAL SERVICE COMPANIES SUCH
AS DEBT SETTLEMENT OR STUDENT
LOAN DEBT RELIEF SERVICES THERE
HAS BEEN- OR AT LEAST- ALWAYS-
BEEN A CERTAIN ABOUT THE HARM
FROM DECEITFUL PREDATORY
MARKETING PRACTICES THAT SHOW IN
THE WORLD FULL SERVICE. AND YET
THERE ARE NO CLEAR RULES. AT
LEAST A OF FOUR COMPANIES FOLLOW
AND SENDING TARGETED
ADVERTISEMENTS ALLOWING THEM TO
USE UNDERHAND METHODS TO CONFUSE
CONSUMERS SO IN SOME CASES
TARGETED ADVERTISEMENTS
IDENTIFYING CONSUMED BY NAY.
WILL LIST DEBTS DO NOT ACT- FROM
THAT THE MAY I THE MAIL IS
ACTUALLY FROM CREDITOR THESE
TACTICS CAN BE ESPECIALLY
ANXIETY INDUCING AND HARMFUL FOR
FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE CONSUMERS
ALREADY DEALING NEVER GET
FINANCIAL STRESS. AB NINETEEN
ZERO FOUR WHEELER THAT'S THIS BY
REQUIRING COMPANIES TO INCLUDES
THREE BASIC. IN ANY TARGET
ADVERTISEMENT THAT IS THE NAME
OF THE COMPANY THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION AND ALSO A STATEMENT
THAT INFORMS THE CONSUMER THAT
THEY- THEY ARE LOOKING AT AN
ADVERTISEMENT THIS BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO MANY FORMS OF
ADVERTISEMENTS SUCH AS
TELEVISION ADS OR OTHER PARTS OF
MASS APPETITE SO THE BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT MESSAGE. PER PROP
MARKET ACTORS TO GET SUMMER THE
THEY NEED TO MAKE INFORMED
CHOICE AND- WITH THAT MY PRIMARY
WITNESSES ACTUALLY IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE TESTIFYING SO I'M
FLYING SOLO ON THIS ONE YOU'RE
DOING GREAT OUR- THAT WILL GO OR
ANY WE. SIGNAL LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. THIS ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ON THE PHONE I'M
SORRY IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE
ZERO FOUR. KEITH TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THEIR OWN YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THE NON WE WILL GO
BACKTO. STOP IT OR IS THERE
ANYONE ON WILL ON THE PHONE WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE NINE OF. ONE OF THEIR OWN
A TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THE COMMAND
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU
WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY-
WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE NEXT WE
HAVE A- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT.
A SECOND SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- AND FOR WORKING
WITH. MY STEP IN WITH ME TO
FURTHER ENHANCE THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS IN THE BILL. IT'S A
GREAT BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
YOU TAKEN TO. BUT THEY WERE.
ADDED TO. AND APPLIED THIS IS A
REPLACE AND THOUGHT WELL
IMPORTANT BELL AND WITH THAT YOU
MAKE. THANK YOU AND I WANT TO
YOU ALL FOR TO BE A AUTHOR TO
HAVE HAVE YOUR BOARD I WANT TO
JUST FOR THE STATE STATE FOR THE
RECORD THAT DAN COME. ON COME
COME RECALL IT WAS. WITH THAT AT
RISK ASK. EVERYBODY IS WE HAVE
COMMITTEES GOT TIMES THIS IS
THAT THIS IS JUST BASED AROUND
HERE AT MOMENT ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. MEDITECH PLEASE THE ROLL
THE NET EN OF HIS DEEP BASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATE
COMMITTEE K. HI GABRIEL I CAN.
AN THEN IT Y. BEN I BURN.
CUNNINGHAM FONG- FONG I IRWIN-
WHEN I VALLEY DERIS. WICKS AND
WILSON. ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
BUT THE.
ONE YOUR- WE WANT TO BRING. YEAH
FOR MOVING FASTER WE ARE WE
PICKED UP THE PACE A LITTLE BIT
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR
WHEN YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF GREAT
BILLS UP TO DATE WITH. BROKEN SO
. RESENTED TWENTY. I THINK I
JUST HAVE ONE CORRECT YES A
COUPLE OF LITTLE CONCERN- NO NO
ANYBODY WENT OUT AND I SENT OUT
A WE HAVE ONE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU A TWENTY
THE.
LAST YEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN IN AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTED NISA
DEVELOPED GUIDELINES FOR
CYBERSECURITY LABELING A CYBER
SECURITY LABELING SCHEME FOR
CONSUMER I O. T. DEVICES THERE
IS MISTER. OUR CRITERIA FOR.
BILLING SCHEME. AND CONCLUDED IT
WAS PREFERABLE TO ALLOW VARIOUS
LABELING SCHEMES OWNED BY PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE SECTOR ORGANIZATIONS
TO BE UTILIZED. CYBER SECURE
LABELS ONCE BY THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ADOPTED BY MANUFACTURERS
WILL EMPOWER CONSUMERS TO MAKE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ABOUT THE
SECURITY OF THEIR SMALL HOME.
HE'S A- SEVERAL IS WITHOUT
PUBLIC SECTOR PARTNER WHILE OFF
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO TO
GIVE ADDITIONAL UP TO NOT ONLY
SUPPORT THE CREATE THE FLY IS
LABELING SCHEMES BUT ALL TO
THEIR IOTV. INSTEAD BY. MISTER
CERTAIN THE MAN OF MORE
INFORMATION TO COULD ALL WITHOUT
SACRIFICE ANY SECURITY SO THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE THE U. L.
LABEL THAT YOU SEE ON YOUR ELECT
DEVICE TALKS FIFTY ELECT IS THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE IIOT TO
SAID TO U. S. EIGHT DAN- I JUST
. BUT IF NOT YOUR- GOING TO. DOT
A AHAB OF IT. THEY WANT
COMPLIANCE TO ENOUGH FOR YOU ANY
LABELS AND AGAIN THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS FOR THIS TO BE AN
OPTIONAL THE BOWLING GAME WE
HOPE SUMER WILL A DEMAND IT AND
WE ARE COULD BURKE TUMOR. I
THINK. IT IS THAT IS TO DO MORE
WITH. TAKE THANK SECOND ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR QUE
HANNAH SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VAN TO ANYWAY SINCE.
SINAN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES MUST OPERATOR TO
HAVE ANYONE THIS IS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO.
PRESS PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE CAN USE YOUR PHONE
IT'S ONE AND THEN THERE. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MATTER
STANDING AS OUR PRIMARY BOB IS
IT IS JUST COME IN WITH. REPORT
FROM. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE JUSTIN
BROOKMAN. THANK YOU THAT LINE IS
OPEN MISTER BROOKLYN ARE YOU
ABLE TO UNMUTE. UNFORTUNATELY NO
RESPONSE AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE
ARE AT WHAT HOW BOUT WHAT WE
GONNA GO THEN AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO BE TWO THREE NINETY TWO OF.
C. NOT GO BACK TO THE IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE IN OFF
INTO AB TWENTY THREE NINETY TWO
. YOU CAN EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE.
TEST. WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES
WITH OPERATORS ME JUST A MOMENT.
YEAH.RIGHT RIGHT SO THE FIRST
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION IS LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SORRY OF MONEY THAT THEY COME
FROM THE COOKIE HOLDEN COMPARE
THAT MY CONCERN WITH THE SPELL
AND FAT THE NEXT GUIDELINES ARE
NOT. FINALIZED AT EIGHT- AND
THEY ALSO- EIGHT AND- ASK YOU
YOUR NAY AND I'M ONLY PLEASE.
THE COMPANY YOU HAVE. A THANK
YOU. SIX WE HAVE MY NINETY. HI
AFTERNOON- JOHN CAN LOCATION
HOPE FIVE MANUFACTURERS BENEFIT
WIENER FOR THE WORK OF KUN FOR
THANK YOU. TURN OFF FOR THE
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WITH THAT WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT SEE NUMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR-
BRING FOR THIS BILL IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN PROVIDING
CLARITY AS TO HOW. MANUFACTURERS
MY COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENT
THE- DEVICES I'M EQUIPPED WITH.
REASONABLE SECURITY FEATURES.
THE ANALYSIS THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT A LANGUAGE THAT MIGHT CREATE
CONFUSION AS TO WHETHER THIS IS
THE SOLE MEANS OF COMPLYING WITH
. THE LAW. OUR APPROACH IS. WE
HAVE. THAT TOUCHES LATTER. MAYBE
A CLARIFICATION THAT WE CAN MAKE
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD- BY.
WHAT I AM. DOUBTFUL TO WORK. IT
AS- FOR HOW TO SUPPORT THE OKAY
. THANK YOU FOR. WITH CLOSE. OF
WELL I FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS IS
THE KIND OF- INFO. OF WHAT WE
DID A FEW YEARS AGO WITH A O. T.
DEVICES REQUIRE. BASIC SECURITY
ON THINGS LIKE YOUR DOORBELLS-
YOU'RE- A SMART. YOU'RE SMART.
WE WERE VERY PLEASED THAT THAT
WAS THE FIRST BILL IN THE UNITED
STATES AND MANY STATES HAVE
SINCE FOLLOWED SUIT SO THIS TO
US IS A LOGICAL NEXT STEP TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. DEGREE
ARE A MINUTE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO MOTION IS DUE PASS
GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I KILEY
ARCADIAN ARCADIAN I BENNETT
BENNETT I BERMAN CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING FONG FONG
I IRWIN AYE- WHEN I VALLADARES
AYE DERIS AYE WICKS. WILSON
WILSON HI. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO MOTION IS TO PASS
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. OKAY
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO GO NEXT TO MR LOW AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE. COULD HAS
THERE FOR MY FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND A GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE FIRST OFF
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO THIS LEGISLATION
AND I APPRECIATE THAT NOW SINCE
AS WELL IN CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION HERE TODAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROTECT MANY OF OUR
CHILDREN IT'S PAST FROM- DATE.
ARE THEY ARE CASTING CURRENT
CITY COUNCILMAN FROM THE TOWN OF
LOS GATOS. RICO SAY OCT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR YOUTH EXPECT THE ASK PRIVATE
. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY%
MEMBER MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN IN
A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON. CAN NOW GO AYE COUNSELOR
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL
MAKE THIS BRIEF AS ALREADY
MENTIONED MY NAME IS MARIE TO
FIND OUT AND I AM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR KATHY WERE NONPROFIT
AGENCY THAT PARTNERS WITH BOTH
OF THEM THE TAILOR OF THE
CORPORATE COUNTY. AT. GOOD BYE.
BOEING OF MOTIONAL DISTRESS OUR
CHILDREN WE NEED PARTS I CAN
ATTEST THAT THIS IS AN ON
DILEMMA THAT OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE
. UNFORTUNATELY LOST A CHILD IN
OUR COMMUNITY JUST THIS MONTH
BECAUSE HE WAS BY PURPORTED TO
APPOINT BUT HE BELIEVES HIS SIDE
BUT ONLY A TO A IT. WE HAVE.
PROTECT CHILDREN FROM BULLYING
AND ARE ARE AN PART IN THE
EFFORT I THAT WE ALSO AT THE- TO
PROVIDE TOOLS. SO THAT WE CAN
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN FROM
CYBERBULLYING TO CARE FOR THEIR-
CALL THANKS FOR YOUR CONCERN FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL WELL BEING AND
CONSIDERATION OF THE- OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT WE WILL
TURN TO ANYONE ASSISTANCE APART
IN THE HEARING ROOM IS READY
WHEN THE HEARING. WAS JUST
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SEVENTY NOT. SCENE AND WE WILL
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINE
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWENTY EIGHT SEVEN NINE
. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE ON YOUR
PHONE. THAT IS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES
IN KEEP. OKAY TURNING IT TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
A PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
LIANNA TALKING FROM TECH THAT
WHO IS ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE WILL BE
ANY COCKTAIL ATTACK THAT AND WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY BOTH VERSION OF
AB TWENTY. NINE IN PRINT TODAY
THE PERSON AT THE MOMENT THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSING ALISON AND
MEETINGS THE OSCAR FOR ACCEPTING
ARMS. AS THEY IMPROVE THE BILL.
THE THIRD. PROBABLY THOUGHT OF A
FEW CONCERNS THAT WE HOPE WILL
BE ADDRESSED YOU SEE AND THAT.
WE CAN TO BELIEVE THE A
SEPARATE. MY FOR SCHOOL. FOR
LITTLE INCREASE NUMBER OF
BALLING APART HOLDING A COCKTAIL
INTO OUR EXISTING REPORT MAKING
IT. ARE COMPANIES ARE- OPEN TO
FIND AN OFFICIAL WAY TO MAKE IT
EASIER SCORED. TO REPORT
INCIDENTS THE FACT THAT.
FURTHERMORE TO AND I'M OF THE I
THINK FOR THE ON. HOW PERSONALLY
PLATFORM POTTER HARDBALL. FOR A
THE WORKING ON A BILL THAT SHE
CALLED HOLLISTER. AND WITH THE
FOR. APPROACH THAN ONE FOCUSED
ON SPECIFIC CONTENT ISSUE. AGAIN
WHILE WE ARE RESPECT OPPOSE THE
VERSION. THANKS WE FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TAKEN TO
REFINE THE LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE HEARING ROOM ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE. AND WE WILL GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE. Q. TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. ONCE AGAIN IT'S
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE AT
LEAST ONE COMMENT TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. OUR COMMON COMES ONLINE
NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON RUN NOT
THE ALONG WITH ALL CHAMBER
ALIGNING ARE COMMON THE
TECHNICIAN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. NO FURTHER LINES INTO IT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITHOUT WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT SCENE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
LOW FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
ME ON THE AMENDMENTS- AND I'D
WANT TO JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON PROTECTING KIDS- AND I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS ON
REQUIRING INNER CYBER BILLING
REPORTING POLICY. TO BE. THE
SEARCH. PLATFORMS TURN. PRESS M.
I THINK WE AGREE THAT FOR FAR
TOO LONG SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN INTENTIONALLY OPAQUE
ABOUT THEIR INTERNAL. PRACTICES
AND PROCEDURES. WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PARENTS AND TEENS TO MAKE
INFORMED CHOICES WHEN
INTERACTING WITH SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS IS ONE OF THREE BILLS THIS
COMMITTEE'S HEARING TODAY POP
PROTECTING KIDS ONLINE. IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE OF NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL PARKS AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO GET IT RIGHT.
TO THAT END OF ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. ON ON SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL. THE BENEFITS THE OFFERS.
WHAT MINISTRY TO NUKE. ARE
PROPERLY BALANCED IN SUBURBAN
THE- PLACES. DELTA APPRECIATE
THIS REDEVELOPMENT CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR AND LOOK TO THE
CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP AS WELL AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. WE HAD
A MOTION AND  SECOND SIR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
DIGEST SHERRY COMMITTEE GABRIEL
HI GABRIEL I CUT. BARRICK AND
THEN IT'S BEEN I BERMAN CUTTING
. CUNNINGHAM I. FONG FONG AYE
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VELADERO.
WICKS WILSON WILSON I. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL WILL BE
THE ROLE OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS
THANK YOU MR LAU I THINK NEXT WE
ARE GOING TO DO GO TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE EIGHT. NINETEEN.
OKAY WELL. YEAH. CAN WE GAS.
HELLO AND GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ARE YOU ALL DOING TODAY. DOING
FANTASTIC AB NINETEEN SEVENTEEN
WOULD ENSURE THAT PERSONAL
INFORMATION COLLECTED THROUGH
CONTACT TRACING CANNOT BE USED
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
COVERED EIGHTEEN PANDA. EIGHT
AND A HALF MILLION CASES OF CODE
NINETEEN IN CALIFORNIA IN OVER
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE
HAVE DIED AS A RESULT OF THE
VIRUS ONE OF THE STRATEGIES USED
TO LIMIT THE TRANSMISSION OF
COVED NINETEEN AS BEEN THE USE
OF CONTACT IN. TRIDENTINE INTO.
POSITIVE FOR. HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH SOME OF YOU MAY
HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS. MEASURES
MUST BE TAKEN TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND THE PUBLIC TRUST
THE CONTACT TRACING INFORMATION
WILL NOT BE USED
INAPPROPRIATELY. BY A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN MINORITY
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHO'VE
BEEN TO. IMPACTED BY CO THAT.
REPORTS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS BEING USED TO CONDUCT
CONTACT TRACING IS NOT ONLY A
POOR USE. OF PUBLIC RESOURCES IT
IS INAPPROPRIATE. ANNA WROTE
PUBLIC LAST. FOR CONTROL OF THIS
AND FUTURE PANDEMIC THROUGH THE
USE OF CONTACT TRACING AB
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN WILL INCREASE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN FUTURE
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS AND
ENSURE THAT CONTACT TRACING DATA
IS USED ALL THE- PROPUBLICA
PURPOSES. WITH RIDE TESTIMONY.
FROM THE VALUE IS MS BECKER
KRAMER MATTER. THANK A CREAMER
OF A CELL YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN SUPPORT AB NINETEEN SEVENTEEN
CENTERS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES ENSURING
ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN PARTICIPATE
AND IMPORTANT CONTACT TRACING
EFFORTS IT IS IN LINE WITH OTHER
RECENT LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVES
TO MOVE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSES
FROM THE POLICE I'M FOR. ONLY
FACING AND PRETENSION BASED THUS
FAR ON ENTANGLEMENT OF POLICE
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE COOPERATE
WITH CONTACT TRACING. CONTACT
TRACING INFORMATION ABOUT WHO A
PERSON WAS WITH WHEN AND WHERE
IS COLLECTED BY POLICE IT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH
GOALS BECAUSE PEOPLE MAY SHARE
LESS OF THEIR PERSONAL AND- IF
IT. M. AND I'M OR RISK LABELING
THEM AS AN ASSOCIATE OF A
SUPPOSED GANG MEMBER FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S ALSO A HIGH DEGREE OF
DISTRUST FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
MANY COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
IMMIGRANTS AND THOSE THAT ARE
MOST IMPACTED BY POLICE VIOLENCE
AND OVER POLICING. DURING CHASE
THANK WHAT HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
RATHER THAN BY LAWN IS IMPORTANT
FOR ENSURING THESE COMMUNITIES
FELT COMFORTABLE TALKING WITH
CONTACT TRACERS ABSENT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN SAFEGUARD
AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT ENGAGING
IN CONTACT TRACING PEOPLE ARE
LIKELY TO WITHHOLD INFORMATION
IS WHICH YOU CAN COMMUTE TO THE
OUT. IF YOU THINK TWENTY ENSURES
THAT BUT HEALTH RESPONSES TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES ARE
HANDLED BY THE PEOPLE BEST
PREPARED TO DO SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK
YOU. YOU MUCH ARE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE- HEARING ROOM THOUGH LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN. SEEING NONE
WE WILL MOVE TO THE FRONT LINES
MISTRUST RAIDERS OR ANYONE ON
THE ON ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN. ID LIKE TO.
EXPRESS SUPPORT AND HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
. GEN NUMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND STRUCK
THE COURT THANK YOU. THANKS WE
HAVE LINE FIFTY FIVE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY WAS NUMBER
CALLING FROM OAKLAND PRIVACY SO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU
FOR THE ALLIANCE IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THAT TIME WE WILL TURN TO WIN
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION THERE IS
NO PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN. SINAN WILL GO BACK TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN.
PRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
OVER THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. THOSE NUMBERS ARE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK YOU MR LEVINE FOR
THIS BILL THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE SEEN THIS PHONE
PRIVACY- BUT HOPEFULLY WILL BE
THE LAST THAT IT'S GOING TO BE-
ON ITS JOURNEY. M. AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
PUBLIC TRUST IN CONTACT TRACING
METHODS ALL STAR INSURING THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN KEEP BOTH
THEIR WORK FORCES AND THOSE IN
OUR JAILS AND PRISONS SAFER
WITHOUT VERY HAPPY SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY YOU MAY. THANK YOU
FOR. MUCH SHARE. THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER THE
THOUGHTFUL. ANALYSIS AND
HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE A THIRD
THREE. THIRD TIME'S THE CHARM ON
THIS ONE FIVE SUBCLASS FROM
ABOUT. THAT YOU KNOW. ALL RIGHT
I'D LIKE ESTAMOS NOT ITSELF.
COMMOTION FROM SOME OF OUR QUE
HIM. SECONDED BY SOME REMEMBER
FONG MEADOW CREEK YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL AB NINETEEN SEVENTEEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I KILEY BAUER K. HAN.
ERA CAN I BAN IT. BERMAN
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FONG
FONG AYE IRWIN VALLADARES FELLA
THERE'S NOT VOTING WICKS AND
WILSON WILSON I. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL KEEP THE RAW OPTION FOR UP
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MAYOR YOU MISTER
UNITY IN NUMBERS ALL RIGHT WE
ARE GOING TO GO NEXT TO. WE HAVE
AN AUTHOR. THANK GO. WE JUST HAD
TO NOW WE'VE NOT. WE'VE GOT YOU
THE HALL. WITHIN THE HOME. YEAH. I THINK IT'S GONNA THAT'S
SPRINKLED A LITTLE BETTER K. HIM
INTO THE MIX. ALL RIGHT WE GOING
TO BE MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWO ZERO. EIGHT NINE BY
SO WE MOVED OUR CAKE AND. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FIRST- I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL- FROM ITS
INCEPTION TO TODAY. AND WITH
THAT I'LL BE TAKING AMENDMENTS
ON THIS BILL TO MOVE THE
PROVISIONS TO THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THE MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT TO PROTECT.
PROTECTIONS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
DATA UNDER EXISTING LAW NAROW
THE DEFINITION FOR COVERED
MENTAL HEALTH APPS AND REMOVED
THE REGISTRATION REQUIREMENT AND
INSTEAD REQUIRE APPS TO NOTIFY
PROVIDERS OF VIOLATIONS UPON.
CONTRACTING WITH THEM. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ON AB TWENTY EIGHTY
NINE WHICH WILL HELP PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF THOSE WHO USE MENTAL
HEALTH APPS. THINK ABOUT THESE
QUESTIONS WHAT SURGERIES ARE
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE YOU HAD
HOW OFTEN IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
HOW OFTEN IN THE LAST YEAR HAVE
YOU HAD FIVE OR MORE ALCOHOLIC
DRINKS ON ONE OR MORE OCCASIONS.
WHICH MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION
HAVE MEMBERS OF YOUR FAMILY BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH. ON A SCALE OF
ONE TO THREE HOW OFTEN DO YOU
FEEL THAT SOMETHING TERRIBLE
MIGHT HAPPEN. IF YOU ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS IN A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE ANY INFORMATION COLLECTED
WOULD BE PROTECTED BY HIPPA. BUT
IF YOU ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS
CAN TO CONNECT TO A PROVIDER
THROUGH AN APP YOUR INFORMATION
WOULD ONLY BE ACTED BY THE C.
PUREE. THIS IS COULD AT AS WE
SELL THE INFORMATION OR USER FOR
ADVERTISING. SB SINCE DAMAGE MY
OCCURS THIS IS A- WITH AS MANY
AS TWENTY THOUSAND APPS IN THIS
CASE GLOW- IS. PUT HER
ADVERTISEMENT IN. BASED OFF A
PROBLEM DYCHE. THEN THEY WILL
REQUIRE A DETAILED SURVEY WITH
QUESTIONS TARGETING HIGHLY
SENSITIVE INFORMATION LIKE THE
ONES I'VE GIVEN YOU. WE'VE SEEN
DATA SHARED WITH THESE APPS SHOP
ACROSS THE INTERNET AND EVEN
SOLD TO THIRD PARTIES. A STUDY
OF THE THIRTY SIX TOP RANKED
APPS FOR DEPRESSION AND SMOKING
FOUND THAT TWENTY NINE
TRANSMITTED DATA SERVICES
PROVIDED BY FACEBOOK OR GOOGLE.
IT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THE
PEOPLE RECEIVING CARE THEY KNOW
HOW THEIR DATA IS SHARED AND HOW
IT IS PROTECTED IF AT ALL. THIS
BILL WOULD SIMPLY EQUALIZE THE
PROTECTIONS FOR DATA THAT
CONNECTS PATIENTS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BY INCLUDING THESE
APPS AND SIEMIATYCZE. THE SECOND
PORTION OF THE BILL IS TO AID
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TO WORK
WITH GOOD. WHEN APPS WITH
PROVIDERS THEY MUST INFORM THE
PROVIDERS AND ENSURE THAT THEY
KNOW IF THESE ARE GOOD ACTORS.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IS HEALTH
CARE AND TODAY WHEN YOU SEEK
THAT HELPED HER THROUGH THESE
APPS YOUR INFORMATION IS NOT
PROTECTED AS HEALTHCARE DATA
THIS BILL WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN CHANGING THAT
LANDSCAPE WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS HAYLEY. TSUKAYAMA
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE ACTIVITY THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND THEN DETESTS IMPOSSIBLE
POLICY ANALYST AT CONSUMER
REPORTS MAYBE THEY'RE BOTH ON
THE FRONT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE. THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
THEM BOTH OF WHO WHO'S GOING
FIRST. I HAVE THAT AND- PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THANK YOU APRIL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KELLY PAMELA AND I AM YOUR
LEGISLATIVE ACCESS AT THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. AND THAT MAKE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS HAVE
TURNED ON FOR CARE PARTICULARLY
FROM THE HEALTHCARE MANY DIGITAL
SERVICES OF TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE INCREASED THE DEMAND. THEY
OFFER CARE CONNECTIONS PROVIDERS
PRESCRIPTION REPORT GROUP.
HOWEVER THE STATE OF NOT ALWAYS
KEPT PRIVATE AND COMMERCIAL
PLATFORMS ADVERTISING HERE BAKER
IS NOT PROVIDED IN THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE ARE NOT PROTECTED Y
HIPPA. THAT'S OUT OF LINE WITH
THE EXPECTATIONS PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS HAVE REGARDING. FOR THE
- AND URGENTLY PURSUE AND PRETTY
STIGMA REGARDING MENTAL AS A
RESULT THERE IS A LEVEL OF
REASONABLE PEOPLE EXPECT WHEN
THEY ARE CONNECTED TO CARE THIS
TRUSTED UNDERMINE COMPANIES ARE
ABLE TO SHARE DIAGNOSES MEDICAL
HISTORIES AND OTHER SENSITIVE
INFORMATION OF THIS TYPE OF A
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FEDERAL
TRADE COMMISSION STUDY REVEALED
THAT CALL PERSON HEALTH APPS AND
ABOUT. IT IT IT. THIRD PARTY
SOME OF THE DATA COULD BE LINKED
BACK TO. EITHER ANY. EIGHTEEN
THIRD PART RECEIVED SPECIFIC I
CAN. IN TWENTY TWO RECEIVE OTHER
KEY HOW IMPROVE. THIS TYPE OF.
TREATABLE THE SHARING TEACHERS
CRIME AND THE CREDIT OF MENTAL
CARE. IT ALSO PUT THE BURDEN ON
PROVIDE TO THE AT HIM TO SEE CAN
BE FOR BY THE- THAT THEY- THE
HEALTH CARE. IS UNIQUE
VULNERABLE TO EXT. FOR
ADVERTISEMENT AFTER PROFIT.
PUTTING THE BILL THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH. DR FEEL STATED WE WERE
WITH INCREDIBLY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR CLIENT
INFORMATION THAT WHEN EXPLOITED
CAN LEAD TO PREDATORY
ADVERTISING OR EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION. WE DON'T HAVE
THAT WHEN WE USE DIGITAL
PLATFORMS ARE MAKE IT
RECOMMENDED TO OUR PATIENTS THEY
ARE EXACTLY A SECURE EITHER IN
PERSON. HE BELIEVES THE BILL'S.
TO PROVIDE NEEDED FOR PATIENTS
INFORMATION AND GET PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THEIR DATA IS
SHARED AND TO MEANINGFULLY
CONSENT TO THAT SHARING. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SRONGLY-
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT I NEED YOU TO SOME POT
FROM CONSUMER REPORTS. HEAR ME.
YES MANY. OKAY MY NAME IS DON
TALK ABOUT THE ANALYSTS AT
CONSUMER APART WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT NINE BECAUSE
THEY WOULD GET CONSUMERS KEEP
PROTECTIONS OVER THE PRIVACY OF
MENTAL HEALTH INFORMATION
COLLECTED DURING OUT BRING IT
INTO ALIGNMENT WITH PROTECTIONS
OVER THE PRIVATE HEALTH
INFORMATION COLLECTED IN A
MEDICAL SETTING THE COMPANY THAT
MAKE UP WHAT THE DEPRESSION. I
THINK KIND OF MADE IT HARDER TO
A CARE. MANY DIFFERENT HAVE
TURNED MENTAL HEALTH APPS TO
BUILD GAP BUT BECAUSE HE'S AFTER
IN TWO THOUSAND COVERED BY. HOPE
PRIVACY I CAN. CONSUMER DURABLE
TO INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE
RECORDER OF IN FROM. SUCH AS
WHETHER THEY SUFFER FROM AND OR
CO. STRESS.
FIVE HELP PRIVACY A LOT BUT THE
FAMILY ASKED ME PROVIDE NEW
TRACKING DIARRHEA OR THERAPY
TRAPASSO WHICH TYPICALLY WOULD
NOT BE COVERED. APPLE BECAUSE
CONSUMER REPORTS TESTING HAS
FOUND THAT MENTAL HEALTH APPS
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT USERS
WITH TECH COMPANIES THAT TRACK
THEIR BEHAVIOR ACROSS OTHER
APPS. AND THAT INFORMATION COULD
BE USED TO TARGET ADS GEO
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REACH OUT FOR HELP WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT HOW THEIR DATA
MIGHT BE SHARED OR NEXT YEAR.
WHEN I WAS THE ACTIVE DO ENOUGH
TO PROTECT SENSITIVE ABOUT THE
WHOLE DATA. ALLOW CONSUMERS TO
TALK TO SELL THE CHRISTMAS. BUT
THEY'RE STILL BY DEFAULT
PROHIBITS BOTH THEY'RE SHARING
AT ALL. MANY CONSUMERS ARE AWARE
OF THOSE RIGHT AND EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE AWARE. OF REPORTS ABOUT
THAT CONSUMERS OFTEN EXPERIENCE
DIFFICULTY OFTEN. TELL
INFORMATION. FINALLY PROPERTY
TWENTY FOUR AMENDED THE CCPA
TECH ALSO WITHOUT A PARTNER A
FEELING ON THE MEASURE. IT IS
INTENDED TO BE STRENGTHENED IN
ORDER TO BETTER PROTECT OUR
PRIVACY AND THAT'S EXACTLY THE
TYPE OF DATA THAT SHOULD HAVE
GREATER PROTECTION. FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BUDGET BASED ON OUR DRIVE. OUT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR MUCH WITH THAT WE WILL GUARD
ANYONE IN THE- ROOM WISHES TO.
SUPPORT FOR A BI TO TWO ZERO
EIGHT NINE. SEEING NONE WILL GO
BACK TO THE PHONE LINES.
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING THIS IS TRACY. B.
CALLING IN TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE.
WITHOUT LEARN OFFER THE LINES IN
COOPER SUPPORT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE HAVE-
PRIMARY. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I'M WE HAVE TO ON THE PHONE
THERE'S RUN ACT DIE DAYS LOBBY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
CONGRESS AND ALEXIS APPLE FROM
THE AMERICAN TELEMEDICINE
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRDS ROCKY ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
WE'RE NOT FORMALLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL THAT WE DO APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS OF AB TWENTY EIGHTY
NINE. I REALLY LIKE TO START
WRITING THE AUTHOR AFTER ALL THE
EXTENT THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
HAD AROUND THE ISSUE ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS WE ORIGINALLY
RATES OF THE BILL IN PRINCETON
TURN AROUND ESTABLISH A HOLE IN
THE STATUTORY SCHEME. WHICH WE
FELT TO BE CONFUSING OVERLY
BROAD AND NOT NECESSARY GIVEN
THE EXISTING PROTECTIONS
UNDERSTAND MY A AND C. K. ABOUT
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE AT THE
MOMENT THAT AWAY FROM THAT
APPROACH AND INSTEAD TRY TO
ADDRESS ANY ISSUES WITH AN
EXISTING PRACTICE THE LOT. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO REVIEW THE FEET
AND THE AMENDMENTS IN GREATER
DETAIL TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK TO
THE AUTHOR HONESTLY APPROACH
THAT BASED ON OUR INITIAL RE
WOULD YOU EXPECT THAT THERE MAY
BE SOME ADDITIONAL NARROWING AT
THE TERMS MENTAL HEALTH
APPLICATION MENTAL HEALTH
APPLICATION INFORMATION THAT MAY
BE NEEDED- FOR ONE IT'S NOT
ENTIRELY CLEAR TO US ON. THIS
INITIAL READ WHETHER MENTAL
HEALTH APPLICATION INFORMATION
MUST BE INDIVIDUALLY
IDENTIFIABLE TO BE CONSIDERED
MEDICAL INFORMATION UNDER THE
BILL FOR ANOTHER THERE MAY STILL
BE A NEED FOR THEIR- APPS TO
THOSE THAT CALL THEMSELVES OUT.
AT THE- PURPOSE AT THIS. MY
HEALTH. FOR WERE CONCERNED WITH
. THE SAID OF THE CASE AT THAT.
MEDIA PROVIDER THAT YOU FOLLOW-
LIKE THIS BILL CAN NOW BUY THEM
AS AN ADULT PROVIDER RICARDO
PROTECT LAWN FROM MATTER
INFORMATION UNDERSTAND MY A- WE
THINK IT'S BENEFICIAL. THEM
SURVEY IF THREE LIKE AT OUR
TRYING TO BUILD HER THE NEGATIVE
AT THE FOR THEM TO DO IF THEY
CAN BROUGHT IN INSTEAD ACT. LAST
WE HAVE THAT THE TO DIRECT
REQUIRE ARE IN THE BILL AND
PRINT- THAT THAT I DO WANT TO
FIND OUT. THE NEW PROVISION. APP
THIRD PARTY CLOSER TO AROUND
EIGHT APPRECIABLE ENCOUNTER. M.
I. A. FOR THE PRESENT WE
RESPECTFULLY REMIND THAT WE
REALLY LOOK FOR. THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE ALSO HAVE OUR
SECOND. IT WILL OPPOSITE WITNESS
. THAT AFTERNOON NUMBER MY NAME
IS ALEXIS APPLE WITH AJ ACTION
THE AMERICAN TELEMEDICINE
ASSOCIATION AFFILIATED TRADE IF
THE PATIENT FOCUSED ON ASKING.
EIGHTY ACTION BY THE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL BASED ON
THE VERSION THAT WAS IN PRINT ON
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
CANADIAN AUTHOR FOR THE
AMENDMENT IN THE CANADIAN OUT
THAT. WE ARE BEING IN THAT WITH
A MEMBERSHIP OUR REVENUE. RIGHT
MEANT HEALTH AT THE IMPROPER.
INTERSECTION OF A NEW PRIVATE
NETWORK HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
- ARE JUST. UP A THIRD PROVIDERS
THAT GENERAL. BOARD TO WORK WITH
YA. LEGISLATION WAS HARD THANK.
OKAY WITH THAT GONNA GO THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATORS ARE ANY ONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT TWO
ZERO EIGHT NINE. YOU FEEL LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S ONE
AND THEN THE ZERO PLEASE. WE DO
HAVE A LINE IN Q. WITH FLYING
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THOUGHT THAT AS THAT- WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED BE SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
CONCERN AND ARE BE EVALUATING
OUR POSITION IN MIND AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU. FOR THE LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MR PRATER WITH THAT WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS. WE ARE MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. SECOND
FROM SOME REMEMBER FONG- I THINK
I SAW MISTER CUNNINGHAM. YES SO
I THIS STRIKES ME AS VERY.
SUBTLY TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT
AND IT. SO THERE. THERE'S THREE
TWO DIMENSIONS TO RIGHT I MEAN
THE FIRST THING IS THE END RUN
AROUND HIP OF THE THESE ARE ABLE
TO WHICH IS. TURNING IN ANOTHER
ITSELF BUT THERE'S FINANCIAL
ASPECT BECAUSE I'VE KNOWN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE APPLIED FOR LIFE
INSURANCE FOR EXAMPLE AND THEY
HAVE TO SIGN DISCLOSURES OF HIP
ON THE IN ON THE DOCTOR'S
TREATMENT RECORDS ARE AND
THEY'RE AND THEY'RE SOMETHING.
WITH MAYBE THEY MENTION THAT A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW THEY
GET AND THEY LOSE WITH FORMS
FROM LIFE INSURANCE UNDERWRITER.
LIKE YOU KNOW HOW MANY TIMES
YOU'VE BEEN NEW COUNSELOR-
ANYTIME YOU DON'T EVER BEEN. IT
MEANT THE STUFF SO IT CAN BE. IT
YES SOMETHING WITH VALIDITY IN
THAT PARTICULAR CASE AND THINK
OF IT OF ALL. IT'S A- IT'S A
FINANCIAL HIT IF YOU. GO GET
LICENSE YOU NEED TO PROTECT YOUR
FAMILY BECAUSE OF SOME. THING
THEY GOT OUT THERE THAT- MAYBE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND IF THESE APPS
CAN DO A SIMILAR THING. I MEAN I
DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG. LEAP TO
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
GONNA BE DATA MINING OFFER THESE
APPS FOR INSURANCE UNDERWRITERS
EIGHT. SETS ONE ISSUE IN THE
OTHER ISSUES JUST. YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO GO SEEK
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. A FEW
OF THE PEOPLE THAT I'M TALKING
ACROSS PROFESSIONS. FIREFIGHTERS
COPS LAWYERS NEED TO DOCTORS THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE HIGH STRESS
JOBS THAT YOU KNOW THEY DON'T
WANT STUFF IN THE RECORD THAT'S
GOING TO CAUSE THEM A PROBLEM.
NO AND I IT IN LESS YOU HAVE THE
SUPER ACTION. AT CERTAIN. GIVES
ANYA THEN THAT HE WHERE ELSE. I
THINK YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE. ARE GONNA FORGO
TREATMENT THAT THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD HELP THEM. AND HELP THEIR
FAMILIES AND HELP THEM
PERSONALLY. SO I THINK IT'S
THROUGH. BILL AND TO SEE YOU
BRING IT FORWARD I DIDN'T. SORRY
I DIDN'T REALIZE THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF IT AND TOSSED
SITTING HERE LOOKING AT IT.
LISTEN THE TESTIMONY- PLEASE ADD
ME AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU IF YOU
SEE FIT TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ANY. ERA QUESTIONS CONCERNS
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT WELL I WILL
JUST A ECHO SOME OF WHAT I SAW
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM SAID I DO
THINK THIS IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT ON A THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING IT. IT'S SUCH
IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT. THE THE CATEGORIES
OF INFORMATION THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO YOU KNOW PROTECTING KEEP
PRIVATE I THINK WITH OUR MENTAL
HEALTH INFORMATION IS AT THE
VERY VERY TOP OF THAT LIST AND I
THINK THAT YOU HAVE- YOU KNOW I
COVERED. A TREMENDOUS ISSUE-
AND- I'M REALLY I THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND WANT TO APPLAUD THEM. I'M
FOR YOU KNOW CRAFTING WHAT I
THINK IS A VERY ELEGANT SOLUTION
HERE- TO CHANGE IT TO PUT IT
INTO. THE OFFICE THE PEOPLE ARE
FEELING A LOT MORE. WITH THAT'S
A REAL. SCHEME THAT PEOPLE. AND
CAN WORK WITH AND I THINK WITH
THAT- WE ARE WE ARE WELL ON THE
WAY SO VERY VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY- APPLIED
YOU FOR- FOR THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING HERE. AND WITH THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU THAT'S WHEN
I THINK I AM MISTER CUNNINGHAM
FOR HIS COMMENTS IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE MISS WALDRON- SPOKE UP
AND TALKED ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN FOR PEOPLE WHO FINALLY.
REACH OUT. AND USE THESE APPS
AND THEN THEY GO ON TO FACEBOOK
ANYTHING ADVERTISEMENT. ALL THE
SENATE. ABOUT MENTAL- THEY WERE
GETTING AND HOW THE SAID THEY
WOULD BE AFRAID. THE INFORMATION
IS OUT THERE IT WOULD MAKE THEM
TURN AWAY. FROM GET- THAT IS SO
DESK. NEED ESPECIALLY. IN TIME.
WITH A GREAT. OF REALLY. WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE AND WE ARE
GOING TO HOLD THE LINE ON SOME
IMPORTANT ISSUES WHICH IS YOU
KNOW EVEN IF IT'S DE IDENTIFIED
WE THINK THAT CROSSED. ARMS
COULD IMPACT. WHERE GET. I THINK
THERE NO. TEN THAT. IS IF. RIGHT
WILL BE PROTECTED. AND SO IF YOU
HAVE THE CENTER. WE IT SHOULD
BE. AS PER. AND THE GOAL TODAY I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE CAN
FOR THEIR- RESPECTFULLY I. YOUR
AYE THAT. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MY WE HAVE. A AND
A SECOND SOME. SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO ZERO EIGHT
NINE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED. GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KILEY. K. N. HIGH. AND I BET.
BENNETT I BERMAN CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. FONG. FONG I
IRWIN- WHEN I VALLADARES AYE
DEAREST AYE WICKS. WILSON WILSON
HI. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEYARTO I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN HERE ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
SO GLAD WE COULD. FINALLY GET
YOU UP HERE SUCH IS LIFE FOR A
B. SEVENTEEN ELEVEN WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY
DORIS. AND A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STACKED UP THANK
YOU HONORABLE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. AND
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION ON THE BILL AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TODAY. CURRENTLY
BOUGHT FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
SUFFERS A DATA BREACH THE REPORT
IS SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE BUSINESS
POSTS. A REPORT OF THE BREACH ON
THEIR WEBSITE. PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE HAD THEIR DATA EXPOSED ARE
THEN NOTIFIED BY PHONE MAIL
ANOTHER LECTURE ELECTRONIC
MEANS. THE SAME PROCESS DID YOU.
WHEN A STATE AGENCY SUFFERS A
DATA BREACH HOWEVER CURRENT LAW
IS VAGUE WHEN COMPANIES WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
SUFFER A DATA BREACH IN THESE
INSTANCES THE COMPANIES
GENERALLY POST THE REPORT OF THE
DATA BREACH. RATHER THAN THE
STATE AGENCY THIS METHOD OF
REPORTING DOES NOT INFORM THE
PUBLIC THAT THEIR INFORMATION
WAS ACTUALLY BEING HANDLED BY A
THIRD PARTY. THE PURPOSE OF THE
REPORT MECHANISMS IS TO PROVIDE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WITH
TRANSPARENCY OF HOW THEIR
PRIVATE INFORMATION IS HANDLED
BY GOVERNMENT. THIS IS A STILL
IN TODAY'S DIGITAL AGE. AS THIS
INFORMATION QUITE LITERALLY
PRESENTS THE KEYS TO PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND THEIR LIVELIHOODS IF
IT FALLS INTO THE WRONG HANDS.
IDENTIFY IDENTITY THEFT IS
BECOMING MORE MORE COMMON SO
MUCH SO THAT IT IS NOW THE MOST
COMMON REASON FOR DATA BREACHES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
ACCOUNTS FOR FIFTY NINE PERCENT.
OF ALL DATA BREACHES GLOBALLY.
FURTHERMORE BECAUSE OF THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF PHISHING
SCHEMES MANY PEOPLE OFTEN ASSUME
THAT THESE REAL NOTIFICATIONS
FROM THE PRIVATE YEAH I AGENCIES
ARE FRAUGHT. IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE
CONSIDERING THAT THESE
NOTIFICATIONS MAY COME FROM A
COMPANY THERE'S A THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTOR AN INDIVIDUAL HAS
NEVER HEARD OF OR HAD ANY
INTERACTION WITH THEM BEFORE.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE FULLY FOR
INFORMED ABOUT WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR HANDLING YOUR
PRIVATE INFORMATION THIS IS
ESSENTIAL TO MAINTAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY AND
CONFIDENCE THAT SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IS HANDLED
RESPONSIBLY AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO REPORT DATA BREACHES
OF ENTITIES. WHO ARE WORKING ON
OR WITH THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
IN ADDITION TO THE REPORTS
POSTED BY THOSE ENTITIES THIS
WILL PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH A
MORE INFORMED UNDERSTANDING
CLARITY HOW THEY'RE FROM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IT NOW GOING TO TURN ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SEVEN ONE ONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEE NOW LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- MISTRUST RAIDER
EITHER ANYONE ON THE PHONES IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT
ONE ONE. PRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL OVER THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. USING YOUR
PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TRACY ROSENBERG FROM OAKLAND
PRIVACY CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE SEVEN ONE ONE
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT WE
WILL TURN TO OPPOSITION I'M- THE
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS IS
DOROTHY JOHNSON FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WHO I BELIEVE IS
UP THE PHONE. DOROTHY ON THE
PHONE. HELLO THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT
YES WE CAN'T. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
YOUR ABOUT WE TODAY A DOROTHY
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN I
AM NOT THE MANDATE TO ATTRACT
START. OTHER SOFTWARE AND-
APPRECIATE DISCUSSION OF IT IN
OUR ANALYSIS. AND THE COMEDIAN
OUT THAT- AND WE BELIEVE WE'RE
OFFERING A MORE REASONABLE
APPROACH TO THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION NEEDS. AND WE ARE
SUGGESTING THAT WE USE THAN
EXISTING METHODS THROUGH DIRECT
NOTIFICATION. AT THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THE STATE OR LOCAL
AGENCY THAT CONNECTED TO THE
DATA BREACH IN THE BENDERS
OUTREACH TO THOSE AFFECTED
PARTIES. AS NOTED THAT WE DO
OPPOSED AT ANY REAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR A- ONLINE- SINGLE. THE BE.
HI AND DISTINGUISHING- I TAXED
WE BUILD MAKES PAGES ARE LANDING
LEFT EFFECTIVE- ANY OF REASON A
PERSON WISH TACTICAL TO FIND
OTHER CRITICAL INFORMATION BUT
IN THIS INSTANCE SPECIFICALLY
WITH EIGHTY SEVENTEEN ELEVEN
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POSTING- TRIGGERING PHONE CALL
FROM CONCERNED PARENTS OR
STUDENTS THAT WOULD DISTRACT
FROM OTHER NEED RESOURCES I
COULD POTENTIALLY OVERWHELM THE
SCHOOL CALL CENTER. RESPONDED
THREAT- AND ONE OBVIOUSLY COULD
NOT AND NOW POSTING PER AND
ABOUT WOULDN'T HAVE OR THE TYPE
OF DATA. ONLINE AND THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT THE GREAT MORE
ALARMED THAN ASSURANCE- IN THE
CASE OF A BREACH THE FOR THESE
REASONS WE MAINTAIN OUR HOLD
ELECTED POSITION THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS OF THE
COMMITTEE ERIN AVERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION ON THIS BILL
AND APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT
FROM COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
OFFICE OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SEE NO ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION IN PERSON IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE LINES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN. OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL
ME PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. IN
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WITHOUT BRINGING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- AND SO I'M JUST GOING TO
SAY THANK YOU MR SUHARTO FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT IN THE UP
TICK IN DATA BREACHES WE'VE SEEN
OF LOCAL AGENCIES IN GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS I THINK YOU RAISE AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE HERE. AND YEAH I
THINK THAT THE APPROACH THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN IS A IS A SMART
ENOUGH AWFUL AND I DO THINK THAT
IT'S WORTH IT I JUST
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
FOLKS.
YOU KNOW. ENCOURAGED TO CONTINUE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
APPRECIATE YOUR-CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIVACY APPRECIATE ABOUT THEM.
THAT YOU'VE BROUGHT FORWARD
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT- AND WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
DO TRY TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF THE- AND- AT THIS TIME I JUST
RESPECTFULLY AFTER AYE VOTE.
OKAY MENACING PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I KILEY BAUER
CAYENNE. SENATE BERMAN
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FONG
FONG I IRWIN. VALLADARES FELLA
THERE'S A WICKS WILSON WILSON HI
. ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPPOSITE OPEN FOR ABSENT
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A TWO
MINUTE RECESS WHAT WE WORK FOR
OUR. I DON'T THINK. GET. WE FIVE
WHAT LET RIGHT. RIGHT OKAY YEAH
YEAH- HI MY NAME ACTUALLY FOR.
RIGHT YEAH. THERE YES YOU WERE
RUBIO. YES UHHUH. OKAY WELL
WOULD IT ARE WE OFF MY WHAT WAS
IT. I LOVE MY JOB AND- HE MOBILE
LAB. FIFTEEN THE ACT- DON'T.
JORDAN DID YOU.
I'M ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT WE ARE
BACK WE ARE MOVING TO AB. TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY ONE. I'M HERE
WELCOME THANK YOU. FOR RIGHT.
YEAH FIFTY THREE. ALL RIGHT WE
ARE BACK WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BAUER K. HIM WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN PLEASE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AMBER AND A. B.
FIVE SEVEN ONE THE BILL WHICH
AND FROM GAINES. THANK AND SINCE
IT'S A STATE WHEN IT THREATENS A
HEADS INTO ONE PER PROP TO HER
AND NINE ON IN SHOOTINGS BY
PRESENT IN A THAT'S HUNDRED. IN
WEBER I CHILDREN HAVE PUT OTHER
CHESS AT RISK NINETY PER OF THE
IN THE SHOOTINGS BY TWO WERE
ALSO CHILDREN OFF PULLING IN.
THIS IS THE THIRD CAUGHT BATH
FOR CHILDREN IN TEENS THIS APP
OF DEADLY VIOLENCE IS FUEL
TREATING CHILDREN TO HOLD A GUN
SOON AS THEY CAN WALK AND MANY.
HERGER KIDS WITH ADVERT. EVEN
CHILDREN'S BOOKS THE ADVERTISING
FOR THESE WEAPONS IS SHAMELESS
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BUY GUNS IF THEY'RE
ADVERTISED ACROSS ALL FORMS OF
MEDIA WITH CARTOONS VIDEO GAMES
AND SOCIAL MEDIA. TWENTY FIVE
ANYONE OKAY PERCENT. FIREARMS OR
WEAPONS TO ANYONE UNDER THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN. THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OR
DISTRICT OR COUNTY ATTORNEY OR
CAN. TO BRING THIS THING EACH BY
. WITHOUT ME FIVE DOLLARS IN
FINES WITH ME TODAY MY PHONE IS
CREEK BELOW BELIEVE PROMOTE
MANDATE AND BROWN. HELLO FROM
LAX. I THANK YOU WE ARE GOING TO
. SINCE SUPPORT BOTH OF WHOM ARE
ON THE PHONE. SIX SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
COLLADO AND THE MOM LIVING IN
THE BAY AREA AND A VOLUNTEER
LEADER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER MOM IN. AGAIN THAT
ROLLER PARENTS PEOPLE ALL AROUND
THE STATE WANT TO SPEAK BEAT THE
WAY ON VIOLENCE PREVENTION. I
HAVE A DAUGHTER AND KINDERGARTEN
NEXT YEAR THAT MILESTONE BRING
STATE IN OVER FRIEND THE NEW IT.
SAYS PARENTS I KNOW YOU KNOW
ALSO GOING TO WORK ABOUT TO
EXPLAIN ACT SHE DRILL. AND HOW
DOES INJECTING SOME TIME TO YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO GUNS TO
GET. AND BRING THOSE DEADLY BUT
JUST GO. EVERY PLAN FOR PLEADING
AFTER. THE NEW FIREARM. PANDEMIC
PART OF MY JOB A MOM NUMBER THAT
OTHER. WHETHER IT FIRE FAILED OR
STORAGE SECURELY. AND MAKING
SURE MIKE. TO THAT ARE NOT TOYS
. SHE THAT THE- PAYMENT ON.
ADVERTISE MINOR YOU STUFF THE
ANIMAL THE COACHING CARE. EIGHT
BILLION MAY THAT CLEAR DISTINCT
THE YOUNG KIDS THAT COME ARE NOT
TOYS ADAM MESSAGES UNDER WHEN
STATE OF THEM TO BE AT. IN
PLEASE SIGN APPEAL TO CHILL.
INCLUDING A ONE OF WITH THE OF A
PASSED THE FIRE IN THE LOW. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE WITH THE
HEAD ADVERTISE FIRE IN THE
DURING TO CHILL. AND ASIAN OF
FIRE. EGGMAN L. TRACKS MY. MUCH
ONE FIREARM SPECIALLY DANGEROUS
IN THE HANDS OF MY AND TO HAVE A
RESPONSE TO REGULATE THE MARKET
OF DANGER PRODUCTS TO MY AB
TWENTY FIVE OPEN BRIDGE BETWEEN
THAT OVER THE GAP BOB I REGULAR
CAMPFIRE CHAU. ON FIRE. FIND IT
AFTER IT. BUDGET CAN. OTHER THAN
ALLOW COMPANIES TO ENTER IT OR
IF AT BAT BUTTON OUR BY.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE LIKE THE
BURNING AND I'M ON THE POLICY
TEAM AT MARCH FOR OUR LIVES.
MARCH REALIZED THE FOUNDED
TWENTY EIGHT AFTER THE TRACK
MARJORY STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL IN PARKLAND FLORIDA
OREGON AND- OUR GOAL TO CREATE
STATEMENT. COMMUNITIES WORK DONE
BY IS OBSOLETE. OUR TO START OFF
BY MY REMARKS BY THINKING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER POWER CAN IN OUR
OFFICE RUN BY NEED TO BE A
WITNESS TODAY AS WELL THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
LET. DISTRICT IT. BEING A
PROMOTIONAL MARKETING PROBLEM
CAN AND TO IN ORDER TO PUT
MINORS THIS PREVENT POTENTIALLY
BUT FROM A HAND OF YOUNG PEOPLE
IT'S WE DO THE SAME WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING SPRING BANK
OKAY. LEADING PUBLIC. UNITED
STATES AND THE THIRD CAUSE OF
DEATH CHILDREN AND TEENS AND
HEALTH I HAVE YOUNG AGE YOUNG
PEOPLE THE BAY WITH SHOOTING
WORLD LIVING LOVE TO DEATH FIRE
ANXIOUSLY LOOKING AT AND
THEATERS BOTH FINDING THEIR
BETTER ONE AND SO MUCH MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE. TRUMP GOT. UNIQUE
GENERAL. THE VIOLENCE WE THE
FIRE ARM MARK TO MY- WE'RE WE'RE
THINKING WE NEED TO WITH THEIR
FILE GUN VIRTUAL THE MARKETING
THEM TO MINORS BY INCLUDE
CARTOON CHARACTER AND SAYING
QUOTE IT SHOULD JUST LIKE MOM
AND DAD ONE GUY IT QUOTE YET
COMPLETELY. THE WHOLE THAT CAN
TO YOUNG PEOPLE MARCH AB ONE OF
THE CHANCE TO HOLD THE GUN
INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU
YOUNG PEOPLE CALIFORNIA LEADER
WHEN IT WE CANNOT. YOU CAN
INITIATE CORRECT. I POPPING FIVE
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF TIME WE WERE GO TO IN
SOME IN THE ROOM IS OUR ONE OF
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS A FOR A TWO FIVE SEVEN
ONE. SIX BACK TO THE PHONE LINES
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWO FIVE SEVEN
ONE. FOR THIS BILL AND IF YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY DONE SO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN THE CIRCLE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY NINE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER THE
HUTCHINS WITH THE READING PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP TESTIFYING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS ARE
BACK TO MARKET ON BEHALF OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FINE TWENTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS VIVIAN
PARTRIDGE AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE CALLING IN TO SUPPORT A.
B. TWO FIVE SEVEN ONE. WELL I AM
TWENTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
BRAVADO AND THE RESIDENT OF WEST
SACRAMENTO AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE AND I'M IN SUPPORT. WHY
NOT. THIRTY HI MY NAME IS NICOLE
THROUGH I'M A RESIDENT OF
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWO FIVE SEVEN ONE. MY THIRTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS JULIE HANNAH
AND I LIVE IN SAN JOSE I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION FOR GUN SENSE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FIVE ONE.
THANK YOU KNOW FOR THEM UP THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION DANIEL S.
READ FROM THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION INSTITUTE FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION WHO IS ON THE
PHONE. YES YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE AND
READ WITH THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO YOU'RE FOR GUN
OWNERS TO CALIFORNIA TODAY. HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO IT TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE- THE SUPER US SPRINT
CORD MAKE CLEAR THAT COMMERCIAL
SPEECH IS NOT ALL OUTSIDE. YOU A
MAN AND MORE. KILEY AND A DOING
SO THEY ALLY. CORTES FROM HAD.
BUDGETARY WHETHER A GIVEN RISK.
ON SPEECH VIOLATE THE PERSON. SO
AS LONG AS IT'S A- SPEECH
CONCERNED A LOT MORE ACTIVE. THE
GOVERNMENT. MUST ASSERTED. PAID
ENTER THE- AND- BY RELATIONAL.
THE REGULATION MAASTRICHT
ADVANCE THE ASSORTED ENTER IN
THE RIGHT CAN MUST BE NEVER.
CHURCH THAT STATE INSURANCE. AND
SO WHEN DO IN THAT CASE BE
INVALIDATED A FEW ADVERTISING.
PROVISIONS RELATING TO TOBACCO
AND- APPLYING THAT THAT TEST
YEAR CADETS THAT ADVERTISING
THAT IS TRACK TO MY- IS CLEARLY
GOING TO FILE. FAIL ON FIRST
GROUNDS EVEN IF ONE WAS WITH.
TWENTY FIVE ONE NEED FIRST. THAT
IT AND OUT JAIL SUPPORT TESTED
THEM MAKE A PIECE OF FABRIC IT.
FOR THE SAME REASON THE MENTAL
SO AND TOP FIND OUR POPPIES.
BURKE THIS LAW PURPOSE. AND THAT
MAY FIND OUT TO THINK. AND THEIR
MIGHT BE A THE.
AWFUL PURPOSES. STATED THIRD
INTEREST MAYBE TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE IS TO COMBAT THE
PROLIFERATION OF FIREARMS EVEN
AMONG MINORS. THE BILL NOTES
STATED THE COMPELLING AND THEN
ENSURING THE MINERS DO NOT PUT
THAT COULD NOT BE DANGEROUS
WEAPONS THE THIRD INTERESTED.
WILL YOU FARMS BY MINOR RATHER
ALL YOU- BIRTH AS MINERS ARE
PERMITTED BY STATE LAW YOU FARMS
FOR A VARIETY OF LAWFUL PURPOSES
THE DUBIOUS AT THE STATE THAT
STARTED INTERESTS ARE PREVENTING
POT USED MINORS STAND. BY THE-
CONTROL. SECOND BUT IF THE GOAL
TO CURRICULA USE OF PROVIDERS
PLUS SUSPECT ENTERS EARLY
BANNING ALL THE MEDIA TO MINORS
GIVEN THAT POSSIBLY THE USE OF
FIREARMS LAWFUL PURPOSES THE
OPRAH BROUGHT ME HERE WE'RE
GONNA NEED. YEAH YES SO. EITHER
OF THE USUALLY IF YOU DON'T
THEIR MAJOR CONCERN WITH-
PROGRAMS SUCH AS HUNTER SAFETY
THAT ACTUALLY KEEP. YOU WITH
FARM AS WELL PARK. PROVED
FIFTEEN IN RIYADH HUNTER IN THIS
- THE BILL HAS BEEN CUT OVER AND
MANY CONSEQUENCES WITHOUT ONE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. I'M NOT
GOING TO GO TO ANY OFFICE
REMEMBERS. SO TWENTY WE WANT.
CINEMA GO BACK TO THE FINAL
OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINES.
S. OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I DO HAVE ONE
LINE WITH AN OPERATOR TO BE JUST
A MOMENT.
COMMENT COMES FROM WHAT I AM ONE
HUNDRED FOR. I AND ONE OF OUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS FOR THE
RECORD AND MEMBERS WITH ANY MY
NAME IS MICHAEL AND THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF FIREARM
MANUFACTURERS AND THE
MANUFACTURERS THE FALCON
SHOOTING JUST. WRONG POSITION
WITH TO ACT. WHAT DO YOU
NATIONAL. IN TERMS OF THIS BEING
OVER BROAD OVERREACHING
CORPORATE. BUT THAT THEY'RE NOT
FOR LONG LINES IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THAT WE'RE GONNA BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE I DO WANT TO NOTE FOR
DISCUSSION PURPOSES THAT THIS
BILL IF PASSED OUT TODAY TO
JUDICIARY NECKS ARE SURE THEY
WILL HAVE A FULSOME. CONVERSE
ABOUT ANY FIRST AMEND. RELATED
TO. EACH I HAVE SET UP TO DO
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT TODAY IS THE JERSEY THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH DOES TO THE
PROTECTION OF A MINER'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION SO WITH THAT WOULD
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR ANY. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SOME REMEMBER BENNETT
. THE TIGERS THAT SECOND THAT
THE SECOND BY A SUMMER WILSON SO
. ALL RIGHT SEEN ON I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD M. WE KNOW
THAT ARE GONE VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC
ENTRY- WE HAVE SEEN IT STEPS
AWAY FROM WHERE WE SAID. IF YOU
ALMOST HAVE TIME WE- YEAH ARE
READING MORE IMAGES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN. VICTIMS OF
GUN VIOLENCE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE IN THIS AREA YOU HAVE BEEN
A REAL LEGISLATURE. I AM PART OF
THE MAP. S. CI WITH A CO AUTHOR-
AND WITH THAT YOU MAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YES WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
CHAIR STONE A SPOT SO WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO ADDRESS
THEM. BACK AND YOU KNOW. AB
BIGGEST HERE. ACTING CAL YEAR
FELL SAYS CAN'T PURCHASE GUNS
AND SO WE DON'T THINK IT
APPROPRIATE THAT THEY BE
ADVERTISED TWO AND A HALF
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN
BUT- ALL RIGHT. A SECOND MAN OF
SECTOR PLEASE CALL. SEVENTY ONE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GABRIEL HI
GABRIEL I KILEY BAUER K. N. I.
R. K. N. I. BENNETT BENNETT FIVE
FOR AN- M. I AM NOT VOTING FONG
FONG- BALANCE. NOW THAT IS NOT
BEING WHERE WELLS I WILSON I.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SHE SHE
HER OUT WE DO YES WE HAVE MISSED
RUBIO SHE'S MADE WONDERFUL. BUT
SIX SIX TIME IS A CHARM WELCOME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. WE ARE
MOVING NEXT TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR. BUT WE HAVE SHOWN FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIRUS. A SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
THANK YOU MR NUMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR TODAY I WANT TO
BEGIN WITH COMMITTED TO STRIKING
SUBDIVISION YOU THE ADDRESS IS
THAT THE- COMMUNICATION FROM. IS
IT THANK THE NEW MEMBERS OF THE
BEFORE AND SMALL. YOU ALL AWARE
WE CALIFORNIA'S FIND FINE
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE THE COMP
CREDIT CORRECTION SYSTEM ON
THEIR OWN I NEED IS.
ADDITIONALLY CAN THIS BACK.
THERE'S TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS A
TROUBLE TOP TROUBLING TIME
ASSEMBLY BROKE TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR WILL UPDATE AND
MODERNIZE THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR CREDIT SERVICE ACTED
CONSUMER PLANS WHEN CAUGHT BEING
. SERVICE BY INNOVATION THE NEXT
. X. IT'S GONNA SAVE FROM TRY OR
RECEIVING MONEY PRIOR THE FALL
COMPLETE OF THE OPERA TO VISIT
YET IN MANY CASES CREDIT REPAIR
COMPANY SYSTEM IN PAYMENT FOR
WORK HALF OF THE CONSUMER
BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES.
SOMMERSBY NORTH OF. BEFORE
SETTLEMENTS ARCHIE AT TO
CONTINUE TO PAY EVEN AFTER ONE
OR MORE DISPUTES ARE SETTLED
CREDIT REPAIR ORGANIZATIONS ARE
DAMAGING CREDIT. BY OF FORM
DISPUTE LETTERS ON ALL OF THE
CONSUMER'S ACCOUNTS INCLUDING
THOSE FOR WHICH CONSUMERS NOT
JUST. THAT TWO MONTHS LATER
OPERATE
CREDITS ORGANIZATION TO DISCLOSE
WHEN IT IS ACTING ON A CONCERN
WITH BEHALF BY ENSURING. NOT BE
OBLIGATE FEES TELL THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY RECEIVED EVERY WERE
PROP. BETTER DESCRIPTIONS. IS TO
BE PERFORMED AND A COMPEL CREDIT
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH ITEMIZED RECEIPTS
AND COPIES OF ALL LETTERS. WE
PUT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR WILL BRING CREDIT
REPAIR SERVICES INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE KELLY- SINCE THE BERMAN.
ITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COLLECTORS TO TESTIFY IN OF.
WE ALL HAVE OUR MARTIN LYNCH OF
THE FINANCIAL CONSULTING
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ACTUALLY I BELIEVE BOTH OF THEM
ARE ON THE- PHONE. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN WE'RE GONNA
GO TO- OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WHO ARE ON THE PHONE. SO TELL
YOU HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN'T.
APPLE THE CHAIRMAN AND FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEANING KELLY
PARDON THE BRIAN AND I SERVICE
THE LEGISLATIVE VOTE SHARE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA. ACQUIRED A PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE EIGHT. EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR TWENTY FOUR WILL
UPDATED MODERN MODERNIZE THE
CREDIT SERVICES ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR TO EXPAND CONSUMER
PROTECTION. WE CONTRACTING WITH
A CREDIT. BUT THEY STILL. CAN'T
WAIT IN HERE TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE OF THE SERVICES
PURCHASE INCLUDING. A GROUP
CALLED AND THE COST.
SERVICES PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN PUT
UNDER THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT FOR OVERSIGHT
AND ENFORCEMENT. HAS RECENTLY
EXPANDED INTO NEW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR MOVES OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT VIA I. DON'T THINK
THIS IN NINETEEN. THE BILL
REQUIRE BECAUSE THOSE INCLUDING
THE- WITH THEM ALLOW FOR THEM
FOR TO SEE IF THE WILL BE TO
LEADER MODIFY. THE CLOTHES INTO
THE PAYMENT REQUIRED BY THE
FIRST. PROVIDED A FEW. THE FBI
RE READ AND LOGIN IN CURRENTLY
ARE WILL TO READ WITH THE
GENERAL AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FORMALLY AS PROTECTION FOR
CONSUMERS IT WILL TAKE YOU TO
BUSINESS PRACTICE AND ALLOW FOR
INFO AGAIN THE REPORT. M. WHERE
. THANKS FOR UTILITIES OF
LEGITIMATE REPAIR ORGANISE THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT AND
YOUR AYE ON EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU TO HAVE ANOTHER-
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. PART ONE I
SERVICE PART OF THE FINANCIAL
COUNSELING ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA- I TEXTED CAROLYN
GABRIEL BUT YOU'RE TELLING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HELLO.
YES THERE IS A LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION REPRESENT TWENTY
SIX BOB PROP. WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES MOST OF
WHICH PROVIDE A VARIETY OF AND
LOW COST SERVICE OF HEARING
HEALTH. WE ARE NOT. WE ARE NOT
COLLECTING. HERE NONSTOP HELPFUL
. SOME OF THOSE MOTIVATED BY THE
ABUSE OF EXPERIENCE THE FAILURE
TO UP BY CONSUMERS WE'VE WORKED
WITH. AIRHELP AB PORTS FOR INCH
SUPPORT OF THE FOR THE FOLLOWING
. THE BILL LIMIT OUR REPAIR
SERVICE FOR EIGHTY DAYS AND FOR
HIM US FROM COMPANIES SHORT UNIT
WE CHALLENGES THE FAMED COUNCIL
OVER REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME.
THE COMPUTERS TO BE THE MAN OF
THE BAD ACT YOU DONE NOTHING. HE
EVERY PATEL DIDN'T COVER OF THE
CONSUMER IN THE COUNTRY PARA
PUMP SHOULD LOOK ARE LIKELY
ACURA. THE BILL ALSO PROHIBITS
COMPANIES FROM URGING CONSUMERS
TO CREATE A NEW CREDIT BY A DE
NAME ON FOR THAT EMPLOYER DOES
NOT AFFECT NUMBER. PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANT AB TWO TO COREY A
FRONT THE- DETAILING INFORMATION
CONSUMERS NEED BETTER. INCLUDING
THE REPORT BECAUSE CHALLENGE THE
EXPECTED BECAUSE- A LOT OF TIME
TO THE CHILD THE JUNK FOR IT.
MUCH BOTH OF WILL HELP CONSUMERS
FOR SPANISH SPOKE AND THE COST
OF THE SERVICE BEING OFF. YEAH
OF EIGHTY TWO FOUR OF ONE HAND
FOR JUST THE FAULT THAT THEY
THIS BILL- SERVICES WATER BE
AVAIL FOR THE WHO NEED THE MOST.
IN FACT THE BILL WOULD NOTHING
OF THE- THERE ARE EIGHTY NINE.
CALIFORNIA THAT ROUTINELY.
REVIEW CREDIT. AND PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT REPAIRING.
BEEPER ARE I WILL ABOUT THERE
ARE SOME WORDS WITH THE- HELLO.
HOW YOU CAN THE PROCESS OF THAT
IS TRUE. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
AB TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
REASONABLE. THAT EVERY REPUTABLE
SERVICE PROVIDER AN HONOR WHICH
IS WHY WE FOUND OUT OF THE
FOSTER AND WHY WE ARE URGING THE
YOUTH BASKETBALL. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE TOP. BUT WHAT.
GREAT THANK YOU MUCH WE ARE NOW
GOING TO AN SORT IN THE ROOM
SUPPORT FOR A TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
IN THE HEARING. I SEE NOTHING
ABOUT. SCIENCE OPERATORS ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR ON THE
PHONES. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S A ONE ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. IN JUST
A MOMENT. COMMENT TODAY COMES
FROM LINE OF MORAL SEVEN PIECE
WELL ARMED WOMAN. THE FINAL
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS PAT
WHALEN ELLISON WILL SNAP YOU SEE
HERE ON BEHALF OF YOU SEE THE
AMERICA- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. WE HAVE. ONE HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON TIM LYNCH FROM
PLATINUM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE'S MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATES INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR.
KLAIN ONE OH NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BRENDA BACK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIRTY GIPSON ENCORE CAPITAL
GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK. FOUR EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. BUT
THEN THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
Q. FOUR SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL TURN TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TWO PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WE HAVE CHRISTIAN CABALLERO WITH
. PRINT PRO JECT C. ON WHO IS
HERE PERSON CHRISTIAN CAN TELL
US HOW TO PRONOUNCE THAT
CORRECTLY- AND WE HAVE- ANDRE
POWELL WITH THE AFRICAN
EMPOWERMENT CENTER WHO'S ALSO
HERE PERCENT. THANK YOU MISTER
I'M JUST GLAD YOU PRONOUNCE MY
NAME. JUST GOOD IT'S PROGRESS-
CHRISTIAN CAVIAR WITH
PROGRESSION. I THOUGHT FIRST
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE BUT MOST OF ALL OF THE
AUTHOR. I HATE BEING ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF YOU BECAUSE I
REALIZE HOW MUCH YOU DO CARE
ABOUT CONSUMERS THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO HELP WITH THIS BILL
AND- THANK YOU FOR. WILLING TO
WORK WITH US HOUSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SADLY AFTER OPPOSE
THE BILL FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THE COMMITTEES. GIVE HER
ALL THE UP ALL THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL THAT ONE CONSUMER GROUP
AMONG THEM. I WANT. SO WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING YOU TO DO IS JAM
A BUILD ON THE CONSUMERS SO THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO. HEAR THE
GROUP. THE BILL. IN AMERICAN
EMPOWERMENT COALITION. THE
NATIONAL ASIAN AMERICAN
COALITION THE NATIONAL DIVERSITY
COALITION. THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. CIAU LUWAK. THESE ARE
ALL OPPOSED TO THIS CONSUMER
FRIENDLY BILL. THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO WHAT IT SAYS WHAT. WOULD
THEY TELL YOU IT DOES IT DOESN'T
IT. FIFTEEN PAGE BILL BUT ONE OF
THE MOST CONCERNING THAT THE
PROMOTING IS. THE CONSUMER OR
THE CSO IS SUPPOSED TO INDICATE
WHICH ITEMS ARE TO BE REMOVED OR
CHALLENGED. THAT IS NOT AT ALL.
THE BURDEN OF THE CONSUMER THIS
YET SO. IF YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
RUIN SOME. HE SHOULD HAVE THE
POWER TO JUSTIFY WHY YOU'RE
DOING. SO FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES
THAT WHEN A CONSUMER CHALLENGES
SOMETHING OR ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
HIS OR HER CREDIT. IT'S THE
FURNITURE THAT COLLECTED AT
SUPPOSED TO JUSTIFY WHY THAT
CREDIT REPORT. THE WAY THAT THE
US WHAT THIS BILL IT WAS NOW
CONSUMER SUPPOSED TO SAY. THIS
IS NOT MINE THIS IS NOT MINE
THIS IS NOT MINE THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT IS OFTENTIMES
BECKETT'S BOUGHT ANY CHANGES
NAMES SO IF YOU WANT TO MAY.
YEARS AGO. ABOUT YOUR- YOU KNOW
HAVE A REALLY LONG FOR CAPITAL
YOU CAN'T SAY AWKWARD. I ON'T
HAVE THIS DEBT THIS ISN'T MINE
THEY WOULD KNOW. SO BY IF THIS
BILL PASSES NOW THAT CONSUMERS
SUPPOSED TO KNOW EVERYTHING
THAT'S ON THE CREDIT REPORT AND
THAT'S SIMPLY UNFAIR. FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THAT SOMEBODY WHO
REALLY EMBODIES CREDIT OR
PROVIDE THAT ROUTE CRAP HAPPENS
BY WHAT DOING. AND THIS WOULD
PUT THAT ON ITS THAT'S A
PROBLEM. IT'S A REAL PROBLEM
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
OTHER ISSUE IS I KNOW A LOT OF
YOU CARE. VERY DEEPLY ABOUT FOR
HOUSING. VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
THE STATE. CREDIT IS A HUGE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT WILL LIMIT
SOMEONE'S ABILITY TO PREPARE THE
CREDIT YOU CAN LIMIT SOMEBODY'S
ABILITY GET APARTMENT TO BUY A
HOUSE TO BUY AFFORDABLE CARD A
REASONABLE RATE AND WITH
INTEREST RATES GOING JUST GONNA
GET WORSE. SO I I'M TELLING ALL
RIGHT BAGS COMMITTEE THIS
COMMITTEE TO REALLY RECONSIDER
ITS PRIOR VOTE ON THIS BILL I
KNOW IT VOTED OUT PREVIOUSLY IT
PLAYED A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU KNOW
. WORK WITH NEW INFORMATION.
COMES NEW. TO MAKE WOULD REALLY
EMPLOYEE TO CONSIDER WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE WITH THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU PASTOR. WELL I DO
WANNA THANK- THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN
AND ASSEMBLY RUBIO I'M I'M SUPER
IMPRESSED WITH YOU IN YOUR HEART
NOW. LAST WE MEANT IT THERE'S
BEEN SOME CHANGES- THE SHOWS
THAT YOU GUYS ARE DEFINITELY
WORKING ON IT- BECAUSE OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA IS A VERY- CONSUMER-
ARE OUR SERVICE THAT WE HAVE
HERE AND ASSEMBLY AND WE KNOW
THAT YOU GUYS ARE FOR WHO. THE
PAST AFTER ABOUT. BY CHURCH
LAWCENTER. AND- I RUN A
NONPROFIT THE- PROBLEM. WHICH WE
DO FINANCED LITERACY TWICE A
WEEK. OF COURSE CREDIT IS A BIG
BIG DEAL IT'S EXPENSIVE TO BE
POOR. IT'S EXPECTED TO HAVE BAD
CREDIT. OR AT LEAST HAVE THINGS
ON YOUR CREDIT THAT SHOULDN'T BE
THERE- THIS BILL IT HAS SOME
GREAT COMPONENTS TO IT. BUT
THEY'RE REALLY SOME SMOKE
SCREEN. BECAUSE BASICALLY IT'S
THIS THE FEDERAL REGULATOR- AS A
SMOKESCREEN AND NOT UNDERMINES
WHAT THE- DECKLID REALLY. AND SO
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST. I SEE
THEIR FACE I KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING I KNOW WHAT THE GOING
THROUGH. YOU GUYS TO BE THERE TO
SEE CRY ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
HARASSMENT ABOUT ALL DAY DOING
THIS IS NOT I MEAN I THINK IT'S
MOST INSULTING TO THINK THE DEBT
COLLECTORS. THANK FOR. OF CAN.
STEP COMPA OF INTEREST- I HEARD
SEVERAL OTHER NONPROFITS. ON THE
DUE CREDIT COUNSELING BUT THEY
ALSO HELP. WITH DEBT SETTLEMENT
SO THAT'S KIND OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST YOU'RE GOING TO HELP.
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK ON ONCE
I'D- BEEN UP PICK A SIDE ISSUE
BECOME. TO WORK FOR THE DEBT
COLLECTORS OR YOU DON'T DO A LOT
I DO WORK FOR CONSUMERS. AND SO
I'M I'M IN STE THIS OPPOSITE.
HOPE YOU. CAN SEE- SOME OF THE-
PROCESS. LIFTING CONANT THERE
ARE BAD ACTORS IN. BUT WE DON'T
GO TO BE OUT WITH BATH. WE WANNA
WE WANT TO JUST CLEAN WATER UP
AND MAKE. FOR ALL. FOR YOU.
TOTAL OPPOSITE. THE YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH PASS
NOW GO TO TURN TO ANY OF OP IN
THE HEARING ROOM SIR ANYONE.
HERE INTO IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FOUR TO.
HE EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES
IN Q. O. Q. WITH OPERATOR STILL
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. OUR FIRST
COMMENT TODAY'S LINE ONE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TERRORISM
COMMITTEE FUNDING AS WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
EIGHTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU. WE
HAVE FINAL SIGN. HELLO MY NAME
IS ADAM FOREMAN UNDER CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWYER AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'LL STATE MY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
HE HELLO MY NAME IS CODY JOHNSON
I'M WITH LEXINGTON LONG FOR A
LAW FIRM THAT FOCUSES ON
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND AYE
OPPOSED AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FOUR. NEVER MIND- SIX. AFTER
GIVING HER SOME ASSOCIATION.
THANK AB TWO FOURTH. FOUR WITH
THAT THEY'RE NOT FOR THE IN
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION. OKAY WITH
THAT BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS. SO MEMBER K. THANK YOU
. RATHER SPEECHLESS HERE TODAY
WHICH IS RARE FOR ME AS EVERYONE
ON THIS DIET KNOWS- BECAUSE I
HAVE RELIGION SITTING ON BANKING
OR WE HAVE HEARD THIS BILL JUST
COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN THE OFFICE
AND CAME TO. AS MEMBERS. WHAT
NUMBER WITH THE ENABLE TO WRITE
LETTERS ON BEHALF THEIR CLIENTS
BANKING DEALT WITH RIVER SHIP
THE BURDEN PROOF AND AFTER
LISTENING HEARING DEEPLY ABOUT
CONSUMERS THE AUTHOR DEALT WITH
THE LETTER WRITING ISSUE. WHICH
WITH LEE. NOW I'M NOT NEW ISSUES
HERE TODAY AND THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE TO DO IS AND I SAID THIS
LAST MEETING I'M GONNA DATE
AGAIN IS TO PUT CONSUMERS FIRST
. AND THAT WHAT I CARE ABOUT
THAT AS WITH OTHER CARES ABOUT
WE'VE SEEN THAT WE SEEN AFTER
THE WORK SHE HAS DONE ON THIS
BILL. THE FACT OPPOSITE HASN'T
MOVED AT ALL GIVEN THE
INCREDIBLE HARD WORK OF THIS
AUTHOR TO BRING IT AT ALL I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. IT IS
. YEAH TO ME YOUR SHE HAS LISTEN
SHE HAS AMENDED AND SHE HAS
BROUGHT THE BILL TO A PLACE TO
ALLOW CONSUMERS TO HAVE THE
SERVICE THAT THE PASTOR PROVIDES
TO WRITE LETTERS ON THEIR BEHALF
AND TO GET THE RESOLUTION THEY
SO DESPERATELY BUT ALSO THE BILL
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND- I. THANKS FOR
AT WITH THAT I'M JUST TO PUT IT
OUT THERE THAT I SHE'S DONE A
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK SHE
DESERVES IT EVERY SINGLE PAYER
AND THAT IS CALLED AND I WILL
RECONSIDER. YOUR MOTION FROM
SOME IT- WE HAVE MOTION ARE ANY
ALL RIGHT WELL HAVE A DOUBLE
MOTION ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
MEMBERS THAT COME WHICH TOOK AND
OR ASK. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WITHOUT I AM I ALSO WANT TO-
APPLIED THE AUTHOR TO FIGURE
SOME REMEMBER RUBIO- YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT TIME THE FIRST TIME
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS SEEN
ABOUT. YOU HAVE TO ENGAGE
EXTENSIVE CALL STATIONS WITH
FOLKS- AND I WANTED THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ME TO TAKE THE MOMENT
THEY ARE TAKING THIS COMMITTEE
I. THE THAT'S GOING TO. THE BILL
. BASS ARE. WHEN I SAW THE
REGION VERSION OF. MUST FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE BEST CHAIR WAS HOW
BE MOST PRO CONSUMER- AND I WANT
TO SAY I THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
THAT ARE GOING TO REALLY REALLY
PART FOR KIDS. IN PARTICULAR BY
ENSURING. THAT A REPAIR
COMPANIES. IF THERE'S DESCRIPT.
IT'S AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
UNFORTUNATE THERE ARE BAD ACTORS
AND CREDIT RISK REPAIRS. I THINK
. BUDGET BURKE AT- THIS.
REMEMBER THANK YOU CAN. AND
WAITING CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY'RE
AT THEIR MOST NOTABLE AND SO WE
ARE NOW. TO ADD SOME-
PROTECTIONS THERE. SAME TIME AS
YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
KERR ABOUT ACTORS IT'S IMPORTANT
WE'RE NOT OPENING THE ABILITY.
FOR OUR- CREDIT REPAIR COMPANIES
OUT PAY FOR THEIR- THE MAN. THAT
THE AUTHOR IS TATE TODAY. AND
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CAN STILL HAPPEN SO. I HOPE
THERE CAN TO. CALL PATIENTS.
YOUR PRESSURE. BUT A LOT OF THE
FOLKS REPORT WE'RE CALL IT.
THERE FOR WEEKS FAR IN BEING
WILLING TO TAKE THESE
AMENDMENTS- WITHOUT I WATCHED
ONE AGAIN. THANK THE THANK TH
AUTHOR FOR TAKING THESE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THANK YOU MR. THE
COMMITTEE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE ON THE SUPPORT OUT WILL ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
ALL OF YOU THAT ENGAGED OUR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN HAPPEN AND
THE- I. AND I DID TAKE THOSE I
HEARD THE LAST TIME AND NOW YOU
ARE BEING. AT COMES TO THE TABLE
WELL WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC HAND FOR
POINTING THAT OUT I WAS GOING
TO. JUST SAY THANK YOU. THE AND
I. ARE NOT ABLE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KILEY I CAN'T AND I
pCUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE FONG
FONG I IRWIN- IRWIN I VALLADARES
VALLADARES AYE WICKS WILSON
WILSON HI. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WE ARE
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS I HAD A
BARRICADE CAN BUILD A FEW
MINUTES SO LET'S- OUT ANOTHER
ONE. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
BARRICADE CAMP. I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE. THANKS TWENTY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A RIGHT THAT SHOULD
BE ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS EVERYONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
FOR VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS LIKE
VETERANS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
I HIGHER EDUCATION OFTEN SEEMS
OUT OF REACH GROUPS AND A WITH
THE SPECIAL MS IN READ THAT OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE IN PLACE CPAS
NEED. TIME OF THREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE EXPERIENCING
ENROLLMENT RATE WHICH RUNS THEIR
SOLVENCY EVEN THOUGH STUDENTS
NEED THESE RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND EVEN ROME
AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
PREVENTED FROM REACHING OUT TO
THESE POPULATIONS BECAUSE THEY
LACK THE DATA AND INFORMATION TO
FIND THEM. TWENTY SEVEN. ISSUE
NOW YOU WITH STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO SHARE DATA WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ALLOWING COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE OUTREACH OF
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES TO THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
THE VETERANS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED WILL IN TURN
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AND PROVIDE
A LIFE CHANGING EDUCATION THESE
ADULT PATIENTS. TODAY IT PORT IS
THE- MEDS I HOPE I DIDN'T MISS
PRINTER NAME EXECUTIVE INTERIM
CHANCELLOR FOR THE CONTRA COSTA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
SAP ARIBA VETERANS THAT YOU.
VETERANS WORKGROUP ON THIS BILL
THEY'RE BOTH HERE VIA TELEPHONE. GREAT WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH I GUESS I
WILL BEGIN- HELLO MY NAME IS
MOTION THAT HE THOUGHT I SERVICE
INTERIM CHANCELLOR OF THE CONTRA
COSTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
. I WANT TO. REMEMBER WHAT
REBEKAH. CARRYING A TWO SIXTEEN
POOREST AND RECOGNIZE THE NEW
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT LORI WILSON.
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BUFFY
WICKS WHO ALSO REPRESENTS OUR
CONTRA COSTA COMMUNITY. I ALSO
WANT TO SAY HELLO- TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG WHO KNOWS A LOT
ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
SERVED AS A TRUSTEE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT LIKE THE VAST MAJORITY
ACROSS THE STATE IS FACING ALL
THE CHALLENGES IT IS NOT ABOUT
THE QUALITY OF HIGHER EDUCATION
. RATHER THE PANDEMIC AND
CREATED. WE'LL TAKE A FEW
SEMESTERS OFF TOWARD THE-
NATIONAL ABILITY TO MAKING
DECISIONS TO GET THE HIGHER
EDUCATION THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR GOOD PAYING JOBS THE
DAYS OF JUST OPENING THE DOORS
TO OUR CAMPUSES AND EXPECTING
HIM TO ARRIVE. ALLEN CAN WE NEED
TO. WHAT YEAR WE BEGAN ON A TWO
PUNCTURE TO OUR ENROLLMENT.
FIRST WE SAW AND SUCCESSFULLY
SIGNED MEMORANDA OF
UNDERSTANDING INTERFERE HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN CONTACT
CONTACT INFORMATION SO THAT WE
CAN INFORM STUDENTS AND THEIR
PARENTS ABOUT THE EXCELLENT
OPPORTUNITIES COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES. WELL IN HIGH SCHOOL. SO
MUCH OF OUR WORK IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS DEDICATED TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WE
DECIDED TO PARTNER WITH CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY TO SEEK A SIMILAR
PATRICK AFTER REACHING OUT TO
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY MEETING-
EMANCIPATED PAUL YOUTH. REPORTER
COUNTERPOINT AND THOSE WHO ARE
FORMER AND- OR JUSTICE INVOLVED.
LIKE MANY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY WHO OFTEN ARE PAID
UPON BY FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. AND
ULTIMATELY ROCK UP HUGE. KEEPING
ALSO MICHAEL. WHAT DO YOU NEED
CONTACT INFORMATION AND
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF THE
INFORMATION. SORRY WE'RE GONNA
NEED YOU TO WRAP UP TO. FOR ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
REACH OUT AND ENCOURAGE THESE
POTENTIAL STUDENTS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE GREAT
INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT SERVICES
WE HOUSE- AND SO WE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SIX TWO SEVEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DATA SHARING
AND OPEN. ENROLLMENT AND GIVE
OUR COMMUNITY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN AND ATTEND HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
FOR ITS IN OTHER. SO WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHECKED FREQUENTLY DOT
METHYLATION FROM INFANTRY COMBAT
VETERAN. MARKETING AND THAT'S
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICER.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTER. IN
THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ON
SUPPORT. BUT IT BETTER MYSELF I
CAN TELL YOU THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
FOR TRADITIONAL MILITARY. BLACK
BASS. ALLEN BERMAN BEING TOLD.
THE HOME PROGRAM HOW IMPORTANT.
ABOUT INJURY THANK YOU LATER
SERVICED THE FIFTY. SIR MEMBERS
AND FAMILIES ARE ARE- UNAWARE OF
THE BENEFITS. AND IF YOU DEFINE
A REGULAR. THE MORE WAYS WERE
ABLE TO EDUCATE SERVICE MEMBERS
AND VETERANS ABOUT THE FEDERAL
BENEFITS THE MORE WE'RE ABLE TO
SAVE FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.%
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE COLLEGE.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO
FORGET SPACE AND DEFENSE AND
OFFENSE UNDER REPRESENT. YOU CAN
CALL JUDGE VETERANS EARNS
BENEFITS BUT SHOULD BE UTILIZED
AND THEY SHOULD UTILIZE THAT
BENEFIT AND NOT WASTED BECAUSE
OF LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
RESPECTFULLY UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE M. WITH THAT WE
WILL GO. TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SEVEN SIR
POINT DOT OF ON BEHALF OF THE
ANIL ALLEYS GOING YUBA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRICKS ALSO PART OF THE
BILL THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYWAY ELSE IT'S A- IN
THE- FONG. PRESS FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEIR OWN PHONE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. KERN ONLINE THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT AT THIS TIME
WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING IN OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
SIX TO SEVEN. BEING OF THE PHONE
LINES IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN. OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. YOU THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. WITH THAT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE CLINIC. NOW WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON. SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SAYING NINE GREAT BELL
I THINK FOR ME AFFORD YOU MAKE
LESS SPECTACULAR EITHER. I'M
SECTOR OF THE WORLD AB TWO SIX
TWENTY SEVEN MOTION AS YOU PASS
TO THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. APRIL HI GABRIEL I
HIGHLY. HIGHLY AYE BACKING IAN
HI THERE CAN SENATE SENATE I
BURKE. CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU FIVE
FOUGHT. FONG I IRWIN- WHAT I.
MILITARES I WICKS WILL. WILSON
HI. ALL RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
KEVIN. SIX ALL RIGHT. THERE ARE
NONE OF. IT'S DIGITAL. THE BILL
LAST BILL. WATSON CAN TURN. ALL
RIGHT OUR FINAL BILL ISASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIX SEVEN SEVEN- BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR KILEY GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M REALLY
PLEASED 2% AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD CLARIFY
SIMPLIFY AND MODERNIZE THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT TO
BETTER PROTECT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION COLLECTED. BOARD AND
SHARE GOVERNOR AGES. DESPITE
MAJOR ADVANCES IN. TECHNOLOGY
THE INFORMATION PROP IS ACTOR
IPA WHICH GOVERNS THE COLLECTION
USE OR DISCLOSURE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION BY STATE AGENCIES
HAS NOT BEEN MEANINGFULLY
UPDATED SINCE ITS PASSAGE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AS THE
TECHNOLOGY EMPLOYED BY THE STATE
TO BETTER SERVE PEOPLE HAS
BECOME MORE SOPHISTICATED THE
CONDITIONS THE PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED THE I PAY HAVE FALLEN
OUT OF STEP WITH THE TYPES OF
INFORMATION WITH YOU. IN OUR
GOVERNOR. WE HE EVER PLECTRUM
CHANGING WITH IN IN THE TWENTY
FOR CENTURY THIS IS AN UPDATE
THAT IS LONG OVERDUE AB TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
THIS MUCH NEEDED UPDATE BY
AMENDING DEFINITIONS RELATED TO
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE INFORMATION THAT
THAT IS NOT IMMEDIATELY I FIND
INDIVIDUAL CANDY THROUGH
PROCESSING OR COMBINATION WITH
OTHER INFORMATION BE LINKED BACK
. VISUAL FIRE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO ADOPT IT IS ATION
CRACKED. USING PERSON
INFORMATION ONLY FOR THE
PURPOSES FOR WHICH IT WAS
COLLECTED AND CLEARLY INDICATING
THOSE PURPOSES AND LIMITING
DISCLOSURES TO THOSE WHICH
FURTHER THE OBJECTIVES ARE
MANDATES TO THE AGENCIES. THE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVEN MAKE A CENTRAL
CHANGES TO IMPROVE THE
ENFORCEABILITY OF THE IPA BY
RECOGNIZING THE HARMS INHERENT
IN INVASION OF PRIVACY. RATHER
THAN REQUIRING INTENT OR
DEMONSTRABLE ECONOMIC HARM OR
PERSONAL INJURY IN ORDER TO
PENALIZE THOSE WHO VIOLATE ITS
PROVISIONS. FINALLY THIS BILL
WOULD APPLY THE REDUCE THE I. P.
TO LOCAL AGENCIES PROVIDING THE
STATE'S CONFERENCE PRINT. COVER
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
COLLECTED USED A DISK. PLEASE
BRING. MY ACTION FOR THE IN FOR
TO WHICH GOVERNMENT AGENCY AND I
DO WANT TO NOTE THE AMENDMENT ON
PAGE TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH ARE GOING TO ACCEPT TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES FROM ONE YEAR
TO GIVE TO COME. BACK ON IF THE
STAFF AT WORK ON THIS BUT WITH
ME TO TESTIFYING TO OF THE BILL
BECCA CREEPER MATTER
REPRESENTING A SO YOU'RE
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND HIS BE ON
CENTER I LIKE FUNDING THANK YOU
WITH RESPECT THE QUESTION I VOTE
. RIVERSIDE MARAUDER TRANSACTION
IN SUPPORT THE PRIVACY COMMUNITY
HAS LONG APPLAUDED MANY OF THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OF THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT WHILE
ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
DEFICIENCIES IN THE IPA THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED ONE OF THE
BEST CLEARING HOLES IT IS THE
PRIVATE SECURITY SAFEGUARDS ONLY
APPLIED TO INFORMATION HELD BY
STATE AGENCIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXACT FOR MOST OF ITS
REQUIREMENTS YET INFORMATION
HELD BY A LOCAL AGENCY IS NO
LESS SENSITIVE AND NO LESS
BUDGING AFTER THAT'S WHAT. I
SAID YEAH I DID SEND HELD BY A
AID THIS LOW GOVERNMENT
EXEMPTION MAKES NO SENSE AND
UNDERMINES THE VERY IMPORTANT
PROTECTIONS IN THE IPA AB TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD INSTEAD
REQUIRE LOCAL COME THE STATE.
THE PERSON. HAS THE SAME RIGHTS
WEBER HELLO LOCAL AND- OR A C.
H. THIS NOT ONLY A FROM
EFFICIENT INTERACT ACROSS STATE
IT ALSO CLOSES THE GIANT
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS THIRD PARTY
TO BY PASS THE IPA'S PROTECTIONS
OF INFORMATION HELD BUT STATED
IT IS. SIMPLY BY THE SAME
INFORMATION FROM THE EQUIVALENT
LOCAL AGENCY. AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN ALSO MAKES OTHER
IMPORTANT COMMONSENSE UPDATES TO
THE IPA INCLUDING OBTAINING THE
BEST PRACTICES FOR DATA
MANAGEMENT SUCH AS ADDING. AND
MEN'S ARTICLE OVER NEVADA. AND
UPDATING DEATH. THANK FOR AT
PATIENT INFORMATION. AB TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY IS AN IMPORTER FIRST
STEP IN ADDRESSING THE GAPS IN
THE IPA AND FOR THIS REASON WE
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR NET SIZE JOINING
US BY PHONE AND THAT IS THE
LEAST OF YAMA WITH THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU TURKEY
BILL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS HALEY
PANDERING TO HEAR LEGISLATIVE
ACCESS AT THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION IN COURT. AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
NOT. INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT
INTERNET PRIVACY PRACTICES THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND GREATLY
IMPROVE PRIVACY PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THE I. K. WELL
IMPORTANT PRIVACY LAW HAS NEEDED
AN UPDATE FOR SOMETIME TO.
ACTIVELY WITH THE WAY
INFORMATION CLOSE AND A SHARE
TODAY. I'VE WRITTEN TODAY HE ANY
IN THE NEXT. WHICH MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENT AND- BECOME EVEN MORE
CLEAR IN THE WAKE OF THE STATE.
TOOK A MASSIVE BEATING. TO
RESPOND TO THE PAN AND EVALUATE
THE EFFECT ABOUT RESPONSE IT
BECAME CLEAR THAT THE- YEAR HE
CREATES AND WHICH EACH LOCAL HE
CREATE OWN PRIVATE POLICY THAT
WILL. TOOK HOW AND WHERE TO GO
ALL OF.
EIGHT LOCAL AND INCREASE
EFFICIENCY AND PROVIDE THE
STRONGER CARE AND SHE THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING PROCESSED
IN A RESPECTFUL WAY. THE PUBLIC
TRUST OF THE WAY THE STATE OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION. IN
ADDITION TO THE PREVENT ALREADY
MENTIONED ON THE COVER LETTER AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN ALSO AT
THE SEVERAL IMPORTANT FACET OF
THE LAW. THAT IS THE DEFINITION
OF PERSONAL INFORMATION AND IT'S
RECOGNITION OF PRIVACY HARMS
THAT BRING IT UP TO DATE WITH
MORE MODERN PRIVATE. AB SEVENTY
SEVEN NEEDED TO THE IPA. RESPECT
ASK FOR YOUR AYE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES TO
OUR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
PRESS SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE.
IN A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO CLIPS. TURN ON A PLAN
TO CURE ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- WHO'S HERE IN PERSON
AND THAT IS JEFFREY NEIL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF
NEAL WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN- ALSO
PASSING ALONG THE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT'S NEWLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES. CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE INTENT TO THE
BILL- AND THE- AND THE AMENDMENT
DOES ALLEVIATE THE URGENCY OF
OUR CONCERNS BUT IT DOES RELIEVE
US OF THEM ENTIRELY AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS THE WASHINGTON POST
REPORTED THAT. MANY LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE WRAPPED. WITH SMALL
I. T. BUDGETS AGING SYSTEMS AND
LIMITED BUDGETS FOR
CYBERSECURITY FORTUNATELY AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
DOESN'T. THOSE ISSUES IT IMPOSES
A NEW LAYER OF REQUIREMENTS
INSTEAD PROVIDING RESOURCES AND
ASSISTANCE TO MEET ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS. THAT THREATENS
PENALTIES- AND EVEN TERMINATION
FOR UNION EMPLOYEES MY- WORK
THANKS. NEED PLEASE. RUN AFOUL
OF THE I. I'M IN THE SAME WAY
THAT THE C. DOESN'T APPLY TO ME
BECAUSE- AGENCIES. PUBLIC
AGENCIES ARE. DIFFERENT IN SAME
WAY THE I. P. A. IS CLEARLY AS
IF YOU READ THROUGH IT DESIGN
FOR AND RE FOR TO APPLY TO STATE
A- WHICH ARE DIFFERENT FROM
LOCAL AGENCIES. M. THAT STATE
AGENCIES ARE GENERALLY LARGE
THEY RARELY PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC. AND THEY
CAN IF THEY NEED ASSISTANCE- MET
FIGURING OUT EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO THEY CAN DROP INTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
GET THAT SYSTEMS. LOCALLY THESE
ARE DESIGNED BY DIRECT SERVICES
TO THE PUBLIC AND OUR DESIGN.
THIS IS TO SHARE. THEY CALL FOR
SOME ADD TO HELP SOLVE SOME OF
OUR THORNIEST ISSUES FOR.
HOMELESS ONE OR NOT WE'RE GOING
HELP SOMEBODY ARE THEY SIGNED UP
FOR MEDICARE AND HOW MANY TRIPS
TO THE HOSPITAL HOW MANY
AMBULANCE VISITS ARE THEY JUST
AS THE BALL THEY HAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES- THAT YOU SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE CONTACT WITH THEM. BUT
THERE'S A BE ALLOWED UNDER THE
IPA BECAUSE YOU CAN'T USE
SOMEBODY'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
FOR A PURPOSE OTHER THAN WHAT
YOU COLLECTED IT FOR. I AM SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO DISCUSS ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EXISTING EFFORTS AT LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE MAKING OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO TALK. SENATE. OR IT
APPROACHES ADD TO THIS AND OF
THE- BAY. SO OF PROCESS AND HAS
MASON. POSE ON ALL PLAYED
REGARDLESS OF SIZE OR THEY- AT
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IF THERE ARE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK IS THAT WHILE ARMED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
GENERALLY ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES HOWEVER MY ASSOCIATION
DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL OPPOSE
POSITION AT THIS TIME. MERELY A
CONCERNED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN OPERATOR OF YOU DID
WAS OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT
ALL. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IN HAVE DONE ALREADY
DONE SO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION IRELAND
MY COMMENTS WITH MISTER NEAL
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINED UP
ONE FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOROTHY JOHNSON WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION I WENT IN MY COMMENTS
BUT THOSE OF- MISTER NEAL THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE AR NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU HAVING TO
GO TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
MISTER BENNETT. JUST JUST ONE
THAT I CERTAINLY RESPECT THE
AUTHORS TO. EFFORTS WITH THIS
AND I JUST WANT TO OFFER JUST.
THE COMMENTS BEING MADE AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR FOR TWENTY
YEARS WE DID STRUGGLE WITH-
CHALLENGES TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. HOW THAT WAS RESTRICTED
I KNOW YOU HAVE THE BEST
INTENTIONS AND- I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND AS IT MOVES FORWARD IF-
YOU KEEP THAT IN MIND. SIR THANK
YOU. YEAH PRETTY MUCH IF I
MIGHT. MISTER CHAIR NO I AGREE-
I 1000% I THINK YOU KNOW WE HAD
NOT HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
PART OF IMPORTANT PUTTING IN A
LETTER. I STILL HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THEIR
CONCERNS IN A MORE FULSOME
MANNER I AM VERY VERY SENSITIVE
TO THE ISSUE YOU RAISED
HOMELESSNESS IS OBVIOUSLY A TOP
PARTY FOR MINE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED TO DO SO IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER-
YOU KNOW OUR READING OF THE I.
P. RIGHT NOW IT'S AT THEIR
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY X. EXCEPTIONS
WRITTEN INTO THE BILL AND ALL.
OTHER STATE LAW THAT ALLOW THEM
TO DO I AM THEY NEED TO DO BUT
CERTAINLY WANT TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THEM
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS- AND
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE MY- MY FIRM
ASSURANCES THAT THERE'S WE ARE
NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING IN THIS
BELT UNDERMINE OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER SERVICES TO OUR- HOUSE
POPULATION THAT'S A TOPIC. FOR
ME. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO I KNOW YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED WE HAD NOT
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION PRIOR
TO THEM DROPPING THEIR LETTER
BUT- YOU EAGER TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM WE'VE
ALREADY PUT IN THAT THE
FUNDAMENTAL TO DELAY THE
IMITATION FROM AGENCIES TO GIVE
THEM SOME TIME BUT I WILL I WILL
KNOW THAT. THEY WERE UPLOADED TO
PRIOR REGISTRATION ABOUT THE I.
PACE DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION
AND SAID THAT THEY WOULD
STRUGGLE TO COMPLY WITH THAT AND
YOU KNOW WHEN THAT WHEN THAT
WENT INTO TO LAW AND TOOK A FACT
THAT THEY HAVE THEY HAVE MANAGED
TO FIND A WAY TO COMPLY WITH
THAT SO- OPEN TO HAVE CAR- YOU
KNOW TO PUSH THIS BILL FORWARD
AND ALLOW. OUR IMPORTANT WORK
BUT ALSO TO PROTECT CONSUMER
PRIVACY. AND THEN THE FINAL
THING THAT I WOULD SAY JUST MORE
BROADLY IS. YOU KNOW WE FOCUSED
A LOT ON THIS COMMITTEE- IN IN.
IN YOU KNOW ASKING MORE OF OUR
PRIVATE SECTOR BUT- OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR BUSINESSES TO DO MORE. TO
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY. AND I
THINK IT'S FAIR THAT WE ASK THE
SAME OF GOVERNMENT. IT'S FOR THE
WE ASK THE SAME OF OURSELVES AND
SO WE HAVE A STATE LAW HERE
THAT'S ON A LOT OF GOOD. BUT HAS
BEEN UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. BECAUSE I AM. I
AM. I CAN DO SOME.
CLARIFICATIONS AND REVISIONS TO
APPLY TO SIX. CITY STIGMA.
INCREASE I'VE SEEN. FOUR CALVET.
THE WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. WE HAVE NOT
. FRIEDMAN SECOND. OKAY DO
PASSES AMEND UP WITH THE ROLL.
AB TWO SIX SEVEN MOTION DUE PASS
AS A MAN TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GABRIEL HI GABRIEL I
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE BARRICADE IN
THERE CAN I BENNETT. BENNETT I
BERMAN CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
FONG FONG I IRWIN. IRWIN
VALLADARES VALID THERE'S A WICKS. WILSON WILSON I. THIS IS TRUE. I TRIED TO MAKE YOUR BILL
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MR KILEY I
THINK THAT CAN CONCLUDES OUR
BILL PRESENTATIONS WHEN WE TAKE
A SPIN THROUGH- TO ALLOW FOR
FOLKS TO ADD ONS SO MADAM
SECRETARY SHOULD WE GO THROUGH
ONE BY ONE. IT SHOULD BE A GOOD
TIME FOR. ANY ABSENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS TO MAKE AN APPEARANCE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDARKILEY HI
CUNNINGHAM I. FONG FONG HI. AB
TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED KILEY
KILEY AYE BERMAN WICKS. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KILEY KILEY NO BERMAN
WICKS. OKAY OKAY YEAH. WHEN HE
ANNOUNCED SHOULDN'T WAIT THAT.
AB. AB TWO THREE THREE SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TODAY APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTE
KILEY KILEY NO BERMAN FONG FONG
HI AND THAT BILL IS OUT. NINE
TWO ONE. AB NINETEEN OH FOUR
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
KILEY KILEY I BAUER-KAHAN OKAY
AND I BERMAN CUNNINGHAM.
VALLADARES VALIDATORS NOT VOTING
WICKS WILSON WILSON HI. THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO I'M SORRY
YES SEVENTY. AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO MOTION IS DUE PASSED
KILEY. KILEY I BERMAN WICKS. SO
THAT BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KILEY KILEY NO.
BENNETT BENNETT NOT VOTING
BERMAN IRWIN. WHEN I WICKS. MATT
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO. AB
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY NINE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO DID
YOU SHERRY COMMITTEE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING BERMAN.
VALLADARES. I'M AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE VALLADARES I.
MAPPILAS OUT EIGHT ZERO. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KILEY
KILEY I BERMAN WICKS. AND THE
BILL IS OUT NINE TWO ZERO. AB
SEVENTEEN ELEVEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KILEY.
KILEY I BARKIN. THERE CAN AYE
BENNETT BENNETT I BERMAN. WICKS. THE BILL IS OUT NINE TWO ZERO. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND BERMAN. AND THAT BILL IS OUT. NINE ZERO. FIRST. AT THE- OKAY. RIGHT BUT I THINK I GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE PEOPLE EVERYBODY
WANTS. LEVINE AT THIS RESTAURANT. YEAH YOU CAN THAT NUMBER. OKAY. THANKS BURKE WITH THE CHAIR.
TODAY.
MY HONOR YEAH ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GONNA CHANGE. YEAH LET'S GO
AHEAD ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BERMAN BERMAN HI. THE BILL IS
OUT ELEVEN THOSE BILLS ARE OUT
ELEVEN TWO ZERO CONSENT COUNTER
AB TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BERMAN.
BERMAN I THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO
. AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BERMAN
BERMAN I THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ONE. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
BERMAN BERMAN I- THAT BILL IS
OUT TEN ZERO. AB TWO THREE THREE
SIX MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BERMAN BERMAN I THE BILL IS OUT
TEN ONE. AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN BERMAN I THE
BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO. NINETEEN
OH FOUR MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN BERMAN I HAVE
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO. AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY TWO MOTION IS DO
YOU PASS BERMAN. BERMAN I. THE
BILL'S OUT TEN ZERO. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN MOTION IS DO YOU PASS
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BERMAN BERMAN AYE THOSE OUT
SEVEN ONE. LEVINE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BERMAN BERMAN I HAVE
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO. AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN.
BERMAN I THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO
. AB SEVENTEEN ELEVEN MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TODAY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN
BERMAN I THE BILL'S OUT TEN ZERO
. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BERMAN BERMAN I A BILL IS OUT
TEN ZERO. ARE AT THE RIGHT FOR
US THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU MR
BERMAN- WITHOUT ALL OF THE BILLS
ARE OUT OF COMMITTEE I WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK THE
STAFF. A FOR. DEMOCRATS FOR YOUR
EX THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF TO
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY TO THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE- TO OUR
SERGEANTS AND EVERYBODY HOW WITH
TODAY'S HEARING WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK AND NOT.
WITHOUT OUR HEARING IS ADJOURNED.